GOOD AFTERNOON I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO OUR
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
FOR OVERSIGHT HEARING ON B.
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT OR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAM I HAVE ENOUGH
TO READ SOME DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY. LAST TIME I THINK
IT'S THE BATTERY FELL JUST A
BIT ON THE- AS I WAS SAYING- I
HAVE ENOUGH TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY AND OF EVERYONE HERE
TODAY WHILE ALLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THAT
DISCUSSION. TODAY WE ARE IN
ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN. WE ARE
HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON HEARING WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO THAT WE CAN KEEP. SIX
FEET OF SPACING THERE ARE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY MAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS WHEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. BEGINS BUT IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK THEY WILL
RAISE THEIR HAND AND I WILL ASK
THEM TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE ROOM. I
WOULD ASK THE I WOULD ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC RESPECT PHYSICAL
DISTANCE AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. BUT PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITED ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. THE PANELISTS
ON THE AGENDA AND THE- ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING TECH
ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. THERE WILL
BE NO VOTE AND TODAY'S
COMMITTEE HEARING. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING. BOTH IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING THIS
OVER THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER
IS TOLL FREE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
IS FOUR THREE SEVEN ONE. THREE
ONE FIVE IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER. WILL ASSIST YOU. AGAIN
ANOTHER THOSE ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE
DONE WELCOME EVERYONE AND
MEMBERS TO THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE FOR OVERSIGHT
HEARING. OF THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM.
LAST YEAR THIS SUB COMMITTEE
HELD THREE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS
ON EDT. WHICH WAS GREATLY
IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN BY
THE PANDEMIC. I KNOW THAT ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE RECEIVED AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF REQUEST
CALLS AND EMAILS. ON THIS
MATTER MY OFFICE IS NO
DIFFERENT AND WE HAVE DONE THE
BEST WE CAN TO ASSIST.
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE
ARE STRUGGLING. DURING THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TUMULTUOUS TIMES.
I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT
EVERY MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE. DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS AND INDEPENDENTS
HAS HEARD FROM DOZENS IF NOT
HUNDREDS. OR THOUSANDS OF THEIR
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT PROBLEMS
WITH EDT. A STORY MANY MY CALL
MAY ABLE TO IS THAT OF A
CONCERT WHO REACHED OUT TO MY
OFFICE BECAUSE THEY WERE
UNSUCCESSFUL. IN REACHING
EIGHTY TO GET HELP WITH THEIR
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE CLAIM. NO ONE
ANSWERED IN Q. TO SPEAK TO
SOMEONE- BEFORE THEY WERE JUST
HUNG UP ON AFTER SEVERAL MONTHS
OF WORKING WITH MY OFFICE THEY
WERE ABLE TO RECEIVE NEARLY
NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. IN
BENEFITS. THE PET THE PANIC
DESPERATION AND COMPLETE LACK
OF TRUST TOWARDS THE PROCESS
WAS QUITE EVIDENT. JUST EARLIER
THIS MONTH A CONSTITUENT THAT
HAD HER HUSBAND'S CLEAN FROZEN
CONTACTED MY OFFICE FOR
ASSISTANCE. THEY LIVE ANIMAL
TELL BECAUSE THEY LOST THEIR
APARTMENT LAST YEAR. AND HER
HUSBAND SUFFERS FROM A HEART
CONDITION. SHE EXPRESSED TO MY
STAFF THAT SHE HAD. SUICIDAL
THOUGHTS BECAUSE OF THESE
DIFFICULT. I'M SURE I'M NOT THE
ONLY ONE. THAT HAD THIS KIND OF
THIS TYPE OF CALL. I BRING THIS
UP I BRING UP THE STORIES
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HUMAN LIFE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE AT
THEIR END OF THEIR ROPE IN OUR
FRAYED AND NOT GETTING ANY HELP
THAT THEY NEED RIGHT NOW. THE
LACK OF COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
CLAIM INSANITY HAS FRUSTRATED
OUR CONSTITUENTS. AND LEAVES
MANY NOT KNOWING WHAT TO DO
NEXT. OFF THE STATE
CALIFORNIA'S UNEMPLOYMENT WAS
AT ITS PEAK AT 16% IN APRIL AND
MAY OF LAST YEAR. THAT'S
ROUGHLY SIX POINT FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT A JOB.
WITHOUT MEANS WORRIED WONDERING
AND FRIGHTENED ABOUT THE FUTURE.
TO DATE EDT HAS RECEIVED MORE
THAN THIRTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION. APPLICATIONS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN. LAST YEAR WE SAW THE
CLAIMS BACKLOG REACH ONE POINT
SIX MILLION. THIS COMMITTEE WAS
TOLD THAT THE BACKLOG WOULD BE
CLEARED BY TOMORROW THE LATEST
REPORTING SO THAT THE BACKLOG
HAS NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
THOUSAND NINETEEN CLAIMS. ITIS
DIFFICULT TO SEE WHAT THE
PROGRESS HAS BEEN. OR TODAY'S
HEARING WE HAVE ONE PANEL TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSING EDIE'S
BACKLOG PROGRESS ON THE STRIKE
TEAM RECOMMENDATIONS. PROGRESS
ON ROLLING OUT NEW FEDERAL
FUNDS FRAUD AND FROZEN DEBIT
DEBIT CARDS. AND LANGUAGE
ACCESS CHALLENGES. THE HEARING
WILL FOCUS ON IDENTIFYING THE
ISSUES THAT EDT HAS IN ORDER TO
HAS MADE IN ORDER TO FIND-SOLUTIONS. EDT HAS MANY
SIGNIFICANT MISSTEPS SINCE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN AND THE
LEGISLATURE IS IN THE BUSINESS
OF HOLDING ALL DEPARTMENTS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND EIGHTY D. WILL
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. THAT SAID
IT IS ALSO THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT ET IS AN AGENCY THAT HAS
FACED UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES.
GIVEN THEIR MASSIVE CHANGE AND
WORKLOAD. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THE WORKERS
EDT. THE MAJORITY OF WHICH HAVE
ALSO HAD TO ADJUST FROM WORKING
FROM HOME THINGS SAFE AMID A
PANDEMIC. AND PERHAPS ARE ALSO
DEALING WITH THE REALITIES OF
DISTANCE LEARNING FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. AND GENERAL BROADBAND
LIMITATIONS. THAT HAVE IMPACTED
THE ENTIRE STATE. IN CASE YOU
HAVE A HEARD IT TODAY OR IN THE
LONG TIME. WE THANK YOU. WITH
THE ASSEMBLY. AND EIGHTY D.
HAVE A SURE GOAL PROVIDE
BENEFITS TO UNEMPLOYED
CALIFORNIANS QUICKLY SO THAT WE
CAN LIVE SO THEY CAN LIVE THEIR
LIVES WITH DIGNITY TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND THEIR LOVED ONES
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT EDT HAS
ALL THE RESOURCES. TOOLS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO MEET THAT GOAL.
THIS MORNING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR RELEASED AN AUDIT
ON ED'S HANDLING OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
DURING THE CALL THAT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE WILL HOLD A
HEARING ON THAT ALREADY WHICH
IS THE APPROPRIATE VENUE FOR
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
RELEASE OF THE AUDIT INCLUDED.
THE BEST SOLUTION TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT PROBLEMS WE SEE
SPLASHED ACROSS HEADLINES IS
RETURNED TO A STRONG HEALTHY
ECONOMY BUT WE ARE NOT THERE
YET IN THE MEANTIME WE MUST
STOP THE RAMPANT FRAUD THAT IS
COSTING OUR STATE COFFERS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING OUR STATE.
UNEMPLOYMENT SERVICES. MY
OFFICE LIKE MANY OF THE MEMBERS
THAT ARE HERE TODAY. I HAVE
HEARD FROM PEOPLE WHOSE
ACCOUNTS HAVE BEEN FROZEN FOR
LIVING IN MOTELS AND
DESPERATELY IN NEED OF HELP
THEY DON'T NEED THIRTY DAYS TO
WAIT THEY DON'T HAVE THIRTY
DAYS TO WAIT. IN AND THEY
DESERVE BETTER. MYSELF AS WELL
AS WELL AS THE MEMBERS HERE AND
ACROSS OUR LEGISLATIVE BODY
HAVE RECEIVED CALLS FROM PEOPLE
WHO HAVE APPLIED FOR EDT ON IN
SHORT. UNINSURED FOR EDT-
PROTHESIS MONTHS AGO HAVE YET
RECEIVE THEIR FIRST PAYMENT AND
THEREFORE ASK US TO HAVE
ASSISTED FEED THEIR FAMILIES
OVER THE HOLIDAYS. THEY HAVE
BEEN HURT BY A SYSTEM IN NEED
OF MATH TO REFER. OUR TO
PRIORITY HALF BE THE CLAIMS
BACKLOG AND THE REACTION THE
REACTIVATION OF THE FROZEN
ACCOUNTS. ALL PROPOSED REFORMS
MUST ANSWER THE QUESTION. DOES
THIS HELP THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
THE MOST HELP RIGHT NOW.BANK
OF AMERICA HAS THE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY OF OPENING
ACCOUNTS FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
APPROVED CLAIMS AND PROVIDE
PROVIDING THEM WITH DEBIT CARDS.
THE AVAIL TO HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO ALERT PLEINEMENT. AND
POTENTIAL PROBLEMS WITH THEIR
DEBIT CARDS OR ACCOUNTS IN REAL
TIME. B. OF A NEEDS TO OFFER
EDT. ACCOUNT AND DEBIT CARD
HOLDERS THE SECURITY. IT OFFERS
ITS CUSTOMERS AS WELL. I HOPE
TODAY'S TODAY MARKS THE
BEGINNING OF A PARTNERSHIP TO
FIND SOLUTIONS. I DON'T EXPECT
THE WORK TO BE EASY I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AND TODAY'S GUESTS
ON UNDERSTANDING THE SCOPE OF
THE PROBLEM AND OUR OPTIONS AND
MOVING FORWARD WITH A SOLUTION.
WE PLAN TO HAVE A QUESTION AND
ANSWER SECTION AFTER THE PANEL
HAD CONCLUDED WITH THEIR
PRESENTATIONS. I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THIS MOMENT TO OFFER ANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. A
CHANCE TO PROVIDE. ANY OPENING
REMARKS MEMBERS I. ATHEY TRY TO
KEEP HER CALM AND CONCISE AS
POSSIBLE. HELLO WE HAVE TIME
FOR MEMBER QUESTIONS AND PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END. AND UNLIKE.
MISTER SOUTH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND THANK YOU
FOR HOSTING THIS IT'S ALL VERY
IMPORTANT THAT LEGISLATURE AS A
DEEPLY BEEN INVOLVED SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC BACK
IN MARCH AND WE HAD A NUMBER OF
HEARINGS- RELATED TO V. D. AND
IT'S ROLL OUT IN ADDITION TO
WHERE THE BUDGET ITEMS THAT
HAVE OCCURRED AND I KNOW WE
HAVE OUR BUDGET CHAIR MISTER
TEAM HERE AS WELL. WHEN WE DID
THE ADDITIONAL ALLOCATIONS TO
IBIZA FOR THE CALL CENTERS AND
THE HIRING- BUT WITH THAT YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS AND LOOKING AT
DECEMBER I MEAN JUST IN
DECEMBER THERE WAS ONE POINT
SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE
STILL UNEMPLOYED AND A NUMBER
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL
TRYING TO GET THEIR BENEFITS
AND I THINK THAT'S I JUST WANT
TO COMMEND YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING BECAUSE- I LIKE YOU
MENTIONED THERE WAS A-
EMERGENCY AUDIT THAT WE THAT I
AUTHORED LAST YEAR WITH THIRTY
NINE OF MY COLLEAGUES- THAT
CAME OUT TODAY AND WILL WILL BE
DOING. THAT HEARING NEXT WEEK
BUT LIKE YOU I RECEIVED- MANY
PHONE CALLS FROM CALIFORNIANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ASKING-
JUST VERY RECENTLY YOU KNOW
WHEN ACCOUNTS WERE BEING FROZEN
YOU KNOW THEY SAID YOU KNOW I
WENT TO BANK OF AMERICA BANK OF
AMERICA TOLD PETER CONTACT EDT
AND WHEN THEY CONTACT THE D. D.
THEY TOLD THEM TO CONTACT BANK
OF AMERICA SO THERE WAS THIS
FINGER POINTING BACK AND FORTH
AND SO I'M I'M REALLY GLAD THAT
THE COMMITTEE TODAY'S GONNA
DIVE INTO THOSE ISSUES SO THAT
WE GET SOME CONCRETE ANSWERS
FOR CONSTITUENTS AND FOR
CALIFORNIANS. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN WITH THAT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME. TO ATTEND TODAY'S
HEARING AS WELL. THANK YOU
MISTER SALAS MISS PITINO. AND I
BELIEVE WILL HAVE FAMILY TO
THAT ONE TO MAKE. THANK ON
ELEVENTH. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
THINK FOR AND ME TO PURSUE. AND
JOIN YOUR- AS CHAIR OF THE SOME
THIKANA. AND EVERY COMMITTEE.
AND I ALSO WANT I JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR FOLK. ON
SOLUTION AS WE FORWARD TOGETHER.
ADD WHAT HAS BEEN. A TREMENDOUS.
FOR THIS OF. AND FOR SO MANY OF.
CONSTITUENTS AS WE ALL KNOW
OVER THE LAST MANY MONTHS OF
THIS PANDEMIC. EDEA D. HAS
WASTED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
HAS CAUSED HEARTACHE FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS. ARE
AS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY'S
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE I
ALONG WITH THAT SO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WERE HERE TODAY. HAS
SPENT MONTHS AT PUSHING FOR
RESOLUTIONS TO THESE CRITICAL
ISSUES AND- I AM GRATEFUL FOR
THE STEPS THAT ARE E. D. D. HAS
TAKEN. I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE
NEW LEADERSHIP AT EDG- BUT I
DO. STILL FIND MYSELF
FRUSTRATED I THINK LIKE MANY OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS BY THE PACE OF
THE PROGRESS AND- BY THE
SEEMINGLY. NEVER ENDING
REVELATIONS OF. NEW NEW
FAMILIES IN THE DEPARTMENT-
THAT BEING SAID I TOO AM LIKE
THE CHAIR VERY FOCUSED ON
SOLUTIONS AND- FIGURING OUT HOW
DO WE CHART A PATH FORWARD. TO
YOU. I PROVIDE GOOD SERVICE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. FOR CALIFORNIANS-
J. TO I GUESS AT THIS FOR OUR-
AFTER ME MIKE TODAY ARE A TO
FALL. ONE TO GET EIGHT. PICTURE
OF AT THE- AS OUR CARD. AT HOW
MANY. ARE IMPACTED RIGHT NOW
THE FOR AS- AND- WHAT CAN WE
TELL OUR CAN. WHO AS THE CHAIR
NOTED ARE. INCREASINGLY
DESPERATE I'M AND NUMBER Q. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD DIG
INTO. THE FIVE ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT YOU MADE YESTERDAY AROUND
EDT FRAUD- WHICH IS NOW
ESTIMATED TO POTENTIALLY UP TO
TWENTY SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS-
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS DESERVE. A
THOROUGH ACCOUNT OF THE FRAUD
THAT'S BEEN PERPETRATED. AS
WELL AS AN UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT IS EDT DOING TO STOP THAT.
AND WHAT ARE WE COLLECTIVELY
DOING TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
PROSECUTING THESE FRAUDSTERS
AND RECOVERING D. AT DOLLARS
ABOUT. OF CALIFORNIA'S
TAXPAYERS SO I THANK YOU TO OUR
PANELISTS AND THANK YOU AGAIN
MADAM CHAIR. FOR AT. FOR HAVING
ME TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU AND I
BELIEVE A SOMEONE MEMBER CHIU
ALSO HAD COME JUST ONE TO
DOUBLE CHECK. IF NOT WE CAN
FORWARD. NO OKAY AND MY
APOLOGIES I DO THINK THAT IT'S
ABOUT MY BATTERY AND I PAD AND
ALL THE TECHNOLOGY OUT HERE UP
HERE THAT'S CAUSING A LITTLE
BIT OF FEEDBACK- SO LET'S LET'S
GET STARTED. SO LET ME TAKE A
MOMENT TO INTRODUCE THE
PANELISTS TO FIRST BAKER IS.
REDEFINES WHO IS THE NEW
DIRECTOR OF EDT. AND THE SECOND
SPEAKERS WILL BE- CHEST ALAMO
WHO IS THE PRINCIPAL FISCAL AND
POLICY ANALYST WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE. ANALYST'S OFFICE
FOLLOWED BY THE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM BANK OF AMERICA BUT LET'S
GET STARTED WITH. MATH SCIENCE.
YOU HAVE FIVE. FOR OPENING
REMARKS. THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE I'M READY TO SIGN
DIRECTOR OF THE CLINIC
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT AND
BEFORE I WANT TO- THE ASSEMBLY
LITERATURE. AND WHO ARE MEMBERS
OF COMMITTEE FOR THE ELOQUENT
PICTURE OF THE- THAT THE BILL.
ARE OUR OUR REGION COMPLAIN IN
THEIR CUTS. AND I ALSO LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR THE VERY MUCH FOR
THE- OF A HARD STAFF. I'M HERE
TODAY TO FOOD TO GIVE
INFORMATION ON THE TV BACK.
PROGRESS ON THE TEAM READ. IN
STAFF OF REPAIR X. AND UPDATE
FRAUD AND YOU DO PREVENT
MEASURES. RENDON UPDATE ON
UTILITIES WITH BANK OF. WITH ME
TODAY EIGHTY EXACT RECEIVE VERY
CHIEF DEPUTY TO COOPER IN THE-
AND X. AFFAIRS- WILLIAMS DEPUTY
FOR UP. AND DATA AFTER THE
PANEL BE GLAD. NUMBER FORTY
YEAR YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN
BOTH THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTORS MY BACKGROUND HAS
PREPARED ME WELL TO TAKE ON THE
CURRENT CHALLENGES OF EDT THIS
IS THE FOURTH DEPARTMENT THAT I
HAVE SERVED AS DIRECTOR
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
I HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH IT OR
BENEFIT PROGRAMS WHAT THE
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC SECTOR. I
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING IN MY
TIME AT EDG THIS MONTH. I HAVE
SPENT MY TIME LEARNING ABOUT
THE VARIOUS CHALLENGES
CURRENTLY FACING THE DEPARTMENT.
POSING FOR MY FIVE FIVE MILLION
BUCKS I WATCHES I WANT TO SAY
THIS. THIS IS ANOTHER THING
THAT YOU SHOULD KNOW ABOUT ME.
I STARTED MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE
AS A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE. AND I
REMAIN AS FEARS AND DEDICATED
TO SERVING THE WELL BEING OF
THE PEOPLE WE SERVE. AS I HAVE
EVER BEEN. THANK YOU FOR THAT-
MATH SCIENCE I THINK IS THE
HURDLE A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME.
TO CONTINUE SPEAKING ON YOUR
VISION FOR EDT. OKAY IN SHORT
MY VISION FOR EDT RIGHT NOW IS
TO GET PEOPLE HATE. TO STOP THE
FRAUD. TO MODERNIZE EDT SO THAT
WERE CAPABLE OF HANDLING THE
CURRENT PROBLEMS WE HAVE AND
THE PROBLEMS IT WILL HAVE IN
THE FUTURE. OUR THE PANDEMIC
STRUCK EDT AS IT DID ALL THE
OTHER EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE OF
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND YEAH SIMPLY WE WERE NOT
PREPARED. WE'RE NOT PREPARED
FOR THE GLOBAL CRISIS IN THE
EXTORT CRISIS AND EXTRAORDINARY
STRENGTH WAS TESTED. IN THE
EXISTING UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SYSTEM AS YOU MENTIONED WE HAVE
AN AGENT R. I. T. SYSTEM WE
HAVE DONE OUR BEST TO MODERNIZE
IT. BUT WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS ON TOP OF THIS
EXTRAORDINARY STRING AND THE
DEMAND FOR PEOPLE WHO WORRY
NEEDS ARE WIDESPREAD FRAUD.
ORGANIZATIONS OUR CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISES SUCH TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE ECONOMIC
STIMULUS CREATED FOR THOSE HIT
HARDEST BY THE RECESSION. THESE
SOPHISTICATED FRAUD SCHEMES
TARGETED UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
AGENCIES ACROSS THE NATION.
HOLDEN ON THE SUSCEPTIBILITY.
ARE YOU INHERENT IN THE FEDERAL
ENDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM CREATED BY THE TEARS
ACT 94% 95% OF OUR FRAUD WAS IN
THIS PROGRAM. THESE ARE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FACING THE
DEPARTMENT I'VE GOTTEN TO KNOW
THE NEW EXECUTIVE NEWLY
INSTALLED EXECUTIVE TEAM I'M
OPTIMISTIC. TOGETHER WITH THIS
HARD WORKING GROUP OF LEADERS
WE WILL CONTINUE TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO PROBLEMS BROUGHT
BY THIS ONCE IN A LIFETIME
PANDEMIC AND THE ASSOCIATED
ECONOMIC RECESSIONS. WE WILL
IMPROVE OUR OPERATIONS
ESPECIALLY COMMUNICATION WITH
THIS DEPART. BETWEEN THIS
DEPARTMENT OUR CUSTOMERS AND
OUR STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
LEGISLATURE. WILL CONCENTRATE
ON A MORE SEAMLESS CUSTOMER
SERVICE EXPERIENCE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA WORKERS INCLUDING.
MEMETIC THIS PROFESSION CLAIMS
WE INTEND TO RESTORE THE
PUBLIC'S FAITH IN THIS
DEPARTMENT AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS WILL CONTINUE THE
DEPARTMENT'S FOCUS ON
IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. OR VIçT BY
THE NEEDY DISTRACTING AND
IMPROVE THE CURRENT CALL CENTER
EXPERIENCE FOR OUR CUSTOMERS
USING MY BACKGROUND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY WILL IMPROVE THE
CURRENT UNITY TECHNOLOGY AND
MODERNIZE AND BECOME MORE
RESPONSIVE AND EFFICIENT. AND
MOVE THE DEPARTMENT TO USE MORE
MODERN AND RESPONSIVE
TECHNOLOGIES. WE ARE REVIEWING
OUR BUSINESS PROCESSES FOR THE
CURRENTLY EXIST AND WERE
CREATED APARTMENT. INCIDENTS OF
ALL OF OUR CUSTOMERS
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
INSTITUTING NECESSARY
IMPROVEMENTS DEPARTMENT MOVED
TO MEET OUR CURRENT AND FUTURE
CHALLENGES. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MATH SCIENCE DOES TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. SURE WE CAN OPEN
WEAKENED CAN THANK HIM A SITES
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
OUR NEXT PANELIST AND- MEMBERS
WILL HAVE QUESTIONS- COMBINED.
THE SECOND SPEAKER IS- CHAS
ALAMO WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHADEMA WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR
YOU PLEASE CONTINUE FIVE
MINUTES FOR OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU ON OUR OFFICE
PRODUCED A HAND OUT- AT THE
REQUEST OF STAFF FOR THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING IT'S
AVAILABLE ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AS WELL AS AT OUR
OFFICES WEBSITE- HOPE TO SPUR
BUT A QUICK OVERVIEW ON RECENT
WORKLOAD- SOME DYNAMICS WITH
THE EDT BACKLOG AND TALK A BIT
ABOUT STEPS RECENTLY TAKEN TO
ADDRESS POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS- SO FIRST REGARDING
WORKLOAD. AT THE NUMBER OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
APPLICATIONS SUBMITTED EACH
WEEK HAS DECLINED FROM THE PEAK
LEVELS SEEN IN THE SPRING- BUT
DESPITE THIS SLOWDOWN- CURRENT
WORKLOAD REMAINS ABOUT FIVE
TIMES HIGHER THAN TYPICAL AT
SORT OF NON ECONOMIC RECESSION
PERIODS SO. UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THE DEPARTMENT
GETS ABOUT FIVE FIFTY THOUSAND
YOU AYE CLAIMS PER WEEK OUR
MINUTES CURRENTLY RECEIVING
AROUND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND PER
WEEK SO THIS GOES TO SHOW JUST
AS AN EXAMPLE THAT WORKLOAD
REMAINS RELATIVELY. ELEVATED
EDT- OUR HEAD OUT A BRIEF TIME-
OF THE MAJOR EVENTS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED AT E. D. I SENSE A
PANDEMIC BEGAN AND I WILL GO
THROUGH THEM IN DETAIL BUT I
WANT TO POINT OUT TO CRITICAL
STEPS IN OUR VIEW- THAT TOOK
PLACE IN SEPTEMBER I THINK
HELP. INFORM THE CONVERSATION
HERE FOR TODAY AND THE FIRST
WAS THE INSTITUTION OF- TWO
MAJOR STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HE BE THE
pWHERE EXPERIENCED STAFF TO TURN
TO WORKING DOWN BACKLOGGED
CLAIMS DURING THE RESET THE
DEPARTMENT DID NOT ACCEPT AND
PROCESS NEW CLAIMS ON AND
DURING THE RESET THE DEPARTMENT
ALSO INSTITUTED A NEW IDENTITY
VERIFICATION SOFTWARE TOOL
CALLED ID ME. THAT WE'LL BE
HEARING MORE ABOUT. ON ALSO IN
SEPTEMBER INDEPENDENT OF THE
STRIKING RECOMMENDATIONS EDT
BEGAN TO NOTICE WHAT LOOKED
LIKE A SUSPICIOUS JUMP IN
ACTIVITY FOR INCOMING CLAIMS
FOR THE FEDERAL P. YOU A
PROGRAM THE PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
LARGELY FOR SELF EMPLOYED
WORKERS. AND AT THE TIME THEY
FLAG YES WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR AND AT. REQUESTED IN FACT
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR IN
WASHINGTON TO GET APPROVAL TO
STOP AUTOMATICALLY APPROVING
BACKDATED P. WAY CLAIMS SO
CLAIMS WERE COMING IN IN
SEPTEMBER. AND THEY WERE-
CLAIMING UP WEEKS OF P. WAY
BENEFITS INCLUDING THE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLAR WEEKLY OUT ON
GOING BACK EIGHT NINE TEN
TWELVE WEEKS ON END AT THE TIME
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS OTHER
STATES WERE AUTOMATICALLY
APPROVING THESE BACKDATED
CLAIMS THAT WERE INCOMING. EDT
FELT THAT THIS POTENTIALLY
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY REQUESTED
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR TO
NO LONGER AUTOMATICALLY BACK
DATE THE FIRST TOUCH BASE AND
VERIFY THE IDENTITY OF THAT
CLIMATE BEFORE AUTOMATICALLY
BACKDATING. DEPARTMENT LATER
APPROVED EDT STEP AND IN FACT
THE NEXT WEEK ENCOURAGE OTHER
STATES TO SET UP A SIMILAR
INSTANCES WHERE WE COULD
POTENTIALLY SLOW SOME OF THESE
POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
INCOMING I'M AND I POINT THIS
OUT TO GIVE THE DEPARTMENT
CREDIT FOR NOTICING THIS TREND
OF FIRST IN THE AND IN THE U.
S. AS STATUS. AS FAR AS WE KNOW
AND SETTING UP STEPS TO LIMIT
THAT ACTIVITY ON THEIR BREAK UP
IS TWO POINT SINCE SEPTEMBER
BECAUSE THE FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY
THAT WE'LL DISCUSS LATER
LARGELY IN LARGE PART HAS TO DO
WITH CLAIMS THAT WERE PROCESSED
PRIOR TO THIS PERIOD WHEN IT ME
WAS SET UP AND WHEN ON DVD
STOPPED AUTOMATICALLY
BACKDATING. AUTOMATIC CLAIMS.
I'M TURNING TO THE BACKLOG IN
SEPTEMBER THE STRIKE TEAM
IDENTIFIED ONE POINT SIX
MILLION CLAIMS THAT WERE IN THE
THAT YOU AYE BACKLOG MEANING
THEY WERE MORE THAN THREE WEEKS
DELAYED ARM AND IT OVER THE
FALL THERE WAS SOME INITIAL
SUCCESS ON BEHALF THE
DEPARTMENT AND IN ADDRESSING
THE BACKLOG THAT THE BACKLOG
FELL TO ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CLAIMS IN MID NOVEMBER
BUT IN RECENT MONTHS THE NUMBER
OF CLAIMS THE BACKLOG HAS BEGUN
TO INCH UPWARD AGAIN I THINK AS
AS WAS MENTIONED AND- THE
CHAIRS INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS-
THE BACKLOG IS NOW IDENTIFIED
IT ALMOST ONE MILLION CLAIMS AT
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
CLAIMS. AS OF THIS WEEK EVD HAS
BEEN CLEAR THAT MANY OF THE
CLAIMS IN THE U. I. BACKLOG ARE
SIMPLY CLAIMS FOR WHICH EDT IS
AWAITING A RESPONSE FROM THE
CLAIMANT- OBVIOUSLY WHAT WILL
WANT TO LEARN MORE ABOUT EASY
STEPS TO COMMUNICATE WITH
CLAIMANTS. BUT IT COULD BE THE
CASE THAT EITHER THESE CLAIMS
WERE ABANDONED OR THEY WERE
POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT AND SO
RESPONSE HASN'T COME. TURNING
TO FRAUDULENT CLAIM ACTIVITY-
OBVIOUSLY. A LOT OF INFORMATION
HAS COME TO LIGHT IN THE LAST
TWENTY FOUR HOURS- BUT SORT OF
TAKING A STEP BACK FROM FROM
BOTH THE AUDIT SECRETARY SUSE
COMMENTS YESTERDAY ABOUT FRAUD
A COUPLE THINGS WE WANTED TO
POINT OUT TO BE REALLY CLEAR
ABOUT. THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
ACTIVITY. ON AT PDT RIGHT NOW
HAVE TO DO WITH THIS NEW
PROGRAM FOR SELF EMPLOYED
WORKERS P. WAY. OUT AND WE
POINT THIS OUT BECAUSE THIS
PROGRAM IS GOVERNED BY FEDERAL
LAW AND FEDERAL GUIDANCE THAT
AS WE UNDERSTAND THE STATE
FOLLOWED. FRAUDULENT CLAIMS IN
THIS IN THIS PROGRAM ARE NOT
CONTAINED CALIFORNIA THEY'RE
AFFECTING YOU I PROGRAMS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. AND ADDITIONALLY
THAT THIS PROGRAM IS 1100%
FEDERALLY FUNDED I DON'T MEAN
TO MAKE LIGHT OF FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS- BUT RATHER THAT THESE.
THE POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT
ACTIVITY IS NOT EXCLUSIVELY
CONCENTRATED IN THE STATE'S YOU
I TRUST FUND- BUT RATHER AT
THAT THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND.
I'M AN. FINALLY TURNING TO
SERVE A COUPLE POINTS WE WANTED
TO MAKE ABOUT RECENT STEPS AT
EDT TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
CLAIMS I'M AT THE END OF LAST
YEAR EDT REVIEWED ABOUT TEN
MILLION OF THESE P. UA CLAIMS
THAT IDENTIFIED ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION OF THEM. AS POTENTIALLY
FRAUDULENT. ON THE POTENTIALLY
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS WERE
SUSPENDED BY EDT AT THAT TIME.
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT CLEAR TO US
YET WHAT INFORMATION OR
CRITERIA THE DEPARTMENT USED TO
IDENTIFY THE CLAIMS I'M
NOTIFICATIONS ABOUT THE
SUSPENDED CLAIMS WERE SENT OUT
IN EARLY JANUARY. AS TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE HE DID NOT NOTIFY
CLAIMANTS BUT FOR THEIR CLAIMS
WERE SUSPENDED. THE CLAIMS THAT
WERE FLAGGED AS POTENTIALLY
FRAUDULENT ARE SUSPENDED UNTIL
THE CLAIMANT'S IDENTITY CAN BE
VERIFIED SO WE UNDERSTAND THE
MAJORITY THESE CLAIMS SORT OF
PREDATE THAT SEPTEMBER PERIOD.
SO THESE CLAIMS ARE FLOWING
BACK THROUGH THE IDEA ME
PROCESS- IN ORDER TO VERIFY THE
IDENTITY OF THE CLAIMANTS. AT
THIS POINT WHAT WE DON'T KNOW.
WE BELIEVE IT'S TOO SOON TO
KNOW HOW MANY LEGITIMATE CLAIMS
WERE SUSPENDED AT THE END OF
DECEMBER BOB FOR BEING
POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT WE KNOW
THAT SOME WORKERS HAVE COME
FORWARD WITH COMPLAINTS THEIR
ACCOUNTS WERE SUSPENDED- BUT IN
THE COMING WEEKS WE SHOULD HAVE
A BETTER PICTURE. OF WHAT SHARE
OF. THE POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS THAT WERE SUSPENDED BY
EDT- IN FACT BELONG TO
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS. AND THE
REASON WE BRING THIS UP IS. IS
BECAUSE IT IT RAISES IN OUR
VIEW SOME CONCERN ABOUT EDIE'S
SELF ASSESSMENT IN ADDRESSING-
THE IMPLEMENTATION
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE STRIKE
TEAM REPORT RELATED TO FRAUD
SPECIFICALLY- R. I WILL QUOTE
ONE RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
STRIKE TEAM REPORT THAT ET HAS.
LISTED AS COMPLETED ON THEIR
ONLINE TRACKER- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT QUOTE
EDT CULTURE MUST SHIP FROM
REACTIVITY. TO RATIONALITY AS
IT RELATES TO FRAUD AND QUOTE
AND TO DO SO. COMPLETING THIS
RECOMMENDATION QUOTE. FRAUD
PREVENTION AND DETECTION
PRACTICES MUST BE SUPPORTED BY
DATA AND EVIDENCE AND THAT
JUSTIFICATION FOR NEW AND
EXISTING ANTI FRAUD PRACTICES.
INCLUDE AN ANALYSIS NOT ONLY OF
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS BUT ALSO
TRADE OFFS AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THESE PRACTICES
INCLUDING ADVERSE IMPACTS ON
THE EXPERIENCE OF ALL CLAIMANTS.
DURING THIS POINT UP BECAUSE
IT'S UNCLEAR AT THIS POINT IF
EDT WENT THROUGH THE FULL
PROCESS OF EVALUATING THE
POTENTIAL EFFECTS OF ITS STEPS.
TO ADDRESS FRAUD AT THE END OF
DECEMBER AND THOSE POTENTIAL
EFFECTS ON ON POTENTIALLY
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS- IT MAY BE
THE CASE EIGHTY ONE CORRECT
DOESN'T SENSE OF PROGRESS. BUT
AT THIS POINT OUR OFFICE HAS
NOT BEEN MADE AWARE OF IT- AND
WE WANTED TO RAISE THIS ISSUE
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS
SOME QUESTIONS- TO THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THEIR PROCESS.
IN DETERMINING- THE STOCKS THEY
WOULD TAKE THE LATITUDE TO
THESE POTENTIALLY FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS AT THE END OF OUR HAND
OUT WHICH I ACT AGAIN IF YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU INCLUDES.
NOT ONLY THAT QUESTION BUT
SEVERAL OTHER QUESTIONS THAT WE
THINK THE COMMITTEE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER- AS IT AS IT HERE'S
MORE FROM. DEPARTMENT AND FROM
BANK OF AMERICA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER ALAMO
THERE WAS VERY INSIGHTFUL. A
GIVEN THAT WE HAD SOME
DIFFICULTIES WITH TECHNOLOGY
EARLY ON I DO WANT TO GIVE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. GIVE REMARKS
JUST IN THE EVENT THAT WE WILL
DO SOME AGAIN DUE TO SOME TECH
PROBLEMS. SO IF WE CAN GO TO MR
CHIU PLACE. AND I KNOW THERE'S
A LITTLE BIT OF A MANAGER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. GREAT GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND- LET ME
JUST START BY BY THANKING
EVERYONE FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
AND DOC I PARTICULARLY WANT TO
WELCOME THE NEW EDT DIRECTOR TO
HER FIRST BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING- AND THANK HER FOR
TAKING ON ONE OF THE JOBS IN
GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA- I THINK MANY OF US
ARE WE'RE ALL COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR NEW
LEADERSHIP TO FIGURE OUT
SOLUTIONS TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
AND REALLY APPRECIATE- THE
CHAIR THIS COMMITTEE ALSO FOR
HER- HER VERY QUICK IMMEDIATE
ENGAGEMENT- I THINK THE MOMENT
SHE BECAME CHAIR ON ON HELPING
ALL OF US- THINK OF HOW WE WILL
WORK TOGETHER TO TACKLE THIS.
OF MEDICARE IF IT'S OKAY I'D
LOVE TO ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS
TO THE EDT AFTER I KNOW I THINK
WE'RE ALL ANXIOUS TO HEAR FROM
BANK OF AMERICA BUT WOULD LOVE
TO JUST- THEY WERE JUST A
COUPLE OF A FRAMING QUESTIONS
AND WONDERING IF THAT IS. IN
ORDER AT THIS POINT. OTHER
MEMBERS HAD QUESTIONS AS WELL
WE'RE DOING AT THE END OF THE
PANEL SO WE WILL CONTINUE OKAY
BANK OF AMERICA AND THEN AT THE
END WILL DO THE ENTIRE PANEL
FOR QUESTIONS. THAT IS FINE SO
I'LL JUST SAY- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY. I'LL BE ASKING WELL-
WILL BECOME A LOT OF SUBJECTS
WE COVER IN THE PAST BUT LOOK
FOR THE CONVERSATION AND-
EAGERLY AWAITING- THE TESTIMONY
FROM BANK OF AMERICA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER TO LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT PANELIST WE HAVE
THREE REPRESENTATIVES FROM BANK
OF AMERICA. WE HAVE- FAIZ AHMAD
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF
TRANSACTION SERVICES WOULD BE
OF A- AND OTHER FOLKS ON HIS-
IT'S ONLY HIM APOLOGIES WE HAVE
ONE INDIVIDUAL BANK OF AMERICA
MISTER AHMAD ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. YES I'M I'M HERE BUT I'M
SURE. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU YES OKAY THANK YOU SO
MEDICARE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTIONS. I'M ACTUALLY
JOINED BY TWO OF MY COLLEAGUES
JOHN POLLARD LEADS OR MUNICIPAL
FINANCE BUSINESS THAT OVERSEES
THE CLIENT RELATIONSHIP WITH
EDT. AND ALSO BILL FOX THE HEAD
OF ORACLE FINANCIAL CRIMES
COMPLIANCE AND OPERATIONAL RISK
TEAM. A FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE
FINANCIAL CRIMES ENFORCEMENT
NETWORK. DURING OUR DISCUSSION
WE WILL DO OUR BEST TO HELP YOU
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO SUPPORT EDT FOR
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS. AND TO
ADDRESS THE LEVEL OF CRIMINAL
FRAUD PROGRAM IS EXPERIENCING.
BANKAMERICA STUDENTS FROM
AUTUMN I'M SO SORRY TO
INTERRUPT CAN WE HAVE YOU TO
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT LOUDER INTO
YOUR MICROPHONE PLACE. SURE
IT'S BETTER THANK YOU. OKAY
BANK AMERICA HAS BEEN THE
PREPAID DEBIT CARD PROVIDER FOR
THE STATE OF BUT A PROGRAM FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE. WE'RE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH EDT
TO DELIVER MUCH NEEDED BENEFITS
TO QUALIFY CALIFORNIANS. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY WE
HAVE HAD TO ENGAGE THE DIRECTOR
SIGNS IN HER BRIEF TIME IN
OFFICE AND WITH OUR TEAM OVER
THE PAST YEAR TO WORK TOGETHER
ON THE PROGRAM WE LOOK FORWARD
TO A LONG. AND CONSTRUCTIVE
PARTNERSHIP. THE OTHER THE EDT
WE SHARE. THE SAME OBJECTIVES.
ENSURING THAT BALLOT CLAIMANTS
RECEIVE TIMELY SUPPORT. AND TO
MINIMIZING AND MITIGATING THE
LEVEL OF CRIMINAL FRAUD WE ARE
SEEING PROTECT THE PROGRAM. I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT IMPORTANT
POINTS. THE CRIMINAL FRAUD IN
THIS PROGRAM IS NOT UNIQUE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A SERVICE
PROVIDER FOR SEVERAL OTHER
STATES. AND FRAUD IS
CHALLENGING UNEMPLOYMENT
PROGRAMS EVERYWHERE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. THE SIZE AND SCALE THE
pSUBSTANTIAL FRAUD. INCLUDING
CRIMINALS WERE FRAUDULENTLY
ATTEMPTING TO CLAIM BENEFITS.
IT IS OUR ASSESSMENT THAT THERE
IS SOPHISTICATED CRIMINAL
NETWORK ACTIVITY INVOLVED IN
THIS HAS BEEN ASSESSED BY ALL
OF THE THIRD PARTY SPECIALISTS
AS WELL. AGAINST THIS BACKDROP
WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH EDT
TO MEET THESE CHALLENGES.
PENTAGRAMMIC BEGAN WE'VE ISSUED
MORE THAN NINE MILLION DEBIT
CARDS. INVOLVING MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED BILLION IN BENEFITS THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM. ON BEHALF
OF THE EDT. WE HAVE THOUSANDS
OF EMPLOYEES ASIDE TO SUPPORT
EDT AND CLIMATES. THIS INCLUDES
NEW PROCESSES FOR EXPEDITING
HANDLING FOR CLAIMANTS AND
SEARING INFORMATION ET ABOUT
FRAUD STRATEGY. THE TRUCK ONCE
IT'S BEEN FREEZING CARDS
BROTHER CONCERNS LISTED
CARDHOLDER WAS NOT ENTITLED TO
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AT ALL. I
KNOW WE WILL DISCUSS THAT MORE
DETAILS. BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
FROZEN ACCOUNTS REPRESENT
FRAUD. BUT WERE STOPPED
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OR BILLIONS OR MORE IN
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. I HAVE A
REGULAR ENGAGED WITH EDT TO
INCREASE ACCOUNTS WHERE WE
CAN'T. YOU'RE WORKING HARD IN
OUR DISCUSSING WAYS TO CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE THAT PROCESS. BANK
AMERICANS TAKE A NUMBER OF
STEPS ON ITS OWN. WE HAVE THE
OBLIGATION TO MITIGATE FRAUD
UNDER VARIOUS FEDERAL
REGULATIONS AND STATUTES AND
REPORT SUSPECTED CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY THAT FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES. THE BANK HAS BEEN
ACTIVE IN DOING SO. THROUGHOUT
OUR FOCUS AFFECT AMERICANS NOT
SERVING BUDGET EMIT UNEMPLOYED
AT FISHERIES. AND MINIMIZING
THE IMPACT OF CRIMINAL FRAUD ON
A SIGNIFICANT SCALE SCALE. I
KNOW WE SHOULD FOCUS WITH EDT
AND WITH ALL OF YOU. THANK YOU
TO BE HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MISTER AHMAD WE ACTUALLY HAVE
ONE MORE SPEAKER. AND BEFORE WE
PROCEED WITH NUMBER QUESTIONS
FOR THE ENTIRE PANEL THE LAST
BIGGER IS SENT TO SERENA
SANTANA LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
WITH THE CHINESE FOR CHINESE
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. IS MISS
ANNA. IS INDIVIDUAL ON THE LINE.
THIRRING SANTANA ON THE LINE.
ONE MOMENT. SHE'S IN THE REMOTE.
SHE NEEDS TO UN MUTE SHE'S IN
THE HEARING ROOM. WE GET HER.
WONDERFUL TECHNOLOGY. I BELIEVE
YOU JUST NEED TO START SPEAKING
AND THEN WILL BE ABLE TO HEAR
FROM YOU. IF GIVEN A MINUTE
WHILE WE FIGURE THIS PIECE OUT.
YOU JUST HAVE TO ON MUTE
YOURSELF IF YOU'RE IN THE IF
YOU'RE IN THE ROOM. THE
SERGEANTS JUST FIGURED IT OUT
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M CENTER CERAM
SANTANA WHICH CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION I WANTED TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEYOND A PART OF THIS PANEL.
CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
IS A CIVIL RIGHTS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION THAT WAS
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE.
AND LANGUAGE ACCESS IS ONE OF
OUR CORE- ISSUES THAT WE WORK
ON BOTH THE PROVIDING DIRECT
SERVICES AND IN ADVOCACY. WE
ARE CURRENTLY. CAN I GO ON OR
IS THERE YES SORRY ABOUT THAT
PLEASE GO ON OKAY OKAY SURE OF.
A CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH A COALITION OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN LOS ANGELES THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA ON BARRIERS
CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYED WORKERS
ARE FACING WHEN THEY ATTEMPTED
TO ACCESS THEIR EDT
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WITH
LITTLE TO LIMITED. OR NO
PROFICIENCY IN ENGLISH. IN
THESE DISTINCT REGIONS OF THE
STATE. WE SEE CALIFORNIA
WORKERS EXPERIENCING SIMILAR
CHALLENGES. LANGUAGE BARRIERS
AN OVER RELIANCE ON TECHNOLOGY
DRIVEN SERVICES AND A LACK OF
PLAYING A LACK OF CLEAN OR LACK
OF INFORMATION IN PLAIN
LANGUAGE AT THE EDT THAT
COMBINE TO CREATE A TSUNAMI OF
EXCLUSION FOR CALIFORNIANS FROM
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
RESIDENTS. THESE THREE FACTORS
COMBINED WITH LOW LITERACY
RATES ALSO HAVE LED TO
EXPLOITATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
WORKERS WHOSE DOMINANT
LANGUAGES ARE NOT ENGLISH OR
SPANISH. THERE HAS BEEN MUCH
EMPHASIS AS WE'VE SEEN- ON
FRAUD AND FRAUD PREVENTION.
THESE HEARING IN THESE PUBLIC
HEARINGS WITH EDT. LANGUAGE
ACCESS IS FRAUD PREVENTION AND
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES LET ME
JUST SAY THAT AGAIN LANGUAGE
ACCESS IS FRAUD PREVENTION IN
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES WHEN
EDT IS INACCESSIBLE TO
APPLICANTS WHO HAVE LIMITED TO
NO PROFICIENCY IN ENGLISH.
THESE THIS PAVES A PATH FOR
PEOPLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THEM WE HAVE SEEN THIS HAPPEN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF WHERE
AN INDIVIDUAL IS LOCKED OUT OF
THE SYSTEM AND THEY ARE
APPROACHED BY SOMEONE WHO
PASSES HIMSELF OFF AS AN EXPERT
FOR AN EXORBITANT FEE THEY WILL
SUBMIT THE CLAIM FOR THEM TAKE
A PERCENTAGE OF WHATEVER COMES.
AND THEY END UP THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND UP KEEPING THE
APPLICANT'S PASSWORD AND
PERSONAL INFORMATION. WHEN
THESE UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS
SUBMIT A CLAIM THAT HAS AN
ERROR IT IS THE WORKER THE
FACES THE HEART CONSEQUENT
HARSH CONSEQUENCES- THEY
WITHOUT LANGUAGE ACCESS AT EDT
THEY CAN'T CLEAR UP THIS
MISTAKE IF THEY CAN'T REPORT IT
THEY CAN'T EXPLAIN IT AND- IT
JUST PROVIDES A HOST OF
CHALLENGES FOR. OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. WELL THERE IS A HUGE
BACKLOG AT THE EDT. MANY OF
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
CANNOT EVEN SAID THAT A CLAIM
BECAUSE OF THE POOR ACCESS FOR
LANGUAGE ACCESS AT EDT. THIS IS
EXACERBATED BY COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE LOW LEVELS OF LITERACY AND
SMALLER LINGUISTIC GROUPS. THE
FASTEST WAY TO APPLY FOR EDT
BENEFITS IS ON THEIR ONLINE
PORTAL. ON THEIR WEBSITE.
HOWEVER THE ONLY PORTAL IS ONLY
IN ENGLISH AND SPANISH THERE
ARE OVER TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO SPEAK A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH AND
SPANISH RESIDING IN THE STATE.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS- CAN ALSO
APPLY ON THE TELEPHONE HOWEVER
THE PHONE LINES HAS BEEN
IMPENETRABLE AS REALLY
LINGUISTICALLY INACCESSIBLE. IF
AN INDIVIDUAL IT DOES CALL AND
THEY GET A LIVE OPERATOR THE
LANGUAGES PROVIDED ARE IN
ENGLISH AND SPANISH. AT
INDIVIDUALS- CAN ALSO APPLY FOR
BENEFITS ON PAPER HOWEVER THE
APPLICATION IS ONLY IN ENGLISH
AND SPANISH. THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTE SOMETIME IF I
COULD JUST ASK FOR YOU TO WRAP
YOUR COMMENTS PLEASE- THERE ARE
MANY SO I WILL SUBMIT MY
WRITTEN. COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE WANTED TO
POINT OUT THE GOOGLE TRANSLATE
DOES NOT WORK- THE ANALYSIS
NOTES THAT EDT PROVIDES A
HUNDRED IN EIGHT LANGUAGES IN
GOOGLE TRANSLATE. AND GOOGLE
TRANSLATE IS- IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE IT IS A LITERAL WORD
FOR WORD TRANSLATION THERE'S NO
CONTEXT AND IN TRANSLATION
CONTEXT IS EVERYTHING- IN AND
OUT COMPLICATED APPLICATION
PROCESS THAT'S HIGH STAKES.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT A
MACHINE TRANSLATION NOT BE USED
SO THE BY ITSELF BUT HAVE HUMAN
REVIEW- I WILL SUBMIT THE REST
OF OUR WE HAVE A WHOLE SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I DIDN'T
GET TO AND WE WILL SUBMIT THIS
TO YOUR STAFF TO UP UP FOR TO
BE ON THE PUBLIC RECORD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE THE INSIGHT ON THE
LACK OF. CULTURAL LINGUISTIC.
ACCESS TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR THAT THIS TIME
WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP. FOR Q. AND
A WITH THE MEMBERS AND I HAVE
MISTER SALAS THE FIRST FOLLOWED
BY MISS PETRI NORRIS THAN. A
MISCUE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND I THINK
THE FIRST ONE IS FOR- MISS
SIGNS OVER AT EDT. YOU KNOW I
WAS JUST TRYING TO GET SOME
CLARITY ABOUT THE FLUCTUATING
YOU YOU Y. CLAIM NUMBERS- THAT
EDT RECENTLY REPORTED. FOR
INSTANCE WHEN I LOOKED AT THE
WEBSITE ON JANUARY NINTH EDIE'S
WEBSITE SAID THERE WAS A
HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT. ADDITIONAL CLAIMS
AWAITING PAYMENTS. BUT THEN THE
VERY NEXT DAY THAT NUMBERS TO
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND. AND FORTY FOUR THEN
TEN DAYS AFTER THAT IT REACHED.
NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE. SO I JUST WANT TO
KNOW WHY THAT BACKLOG. OF
CLAIMS HAS GROWN SO MUCH IN
JUST A COUPLE OF. WITHIN TWO
WEEKS. AND WHY THAT'S THE CASE
AND TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM. EXCELLENT
QUESTION. I WANT TO HAVE THIS
DOUBLE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO GIVE A GENERAL EXPLANATION
AND THEN- ONE OF MY CREEK
DEPUTIES WILL PROVIDE MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION SO YES
CURRENT AS OF JANUARY TWENTIETH
THE CURRENT BACKLOG SHOWS
ACCOUNT OF ROUGHLY NINE
THOUSAND NINE MILLION. AND MY
EX ME. IT FEELS NINE MILLION
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
THOUSAND UNIQUE CLAIMANTS SO WE
NEED TO CLARIFY THAT NUMBER.
THE CURRENT INITIAL CLAIMS
DASHBOARD CONTAINS A CATEGORY
CALLED WAITING FOR CLAIMANTS
CERTIFICATION. WHICH REPRESENTS
ACTIONS REQUIRED BY THE
CLAIMANT. IN ORDER FOR EDG TO
CONTINUE. THE CLAIM IT NEEDS TO
SPLIT APART TO SUBMIT THEIR
FIRST BI WEEKLY CERTIFICATION
FOR. WE DETERMINED AND EVERY
TWO WEEKS AFTER SO IN THE FIRST
PLACE WE NEED A BETTER
DASHBOARD THAT'S OBVIOUS. CAROL
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO
SAY ABOUT THAT. YES THANK YOU
SO MUCH BECAUSE THE- THE PART
THAT WE REALLY ARE TRYING TO
EXPLAIN. IS ARE THE CATEGORIES
ON THE STRIKE TEAM DASHBOARD IN
OUR EVOLUTION INTO A SMARTER-
MORE FREIGHT DASHBOARD IN THE
COMING WEEKS 91% OF THE NINE
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND. I
CLAIMS PEOPLE ON THAT THE
PASSPORT WE ARE LITTLE. WAITING
FOR THEM TO CERTIFY THERE'S A
NUMBER OF EFFORTS THAT WE'VE
BEEN UNDERTAKING IN THAT SENSE
THE FALL TO ENSURE EVERY CLAIM
IT KNOWS THE PROCESS YES IT'S
OVERLY COMPLICATED WE CERTAINLY
NEED TO SIMPLIFY IT BUT THEY
HAVE TO CERTIFY INITIALLY AND
COME BACK EVERY TWO WEEKS. AND
IT'S THE RETURN OF EVERY TWO
WEEKS THAT UP. WE'RE TRYING TO
GET IN THERE ALL THAT KNOWLEDGE
GAP. SO CLOSE- FIND EMPLOYMENT
IN THE ABANDONED THEIR CLAIM
AND THOSE. THANK WILL STAY ON
THE DASHBOARD FOR THIRTY DAYS-
FOLKS ARE UNAWARE THAT THEY
HAVE TO RETURN AND WE ARE NOW%
MAKE NOT NOW WE STARTED THIS IN
THE FALL AS YOU KNOW MAKING
OUTBOUND CALLS EVERY SINGLE DAY
THE CLAIMANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY KNOW THAT THEY HAVE TO
RETURN IT'S NOT OKAY FOR THEM
TO JUST SIT FOR THOSE. CLAIMS
TO SIT ON THE DASHBOARD WERE
ACTIVELY AND PROACTIVELY TRYING
TO ENSURE THAT IF THEY'RE THERE
IT'S BECAUSE THE INCLUDING
ABANDONED THEM BUT THE INCREASE
IN THIS CATEGORY OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS HAS EVERYTHING TO
DO WITH THE NEW FEDERAL
PROGRAMS- M. THERE WASN'T.
ERROR SO LET ME JUST BE REAL
BRIEF AND TELL YOU ABOUT THAT
IT'S A VERY SMALL PART. BUT IN
THIS MASSIVE AND COMPLICATED
PROGRAMMING OF BRINGING UP THE
NEW. PROGRAMS THE NEW FEDERAL
PROGRAMS- AND I'LL JUST SAY
BEFORE MANY MANY OTHER STATES.
MADE OF STICKS WITH. WE MADE TO
I'M SURE SOMEONE WILL BE
INTERESTED IN THE RE OPENING
ITS YOU'RE- VERY HAPPY. ONE IT.
WAS WHEN WE GRABBED ALL OF THE
CLAIMANTS AND WE SAID WE ARE
GOING TO OPEN YOUR CLAIMS WE'RE
GOING TO POPULATE THE WEEKS
FOR. THE NEW PROGRAMS ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO IS CERTIFIED. WHEN
WE GRAB THAT POPULATION QUITE
HONESTLY WE GRAB A SUBSET THAT
HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN
DISQUALIFIED THEY WERE OLDER
PLANES. THESE BOTH WOMEN AND
THEY TRY TO CERTAINLY OPEN
THEIR CLAIMS AND THEY'RE NOW
SITTING ON THE DASHBOARD THEY
CONTINUE TO BE DISQUALIFIED.
FOR ELIGIBILITY REASONS. BUT
OUR PROGRAMMING IS NOW FOCUSED
ON. COMPLETING THE REST OF THE
NEW FEDERAL PROGRAMS SO THEY'LL
SIT THERE FOR THIRTY DAYS AND
SO WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DISTORTION WE ARE WORKING TO
CREATE A BETTER AND SMARTER
DASHBOARD SO I'LL STOP THERE IN
ESSENCE OF TIME AND ALLOW FOR
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. YEAH LET
ME JUST. JUST CONTINUE ON THAT
BEFORE I ASK MY NEXT QUESTION.
91% WAS WAITING TO CERTIFY. BUT
A RECALL IN PAST HEARINGS YOU
SAID ONCE WE- IMPLEMENTED THE
ID ME SYSTEM WE WERE GOING TO
AVOID A LOT OF THIS. SO DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE THAT'S WORKING IF
91% OF THE NEARLY ONE MILLION.
IS NOT THE STILL GOING THROUGH
THE SAME ISSUE OF CERTIFICATION
HE JUST ELABORATE WHY THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY. I DE MI
WAS BROUGHT ON BECAUSE OF THE-
IT WAS DETERMINED BY THE STRIKE
TEAM THAT YOU WERE HAVING TO
MANUALLY PROCESS. LOOKS LIKE WE
NEED A TO YOUR CALL WE HAD A
60% INITIAL CLAIMS AUTOMATION I
BABY WAS BROUGHT ON IN ADDITION
WITH ADDITIONAL EDT EFFORT TO
INCREASE THAT 290% AUTOMATION
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE. SO I
DIDN'T CAME ON TO. AUTOMATE THE
PROCESS AUTOMATE THE INITIAL
CLAIM FILING PROCESS IT ALSO
PROVIDES A MEASURE OF. FRAUD
DETERRENT OR FRAUD DETECTION.
SO THAT'S IDEA. THAT WAS THE-
SPEED. THE CERTIFICATION AS
ALWAYS AND CONTINUES TO PAY HER
REQUIREMENTS. ACTION THAT THE
CLAIMANT HAS TO TAKE. IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT ME M. EDT
BEARS RESPONSIBILITY ENSURING
THE EDUCATION IS ABSOLUTELY
THERE BUT THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY
COME BACK AND SAY I HAVE FOUND
WORKING DIDN'T FIND WORK- OR
WAGES IF WAGES. IF THEY
RECEIVED EARNINGS THEY HAVE TO
DO THAT- I CERTAINLY MEANT
LOOKING FORWARD TO US SIMPLER
WAY FOR THEM TO DO THAT WELL
IT'S ACTUALLY SIMPLE BUT THEY
JUST NEED TO DO IT SO WE CAN'T
MAKE THE DETERMINATION TO EARLY
THEY'VE ABANDONED THE CLEANING
SO WE. LAST THIRTY DAYS. SO I
HOPE THAT MAKES SENSE AND IF I
COULD JUST I COULD JUST TAKE A
GROUP STEP BACK THE- BACKLOG
THAT WE ALL DISCUSSED FROM
DISTRACTING WHICH WAS ONE POINT
SIX MILLION. BACK LOG IS JUST
ABOUT DONE. HERE SORTED AND
ATTESTED THAT WE WILL BE DONE
THIS MONTH AND- AS OF LAST
FRIDAY THERE WERE LITERALLY A
HUNDRED AND TEN CLAIMS LEFT AND
THESE ARE NOT NORMAL PROCESSING
CLAIMS THAT. A CLAIM FILED IT
THERE. HOW REQUIRES TECHNICAL
RESOURCES FROM I. T. STAFF BUT
WE ARE COMMITTED TO RESOLVING
THOSE CLAIMS THE BOUNTY THAT
YOU'RE SEEING NOW HAS BECAUSE
YOU SAW THE DECREASE HAS
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THE NEW
FEDERAL PROGRAMS. US MAKING THE
WEEKS AVAILABLE CLAIMANT'S NAME
COMMENTED CERTIFY IF THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE THAT'S THERE TO TURN
THEIRINITIAL DECISION AND THEN
WILL WE DO A MEASURE CHECKING
FOR NORMAL YOU Y. SO DOES THAT
I HOPE ANYWAY THAT FROM. THE
HELP ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
YEAH NO THANK YOU I THINK IT
DOES BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE
SAYING INITIALLY THAT WAS ONE
POINT SIX. BILLION THE ONE
HUNDRED SIX POINT MILLION.
BACKLOG THAT WAS IDENTIFIED BY
THE STRIKE FORCE BUT NOW.
YOU'VE YOU'VE WORKED ON THAT
BUT NOW. THE BACKLOG IS NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE THOUSAND.
BUT THAT'S BECAUSE OF ALL THESE
OTHER NEW CRITERIA IS WITH THE
NEW FEDERAL PROGRAMS- THE ERROR
THE DVD HAD. BUT YOU KNOW IN
YOU MENTIONED IN THAT ERROR YOU
GRABBED OLDER. INELIGIBLE
CLAIMANTS DO YOU KNOW WHAT
PRIVILEGE OF THE 91% OF THE-
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
THOUSAND. THAT PERTAINS TO ARE
WE LOOKING AT MOSTLY NEW
CLAIMANTS OR IS THAT JUST
PEOPLE THAT GOT. LOOKING UP
SORRY FOR THE INTERRUPTION
WE'RE ABSOLUTELY LOOKING THE
BOOK OF IT OUR NEW CLAIMANTS
THERE'S ABOUT. TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND THAT WE GRABBED
INADVERTENTLY. SO IF I COULD
ALSO- THE TO. THE PASSPORT THE
AND READERS IT WILL TELL YOU
THE PUBLIC THE CLAIMANTS. BACK
RELATED TO BILLING THE ACTION
AN ACTION THAT WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE NEXT SO IT'S NOT ALL
CONVOLUTED A MIXED TOGETHER
BECAUSE THAT REALLY IS- THE
PICTURE THAT NEEDS TO BE
PRESENTED WE ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ACTIONS WERE ALSO USING A
DEAL WELL INSTRUCTING MEASURE
THAT OUR GOAL IS TO NOT CARRY.
ANY BACKLOG BUT THE FEDERAL
MEASURE REALLY IS NO MORE THAN
13% SO YOU WILL SEE THAT- AS WE
TRANSITION TO PROVIDING UP-
TRANSPARENT OR PERFORMANCE
MEASURES I HOPE THAT HELPS GOT
IT NO I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
APPRECIATE THE DIRECTOR IN OUR
OPENING COMMENTS TALKING ABOUT
MODERNIZING EDT AND I HOPE. IN
OUR MODERNIZATION WEEKEND BY
CIPHERS THIS INFORMATION ON THE
DASHBOARD A LOT MORE CLEARLY AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND I THINK
JUST BY DOING THAT YOU'RE GONNA
IMPLEMENT SOME REFORMS IN TERMS
OF TRANSPARENCY- FOR THE PUBLIC
AND FOR THE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR AS WELL SO APPRECIATE
THAT- I DO HAVE A SECOND
QUESTION MADAM CHAIR IF THAT'S
OKAY- SECOND QUESTION REALLY
IS- WHEN I STARTED MY OPENING
COMMENTS ABOUT AND THAT'S
REALLY FOR. BANK OF AMERICA AND
FOR EDIE D. AND IT'S ON THE
SUSPENSION OF THE BANK CARDS
BECAUSE LAWS LIKE YOU MADAM
CHAIR THAT YOU SAID IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS- THERE'S LOTS
OF CALIFORNIANS OF CONTACTED
EACH OF OUR OFFICES ABOUT. THE
SUSPENDED ACCOUNTS AND I KNOW
WE BRIEFLY TOUCHED UPON THAT
BUT I JUST WANT TO ASKA VERY
BASIC QUESTION IS. NOT WHY WERE
THOSE ACCOUNTS- FROZEN IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND WHO WHO CALLED
THAT CHART WAS IT EDT THAT.
TOLD BANK OF AMERICA TO FREEZE
OUT OR DID BANK OF AMERICA.
FREEZE THAT ON ITS OWN. AN ARAB
IF MAY ADD TO THAT. NOT ONLY BE
ABLE MADE THE DECISION BUT WITH
A CRY TO BAHAI IT AB. AT THE
FOLLOW. WHAT CAN SO OF THIS IS
A DIRECT. IN DROUGHT. THE
DECISION WAS MADE BETWEEN BANK
OF AMERICA AND EDT. I HAVE A
NOTE ABOUT THIS. SO IN
SEPTEMBER THE BOOKS THAT ARE A
GROUP OF SUSPICIOUS KHARGE
IDENTIFYING THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND POTENTIAL
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. IN THE
INTERIM. EDT EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT WAS REVIEWING
OPTIONS TO BEST ADDRESS BEST
ADDRESS THESE ACCOUNTS IT WAS
COMMUNICATED TO THE BANK THAT
THE CARDS COULD BE FROZEN.
SINCE THAT TIME EDT HAS WORKED
TO IDENTIFY THOSE INDIVIDUALS
IN ORDER TO FREE UP THEIR
BENEFITS. WHAT'S WE VALIDATE
THEIR IT FIRM THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR BENEFITS S. R.
FRAUD CULTURES WE BEGIN TO AB
THE BENEFITS BY CHECK. THE BANK
USING LAWS REGULATIONS AND
RULES THAT ARE APPLICABLES TO
BANKS. AS CONTINUE TO FREEZE
ACCOUNTS BASED ON THEIR OWN
OBLIGATIONS AND PROTECT YOUR-
WE'RE WORKING TO CONTINUE. WITH
CONTINUALLY WORKING THE BANK OF
AMERICA TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS SUBJECT REQUIREMENTS
ARE NOT DEPRIVED OF THEIR
RIGHTFUL BENEFITS CAROL IS
THERE ANYTHING AT DATA THAT. I
CAN ACT FINANCING DIRECTOR
NANCY VARIOUS- WITH EDT- THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY-
V. THE I BELIEVE- JUST OUT ON
TO WHAT THE DIRECTORS THE WITH
THE ONE POINT FOUR. MILLION
STOP PAYS THAT WAS PUT ON I
BELIEVE THAT'S- POSSIBLY WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN IN DECEMBER- THAT WAS
MADE BY- EDT EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP INCLUDING MYSELF TO
PUT A STOP PAY- ON THOSE CARDS-
WE RAN ALL OF OUR- AS I THINK
YOU PROBABLY ALL KNOW WE RAN
ALL OF OUR CLAIMS THROUGH. OUR
THOMSON REUTERS- FRAUD FILTER
AND IT YOU KNOW IT CAME BACK
WITH YOU KNOW OVER THREE
MILLION CARDS OF WHICH MOST WE
HAD ALREADY DISQUALIFIED THE
ONES THAT WERE NOT
DISQUALIFIED- WE PUT A STOP PAY
ON THOSE BACK AT THE END OF
DECEMBER- WE DID NOT NOTIFY
EVERYONE AS AS- THE L. A. O.
POINTED OUT. ON THAT DAY WE DID
NOTIFY THEM BY THE END OF THE
YEAR THAT THERE WAS A STOP PAY
ON THEIR CARD- WE THEN DID.
SEND OUT THE LINK- YOU KNOW
STAGGERED FOR ID ME SO THEY
COULD GO THROUGH ID
VERIFICATION FOR ABOUT ONE
MILLION OF THEM THEY WERE NOT
ALL ID RELATED SOME OF THEM
WERE NON IDENTITY- FRAUD
FILTERS THAT WORKS. FROM
THOMSON REUTERS- SO AND I HOPE
ANSWERS THE OTHER PART OF THAT
QUESTION. WELL THE **** IS
ASKED FOR CLARIFICATION I KNOW-
THE MADAM CHAIR. SOME FOR SHE
WAS ASKING ABOUT THE
CLARIFICATIONS ON THE LIKE WHAT
QUALIFICATIONS DID USE AS A
BASICALLY YOU RAN A FRAUD
FILTER AND IF THEY GOT FLAGGED
AND THAT'S HOW THEY- YOU
AUTOMATICALLY SAID THIS.
ACCOUNT IS SUSPENDED OR WAS IT
THROUGH THE ID ME. IT WAS THERE
ARE FRAUGHT FIVE FILTER IT WITH
NOT ID NEEDS SO IT WAS THROUGH
THOMSON REUTERS ARE FRAUD
FILTER- AND THERE ARE YOU KNOW
THERE ARE DIFFERENT CRITERIA
THAT THAT YOU KNOW I'M I'M SURE
YOU CAN IMAGINE WE WOULDN'T.
TALK ABOUT HERE RIGHT NOW BUT-
AND THAT WAS THE DECISION THAT
WAS WHY WE MADE THAT DECISION
BECAUSE THEY WERE FLAGGED AS-
FRAUDULENT. GOT IT AND SO IT
JUST THAT JUST BEGS THE
QUESTION WHAT. ID YOU READ THE
FRAUD FILTERS WHEN YOU FIRST
GAVE OUT- WHEN HE FIRST STARTED
DISBURSING FUNDS BECAUSE WE
KEEP READING THESE HEADLINES
OF. HOW MUCH PRIDE AND HOW
MUCH. HOW MUCH MONEY IS
PROBABLY POTENTIALLY BEEN LOST
TO FRAUD. AND WAS JUSTICE DONE
LATER WHEN WE STARTED. TO
WORKING WITH BANK OF AMERICA OR
WHY IT WASN'T DONE AT BOTH
CASES AND JUST SOME GOT MISSED.
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE WE- WHERE THE GAP IS. YEP
THAT'S THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
SO EDT AS FRAUD FILTERS YOU
KNOW WE WORK WE HAVE YOU KNOW
CYBER SECURITY- FILTERS THAT WE
USE WE HAD. YOU KNOW PRE
PANDEMIC. SO LET MONEY MAYBE
BACK UP PRE PANDEMIC ON THE U.
I. SYSTEM WAS NOT NECESSARILY-
YOU KNOW THERE WAS NOT A WHOLE
LOT OF FRAUD IN THE U. I.
SYSTEM. THE KEY WAY THE FEDERAL
AS AS THE L. A. O. POINTED OUT
YOU KNOW WITH THE P. AWAY THEIR
LAST CHECKS AND BALANCE. LET'S
CHECKS ON- BEFORE. I PAYMENT
IS- DISTRIBUTED SO WE HAD FRAUD
FILTERS THAT WORKED UNDER UNDER
YOU WHY- UNFORTUNATELY WITH THE
NUMBER OF CLAIMS THAT WE GOT.
SINCE THE PANDEMIC AND THE TYPE
OF INTERNATIONAL- CRIME THAT
THAT AS BANK OF AMERICA POINTED
OUT- INTERNATIONAL CRIME
ORGANIZATIONS. I'M THOSE
FILTERS WERE NOT. GOOD ENOUGH
QUITE FRANKLY- WHAT ARE THE
AMOUNT OF CLAIMS THAT WE HAD.
SO AFTER THE STRIKE TEAM- CAME
AND YOU KNOW RECOMMENDED ID ME
YOU KNOW WE ALSO THEY ALSO
RECOMMENDED AND ARE NOT NOT
NECESSARILY TALK TO WRITERS
BUT- YOU KNOW WE START LOOKING
AT- WHAT KIND OF A TOOL THAT WE
CAN USE TO. ENHANCE OUR FRAUD-
FILTERS SO ORIGINALLY WHEN WE-
OBTAIN. THOMPSON REUTERS. WE
WERE RUNNING OUR CLAIM THROUGH
THE REUTERS AND THEN WE WOULD
PUT A STOP PAY LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED IN DECEMBER. NOW WE
ARE RUNNING OUR CLAIMS THREE OF
THOMSON REUTERS BEFORE PEOPLE
ARE PAID- SO THAT SHOULD
ALLEVIATE HOPEFULLY ELIMINATE
THE NEED FOR- MASS- STOP PAYS
LIKE WE DID- AT THE END OF
DECEMBER THERE IS ONE MORE
MONTH THAT WE'RE STILL WORKING
ON SAID TO GO THROUGH THOSE
CLAIMS BUT- WE ARE GOING TO
RUNNING. ALL OF OUR CLAIMS
THROUGH THOMSON REUTERS BEFORE-
PEOPLE GET PAID ESSENTIALLY YOU
KNOW STOPPING FRAUD AT THE
FRONT DOOR. RECLAIMED WHEN THIS
FIRST BEGAN HE DIDN'T RUN EVERY
CLAIM THROUGH THOMSON REUTERS.
I THINK THAT WHAT I'M
UNDERSTANDING AND WAS THAT A
FUNCTION OF WHAT WAS THAT
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
STAFF A DVD WASN'T HE DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH- ALLOCATION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE THIS
OVERSIGHT OF JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT SO WE CAN FIX
IT MOVING FORWARD. SO WE
ACTUALLY HAD- YOU KNOW AS A AS
I JUST SAID WE ACTUALLY HAD A
LOT OF FRAUD FILTERS- PRETE
PANDEMIC. THAT WORKED FOR THE
STRAIGHT UP YOU AYE SYSTEM
RIGHT FOR STRAIGHT UP
UNEMPLOYMENT- AND THAT WAS YOU
KNOW AGAIN I I'M NOT OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD I CAN'T REMEMBER
WHEN OUR FLAG RATE WAS BUT IT
WAS VERY LOW- IT WAS. IF I CAN
REMEMBER IT WAS BELOW THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. SO WE THEY
DID WORK. YOU KNOW- PRE
PANDEMIC. ET YOU KNOW SO POST
PANDEMIC WHEN IT WAS THE WAY
AND THERE ARE LESS CHECKS
COMING FROM YOU KNOW BASICALLY
JUST PER THE CARE ACT THEY WERE
JUST LACK LESS- CHECKS YOU KNOW
THERE WAS NO ID VERIFICATION NO
CERTIFICATION. YOU KNOW THEN.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S WHEN WE
STARTED SEEING ALL THE FRAUD
BACK IN- OVER THE SUMMER AND WE
REALIZED THAT SOMETHING WAS
WRONG THAT AUTOMATIC BACKDATING
WE STOP THE AUTOMATIC
BACKDATING BEFORE THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY DID BECAUSE WE SAW.
THE YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT OF
THOUGHT THAT WAS GOING BACK THE
NUMBER OF CLAIMS THAT SPIKE
THAN WE HAD ASSUMED THAT IT WAS
BROAD AND THAT'S WHEN WE
BROUGHT IN- THOMSON REUTERS. TO
HELP US WITH THAT AND THEN WE
RAN OUR CLAIMS THROUGH AND THEN
HENCE THAT THE V. DECEMBER-
STOPPING ME IN THE MINUTE. YES
OKAY REALLY BRIEFLY BECAUSE I
THINK WHAT WOULD HELP WHAT IS
THE TIMELINE. SO UP UP UNTIL
OCTOBER FIRST EDT HAD DONE ITS
OWN IDENTITY VERIFICATION. AS
YOU KNOW OCTOBER FIRST- I D. ME
K. IN. ON A FORWARD MEASURE.
MMHM FOR ALL CLAIMS FILED
BEGINNING. TEN ONE FOUR. THEN
WE BECAME EXPLORING ANOTHER
LAYERED APPROACH FOR FRAUD WE
ENGAGED WITH THOMSON REUTERS.
THE FIRST TIME WE USED IT IN
BULK WAS THIS ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION CLAIMS THAT WE
SUSPENDED AND LATE DECEMBER.
THAT WHILE YOU WAS THE LOOK
BACK PRIOR TO OCTOBER FIRST FOR
IDENTITY VERIFICATION SO I'M
SORRY THIS IS CONFUSING BUT-
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I DO WE-
WITH THE FORWARD APPROACH FOR
NEW CLAIMS WE NEED TO GET
PLANTS EVERYTHING GOING BACK TO
I BELIEVE IT WAS JANUARY AND
THAT'S WHERE THOMSONREUTERS
CAME IN AND GAVE US ANOTHER
LAYERED APPROACH ANOTHER LOOK
FOR EVERYTHING THAT WAS BEHIND
US IN TERMS OF RAW SO CAROL
WOULD YOU SAY. WHEN WE STARTED
USING THOMSON REUTERS. I'M I
THINK IT WAS A SMALL SAMPLE
PERHAPS I'M JUST LOOKING AT HOW
THEY WOULD USE DATA AND
UNDERSTANDING THEIR METRICS IN
NOVEMBER BUT THE FIRST MAJOR
APPLICATION WAS IN DECEMBER SO
WE DIDN'T HAVE THOMSON REUTERS
BEFORE THAT NO NOT REALLY NOT
KNOW. RIGHT SO AND ALSO REALLY
BRIEFLY- WE FELT THE PAIN OF
THE INNOCENT CLAIMANTS. AND
THAT ONE POINT FOUR IT WAS A
DELIBERATE DECISION WE FINALLY
HAVE COMPREHENSIVE DATA
ANALYSIS ON SUSPECTED FRAUD IN
OUR IN OUR INVENTORY. IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY ON THE EVE OF THE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS BEING EXTENDED
AND IF WE DIDN'T TAKE ACTION
MORE OF THE SAME VICTIMIZATION
OF INNOCENT PEOPLE. WE HEARD.
IN ONE STEP EVERYONE KNOWS YOUR
IDENTITY HAS BEEN STOLEN IT
ISN'T IT IS VERY VERY DIFFICULT
TO UNRAVEL THAT PERSONALLY SO
IF I COULD JUST SAY WE'RE
ACTUALLY LOOKING TO PUT GREATER
INFORMATION ON OUR WEBSITE FOR
THOSE INSTANCES WHERE THAT HAS
OCCURRED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I JUST I JUST WANT TO ADD ONE
ONE THING ON THE- THE P. WAVE
VERSUS THE U. Y. YOU KNOW. WHAT
IF THE IF YOU HEARD ARE THAT
YOU KNOW THE OUR PRESS
CONFERENCE YESTERDAY YOU KNOW I
MEAN. 95% OF THIS- FRIDAYS IN
THE P. WAY PROGRAM AND YOU KNOW
IT'S ABOUT 5% OBVIOUSLY IN IN
YOU WHY AND THAT WAS AS I
UNDERSTAND. TWENTY NINETEEN
THE- FRAUD RATE AND EASY D. WAS
ABOUT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FIVE
AND SIX PERCENT- AND SO IT IS
CONSISTENT YOU KNOW THAT THE
TOOLS THAT WE USED FOR OUR PRE
PANDEMIC- WORK. YOU KNOW- AND
THEY JUST DID NOT WORK FOR THE
P. WAY PROGRAM. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW
WE'LL GET INTO PROBABLY SOME
MORE THOSE QUESTIONS NEXT WEEK.
BUT JUST A QUICK FOLLOW UP ON
THE CARD- ON THE CARDS THAT
WERE FROZEN BY BANK OF AMERICA.
HOW DID YOU GO ABOUT AND
FREEZING THE ACCOUNTS AND
NOTIFYING PEOPLE BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THERE WAS SOME
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE WAITING
FOR RELIEF THOUGHT THEY HAD IT.
AND THEN HAVE SOME CHECKS
BOUNCED BECAUSE THEN THEY WERE
FROZEN EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE
LEGITIMATE CLAIMS. I BECAUSE I
KNOW THOSE WERE SOME OF. THE
FOLKS THAT WE HEARD FROM IN OUR
OFFICES. SO THAT'D BE THE ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION- WITH THE
STOP KATE AREN'T NECESSARILY
FROZEN CARDS- WE PUT A STOP PAY
ON AND THERE THERE ARE LIKELY
SOME THAT BANK OF AMERICA HAS.
FROZEN THE CARDS BUT AS- CAROL
MENTIONED. WE ARE GOING THROUGH
THOSE THEY ARE MOST MOST OF THE
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION ARE
GOING TO I. NI. AND ONCE THEY-
CLEAR IDENTITY. YOU KNOW IT
COMES BACK TO EDT AND THEN. IF
THEY YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY IF THEY
CLEAR ID ME AND THERE ARE NO
AND THEY HAVE CERTIFIED
CONTINUE TO CERTIFY WHICH WE
HAVE ASKED. CLAIMANTS TO DO AS
AS IS REQUIRED THEN THEY WILL-
BE PAID- AND IF IT'S NOT IF
THEY IF THERE IS A FROZEN CARD.
THEN THEY WON'T BE PAID BY
CHECK. GOT IT IS THE TIME FOR
THAT TO OCCUR WOULD BE WHAT A
WEEK TWO WEEKS A MONTH. IT'S
ABOUT I MEAN ONCE THEY GO
THROUGH ID ME I WOULD SAY IT'S
ABOUT A WEEK OR SO I THINK IS
WHAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING THERE IS
THERE HAS BEEN- ABOUTTHREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE. THAT
HAVE ALREADY CLEARED ID ME AND
PAYMENT HAS EITHER BEEN MADE OR
IS BEING MADE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK MATHIS SALAS THE QUESTION
WAS ALSO DIRECTED TO BANK OF
AMERICA AND I WANT TO PRE FAITH
BY SAYING THAT BANK OF AMERICA
HAS ENJOYED. AN EXCLUSIVE
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PAST DECADE
THEY ARE A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION THAT HAS BENEFITED
AND PROFITED FROM THIS CONTRACT
FOR QUITE SOME TIME- I WANT TO
ALSO HEAR FROM BANK OF AMERICA
IN TERMS OF. WHAT ARE THEY
DOING WHAT DECISION WAS MADE
THAT WE KNOW NOW THAT IT'S A
DECISION THAT WAS MADE BETWEEN
EDT. AND BANK OF AMERICA SO HOW
WAS THE DECISION MADE AND HOW
WAS HOWEVER ANY CHECKS AND
BALANCES DONE ON ON YOUR SIDE.
IT'S A IT'S PRESIDENTE THROUGH
THE BANK. FIRST OF ALL- I WOULD
SAY WE CONTINUE TO SHARE WITH
THE EDT. THE GOAL OF ENSURING
THAT LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS
RECEIVE THEIR FUNDS THAT THAT
IS THE CRITICAL ASPECT BUT WE
WORK ON WITH THEM- AND ENSURING
THAT IF THEIR ALLEGED
REQUIREMENTS WITH THE POOL OF
FROZEN CARTS AT THE SELECTION
OF CLAIMANTS RECEIVE THEIR
FUNDS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
OTHER THAN THAT THE- DIRECTOR
SIDES OR STAFF. COVERED I THINK
QUITE THOROUGHLY. OF THE
PROCESS THAT WE JOINTLY
UNDERTOOK THAT LED TO THE
FROZEN CARD POPULATION. IN
EARLY OCTOBER- AND- I'D BE A WE
CONTINUE TO WORK AT UNFREEZING
WHICH IN ACCORDANCE WITH IT BUT
POOL UP BEYOND THAT. REALLY
HAVE NOTHING TO. I THINK THAT
LAST COMMENTED AND LOOK JUST A
LITTLE BIT DISTURBING AND
SAYING YOU HAVE NOTHING TO ADD
WHEN THERE'S- MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE SUFFERING EACH
AND EVERY DAY. I JUST WANT TO
BEING CONSCIENTIOUS. THAT WE
HAVE TO RESPOND TO PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN GREAT NEED. AND THE ROLE
OF THIS OVERSIGHT HEARING IS TO
HEAR FROM YOU DIRECTLY. IN
TERMS OF WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO
ENSURE THAT. PEOPLE THAT ARE
RECEIVING THE DEBIT CARDS. ARE
BEING NOTIFIED ON TIME AND THAT
THEY ARE TREATED EQUALLY AT THE
REST OF BANK OF AMERICA
CUSTOMERS. OKAY YES HAPPY TO
ADDRESS THAT SO- WE'VE ADDED
THOUSANDS. AGENCE OR VARIOUS
CALL CENTERS TO ENSURE THAT
CLAIMANTS RECEIVE THE SAME
TREATMENT AS ANY OTHER BANK
AMERICA CUSTOMER. WE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE EIGHTY D.
AUDIT PROVING ANY PROCESSES.
AROUND THE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AT T. R. REFINING. ANY
ASPECTS OF THE VARIOUS FILTERS
THAT ARE USED AT LEAD TO FROZEN
CARDS. FOR TO UNFREEZE CARDS-
WE DO PART OF THE DEAL WE
DEPEND ON THE EDT FOR THE
AUTHENTICATION OF WHO ALLEGEDLY
CLIMATE IS. AND ONCE THAT HAS
BEEN DETERMINED WE USE THAT TO
UNFREEZE CARDS. OUT WHERE WE
CAN. I WOULD ALSO ADD. THAT IN
ADDITION TO ADDING- THOUSANDS
OF AGENTS AND STAFF ACROSS ALL
ASPECTS OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM. BUT WE ARE MONITORING
THE CLINIC EXPERIENCE. WHENEVER
WE CAN HOW WE CAN WE OUGHT TO
OUR OWN CALL CENTERS WE OUGHT
TO QUIT IT'S EXPERIENCE AND WE
ARE DELIVERED ENSURING. THAT
THEIR CONCERNS ARE ADDRESSED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AND IT
EXPLODED MATTER. WHATEVER
WHEREVER POSSIBLE. BUT BY ANY
OTHER COLLEGE STATS BUT IT'S
THE SECRET. I'M INTENDED TO
HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO I
DO THANK YOU FOR BOTH THE JUST
ON THIS TOPIC FOR BOTH THE DMB
AVE- SO MISTER AHMAD- THAT THAT
ABSOLUTELY HAS NOT BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE WITH MY CONSTITUENTS
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S REFLECTS.
IF YOU TRY YES THE MARKETS ON.
HI SORRY CAN YOU HEAR ME MISTER
MARK. I CAN HEAR YOU OKAY THANK
YOU ABU. I'LL TRY I'LL TRY TO
SPEAK UP SO THE EXPERIENCE DOT
WOULD YOU SAID APTLY DOES NOT
IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR SHAPE
REFLECT THE EXPERIENCE SHOULD
BY THE CONSTITUENTS THAT HAVE
CALLED MY OFFICE I DON'T KNOW
IF IT REFLECTS WITH. MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES IN THEIR
CONSTITUENTS ARE FELT ON WE GET
CALLS BECAUSE WE HAVE
CONSTITUENTS WHO CALLED YOUR
CALL CENTERS BEEN ON HOLD FOR
HOURS WILL ACTUALLY GET TO
SPEAK TO SOMEBODY THEY SAID
THAT THE THEY REACH A BANK OF
AMERICA CUSTOMER SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVE. THE THING THAT
THE SECOND THAT COULD DO. THE
SPEECH CONSTITUENTS HAVE
GARDEN- ALREADY A CLEARANCE
FROM EDIE D. N. SAID THAT THERE
ARE LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS THE
SAID THAT THERE'S NOTHING AGAIN
NOTHING THAT YOU CAN NOTHING
THAT WE CAN DO- I FEEL LIKE AT
THIS POINT YOU KNOW MY STAFF IS
TO GET REIMBURSED BY YOUR BANK
BECAUSE OF ALL THE TIME THAT
WE'RE SPENDING. WORKING ON
THESE CLAIMS ON THE BECAUSE
IT'S YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE NOT
PAID TO DO YOUR JOB- BUT YET IT
ENDS UP- COMPLETE
FINGERPOINTING IN FACT WHEN I
SENT A LETTER TO YOUR BANK ALL
I GOT WAS A BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE
POINTING FINGERS DD DDD POINT
FINGERS. TO YOU THIS THE FIRST
TIME. SINCE THE NEW. WHEN I
WOULD- MEETINGS IN. DISCUSSIONS
WERE BOTH ORGANISE THAT YOU ARE
BOTH. IN THE SAME ROOM. WE GET
PAID TO SOLVE PEOPLE'S PROBLEMS
NOT TO POINT FINGERS. SO WHAT
ARE YOU DOING TO RESOLVE THESE
CLAIMS BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN WE'VE
BEEN HEARING THESE THINGS FOR
MONTHS ON GOING BACK TO E. D.
THE ONE WEEK PROCESS OF
RESOLVING THESE CLAIMS I DON'T
KNOW WHO THAT'S FOR MAYBE I'VE
MISSED HER THAT BECAUSE-
OBVIOUSLY THE HERE IS A LITTLE
BIT CHALLENGING THIS ROOM. BUT
PLEASE CLARIFY BECAUSE THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY. HAS NOT BEEN OUR
EXPERIENCE UNLESS PERHAPS THE
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT ARE
GETTING TREATED. DIFFERENTLY
JUST LIKE THE GETTING TREATED
DIFFERENTLY FROM BFSI MISTER
ABOUT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ANSWER. YES SIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEN FIRST OF ALL AGAIN. IF
THERE ARE SPECIFIC CASES. OR
SPECIFIC INSTANCES WITH RESPECT
YOUR CONSTITUENTS. YEAH PLEASE
DO REFERENCE- TO PROVIDE THE
NAMES TO UP- FRIED POPULAR
WHO'S ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO
IS ONLINE RIGHT NOW- WE WOULD
OF COURSE LOOK INTO THOSE CASES
AND DRIVE AND ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE BEING TREATED DIFFERENTLY
THE COR. UP IF A CUSTOMER.
SECONDLY WE HAVE WE HAVE
PROVIDED THAT INFORMATION TO
YOUR BANK RIGHT. WHAT WOULD WE
WILL WE WILL WE WILL TAKE IT
AWAY. OKAY WELL THAT'S NOTED
AND WE WILL TAKE A LOOK. THE
WAIT TIMES THAT OUR CALL
CENTERS ARE ONE MINUTE. WITH D.
TAIL BEING BETWEEN ONE AND FIVE
MINUTES THAT'S UP FOR NOT I
DON'T KNOW FOR FOOD MAYBE YOU
HAVE A DIFFERENT LINE FOR
PEOPLE BUT THAT'S YOU KNOW WE
GET TOLD THAT PEOPLE ARE ON ON
YOU KNOW- IF IT WAS JUST ONE
PERSON I WOULD SAY THAT ON
PERHAPS THEY ARE INTELLIGENT
BUT THIS IS VERY CONSISTENT
AROUND THE FEEDBACK WE ARE
GETTING FROM A NUMBER OF PHONE
CALLS TO APPEAR ON HOLD FOR
HOURS. I DON'T I DON'T KNOW. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE STILL
GETTING SENT TO A DIFFERENT.
CALL CENTER A DIFFERENT PHONE
NUMBER- I WOULD ASSUME THAT
THAT IS. YOU KNOW A FEW MINUTE
WAIT TIME IS A TYPICAL WAIT
TIME FOR A BANK CALL CENTER.
CLEAR CLEARLY THEY'RE NOT BEING
SENT TO. ON THE SAME CALL
CENTER YOUR REFERENCING OR
EITHER THAT OR YOUR KNOW THE
CORRECT. YES SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGAIN WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO LOOK
INTO THOSE CASES IN GREATER
DETAIL- THERE IS THERE ARE
DEDICATED CALL CENTERS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM. WITH
DEDICATED STAFFING SO WE WERE
ABLE TO TRACK THE DATA- QUITE
CLOSELY BUT WE- WE WOULD OF
COURSE- LOOK AT ANY CASES YOU
HAVE. AN EXAMPLE IN DETAIL.
THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU FOR
THAT MISTER TANK- BECAUSE JUST
ABOUT THE EIGHTY DIESEL. IS
EXCUSE GIVEN THAT MEASURE. SO I
WAS JUST GONNA I WAS GONNA
ADDED THAT THERE ARE A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHO ARE GOING TO
WANT MISTER AHMAD'S EMAIL AND
SEND HIM. ALL THE THOUSANDS OF
CLAIMS THAT I HAVE YET TO BE
ACCOUNTED FOR TO YOUR POINT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DISCUSS
TO EATING DE. R. IS IT REAL
ONLY. A WEEK OR DID I HEAR THAT
INCORRECTLY TO RESOLVE THESE
CASES. IT'S SIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NATIVE AREAS WITH EDT- THAT
THAT WAS SPECIFIC TO THE- THAT
THAT I THINK IDENTITY THE I.
DENSIFICATION ISSUES THAT WE
HAD THAT WE PUT THE SPOT ON THE
ONE POINT FOUR IT'S ACTUALLY
ABOUT ONE MILLION OR SO THAT
HAD TO GO THROUGH ID MEONCE
PEOPLE GO THROUGH ID ME. AND IF
THEY ARE IF THEY HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO CERTIFY THEN IT
SHOULD TAKE ABOUT A WEEK I IT'S
SOMEBODY A SEVEN OR EIGHT DAYS.
IS WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD. GOT IT
GOT IT IN AND I THINK BASED ON
OUR LAST BRIEFING. WE WERE WE
WERE TOLD THAT IT'S TAKING
BETWEEN SIX TO EIGHT WEEKS TO
GET VERIFIED THROUGH ID ME WITH
THAT. ROUGHLY BECAUSE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE SYSTEM.
SO THERE HAVE BEEN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
VERIFIED ALREADY- I HAVE NOT
HEARD SIX TO EIGHT WEEKS- YOU
KNOW AGAIN I THINK I THE ME
HAS. STEPPED UP- SPECIFICALLY
FOR- THE SPOTS THAT BUT THAT
STOP PAYS THAT WE PUT ON THOSE
ACCOUNTS- AND IF I COULD ADD
BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE ADDRESSING
ARE THE LONG WAYS ALTHOUGH. THE
LONG LEG. THE LONG DELAY THE
LONG WAIT TIME THAT WAS
INITIALLY EXPERIENCED BY
CLAIMANTS WHEN- WE SEND THEM
THE LINK AND THEN THEY COULD GO
ON THE ID ME AND- VALIDATE
THEIR IDENTITY. AND BECAUSE OF
THOSE LONG INITIAL WAIT TIMES
AND THEY WERE LONG WE'VE
EXTENDED THE TIME PERIOD TO
LIKE FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH TO
ALLOW EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GO IN AND VERIFY THEIR
IDENTITY WITH THE IDEA ME IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED TO DO THE
WAIT TIMES HAVE- FINALLY
STARTED TO DECREASE. UP SO THE
LONGEST THAT I SAW RECENTLY IS
TWO TO THREE HOURS YES THAT IS
LONG BUT IT WAS CERTAIN TWICE
THAT- A WEEK OR SO BACK. GAGA
THE BLOOD JUST WANNA UNDERSTAND
SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE CASES GOING
BACK INTO NOVEMBER DECEMBER IN
PART THE REASON THEY ARE TAKING
SO LONG IS BECAUSE THAT WAS THE
TIME PERIOD WOULD YOU
IMPLEMENTED ID ME. YOU HAVE THE
TWO WEEK PAUSE WERE YOU WERE
THE SYSTEM WAS BEING-
TRANSITION AND THEN AGAIN WHAT
THE SYSTEM IS UP TO THE SORT OF
OUR TIMES OF BEGAN. YOU'RE
SAYING ONE WEEK BUT I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD. CUSTOMERS WAITING
MONTHS ON THIS ISSUE. IT CAN.
YES SPECIFICALLY REFERRING
BELIEVE TO THE TO THE FROZEN
CORRECT IT'S NOT AS SO I WAS I
AM TALKING ABOUT THE STOP PAID
THAT WE DID AT THE END OF
DECEMBER THERE ARE- OTHER YOU
KNOW- AS AS BANK OF AMERICA-
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WE ARE
WORKING WITH BANK OF AMERICA TO
UNFREEZE CARDS FROM PREVIOUS
TO- THE SPOT THAT WAS PUT ON AT
THE END OF DECEMBER SO THOSE DO
TAKE LONGER. HOW HOW LONG DO
THEY TAKE. WELL I WILL- I
COULDN'T GIVE YOU A SPECIFIC
THAT YOU KNOW DATE OR TIME BUT
I WILL TELL YOU THAT IF WE HAVE
A CLAIMANT THAT COMES TO US
WITH THE FROZEN CARD AND IF
THEY- HAVE VERIFIED THEIR
IDENTITY AND ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS AND ALSO CLEAR YOU
KNOW THE THOMSON REUTERS AS I
MENTIONED PROJECTS- WE WILL WE
WILL PAY THEM BY CHECK. IF
THEIR CARD IS STILL FROZEN AND
I. YOU KNOW. THAT PROBABLY
TAKES LONGER BECAUSE IT'S A
MANUAL PROCESS- WHEN WE GET
CARDS THAT ARE FROZEN. BUT WE
ARE WORKING ON THOSE ARE WE
TALKING. SIX MONTHS THREE
MONTHS. ONE MOMENT HE WOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE
CUSTOMER. SO I'M NOT I COULDN'T
GIVE YOU A TIME AND MAYBE CAROL
COULD I DO I DO KNOW THAT
ANYTHING THAT IS PREVIOUS TO
THE- STRIKE TEAM BACKLOG HAS
BEEN CLEARED SO. I IT COULD BE
SIX MONTHS BY NOW BUT I DON'T-
BUT I DON'T. I'M NOT SURE I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYTHING TAKES
SIX MONTHS BUT- OKAY BUT THAT'S
NOT REALLY AN ACCEPTABLE
ANSWERS WILL BE FOLLOWING UP
WITH YOUR- NO PROBLEM THANK YOU
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN THING- IT'S
VERY IF I THINK OF. THE
QUESTION RESPONSES REALLY THE
CONCERN THAT WE ALL SHARE ONE
CONSTITUENTS CALL OUR OFFICE WE
CANNOT TELL A CONSTITUENT WE
ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
IT'S GONNA TAKE SO IF IT PUTS
US IN A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION TO TRY TO. HELP
SOMEONE THAT'S IN NEED WAS
GONNA NOT ABLE TO PAY THE RENT
TO PAY THEIR MORTGAGE PUT FOOD
ON THE TABLE WE CAN'T TELL THAT
PERSON WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
GONNA TAKE THIRTY. THE BETTER
SOLUTION TO THAT. I WILL I WILL
JUST JUST REITERATE THAT THAT
YOU KNOW THIS THE STAFF THEY
ARE WORKING- A LOT OF TO CLEAR
THE MANUAL. CLAIMS THAT WEHAVE
YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE HAVE TO
BE DONE MANUALLY UNFORTUNATELY-
AND YOU KNOW I MEAN IT I THINK
IT CAN TAKE A FEW WEEKS I DON'T
KNOW THAT IT TAKES SIX MONTHS
BUT I DO KNOW THAT IT CAN TAKE
A FEW WEEKS SO- AND YOU KNOW
YOU COULD PLEASE CONTINUE TO
SEND US THESE. THESE CASES AND
YOU KNOW WE CAN WORK THROUGH
THEM EDT. THANK YOU MISS PETER
NORRIS AT SO I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR BANK OF AMERICA
BUT JUST I THINK BEFORE WE
CLOSE ON THAT- I KNOW IN MY
OFFICE AND I THINK IT'S THE
SAME FOR EVERY LEGISLATOR HERE
WE HAVE CONSTITUENTS WHO AVE
HAD ACTIVE CASES OPEN WITH OUR
OUR- OFFICE. SINCE JULY SINCE
JULY WE HAVE LITERALLY BEEN ON
THE PHONE WITH EDT EVERY WEEK
ON BEHALF OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
SINCE JULY SO I'M IT THAT IS
JUST COMPLETELY COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE I'M OKAY SO LET ME
LET ME THE MOVE BACK TO YOU
MISTER AHMED- AND ACTUALLY GOT
SOME SOME QUESTIONS. FOR YOU
RELATED TO AT THE PRESENT ABOUT
CARDS AND FRAUD IT BFA BUT
BEFORE I JUMP INTO THAT I WOULD
FIND IT REALLY HELPFUL JUST TO
GET AN OUTLINE OF. OUR CONTRACT
WITH BANK OF AMERICA- YEAH
WHAT'S THE COMPENSATION
STRUCTURE AND HOW MUCH HAS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PAID BANK
OF AMERICA. LAST YEAR. I MEAN
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE EDT
WOULD BE COMFORTABLE PROVIDING
THE CONTRACT YOU AND I'M SURE
THE CONTRACT CAN BE PROVIDED TO
YOU. WITH RESPECT TO WHAT THE
BANK IS EARNED LAST YEAR WE'VE
ACTUALLY LOST- HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON THE
CONTRACT. BUT WE NEVER REALLY
MENTIONED IT BECAUSE IT PALES
IN COMPARISON TO THE SCALE OF
THE- HUMAN COST OF THE PANDEMIC
IS ABOUT AS MENTIONED. AND
WE'VE STAFFED UP- THE CONTRACT
AS MUCH AS WE POSSIBLY CAN TO
ENSURE THE CLAIMANTS ARE SIR
PROPERLY. BUT WE'VE ACTUALLY
LOST HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS BOTH
THROUGH LOSSES THE FRAUD LOSSES
IMPACTED THANK AMERICA AS WELL.
AND THE COST OF SERVICING THE
CONTRACT TO BE A HIS EXTENT
POSSIBLE HAS ALSO COST HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS BUT UP BEYOND
SECONDARY TO THE HUMAN COST OF
THE PANDEMIC. YES I WOULD FIND
IT VERY USEFUL FOR EDT IF WE
COULD PLEASE GET A COPY OF THAT
CONTRACT AS A FOLLOW UP TO THIS
HEARING. I'M AND AS A MISTER
AHMAD YOU'VE GOT THE SORT OF
STARTED TO LEAD TO IT SO. THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF. DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES I THINK BOTH A
FROZEN OF REASONS FOR CARDS
BEING FROZEN AND ALSO. FOR THE
FRONT THAT'S AN EXPERIENCE SO
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THERE WERE IS ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
RIGHT ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
CARDS PRESENT. AND BECAUSE OF
AN EIGHTY D. DECISION. IN
ADDITION TO THAT YOU HAVE
SEPARATELY FLAGGED CARDS AS
SUSPECTED IDENTITY THEFT OR-
OTHER. FRAUD REASONS AND ALSO
FROZEN THOSE CARDS IS THAT
CORRECT AND HOW MANY. OF THOSE
CARDS. ARE SUFFERS IN RIGHT NOW.
SO IS CORRECT AS PART OF OUR
EFFORTS WE HAVE FLAG FOR THE
EDT- CARDS THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
THE RESULT OF WHAT WE CALL
BENEFITS LEGIBILITY FRAUD. NAME
RECLAIM WHO SHOULD NOT BE
RECEIVING. FUNDS AS YOU ARE
PROGRAMS SO ELIGIBLE CLAIMANTS
CRIMINALS. AND WE'VE WORKED
WITH THE EASY TO IDENTIFY THOSE
CLIENTS AND AS OF TODAY THERE
ARE APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND CARDS THAT
ARE STILL FROZEN. AND THAT'S ON
TOP OF THE ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION POOL THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT. WHAT WE WHAT WE
WEEK WE DON'T KNOW BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE LIST OF THE ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION CARDS- OF
THAT GROUP THAT. HAVE THAT ARE
THE SUBJECT OF A STOP PAYMENT
AS A AS THE STAFFERS- HAS
MENTIONED UNDERSTOOD OKAY BUT
YOU BANK OF AMERICA HAS FLAG
FOUR NINE EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
CARDS THAT ARE STILL FROZEN AND
WHAT IS THE PROCESS. FOR AT
RESOLVING THOSE CASES. YES SIR
SO IT'S APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
CARTS AND THE CLAIMANTS HAVE TO
REESTABLISH A RE VERIFY THEIR
IDEA L. ELIGIBILITY BY UP TO
EDT- ANYONE WHO APPLIES FOR AND
WISHES TO MAINTAIN. THEIR
STATUS AS LEGITIMATE CLAIM IT
HAS TO DO SO BY A CD DVD
PROGRAM AND ONCE THEY'VE DONE
SO- IS SUBJECT TO THE DECISION
MADE FOR FREE THE CARD IN THE
FIRST PLACE- BUT ONCE IT'S DONE
SO AND WE'RE SATISFIED WE- IN
OUR DISCUSSIONS THE EDT WE
UNFREEZE THE CART. AND HOW LONG
IS THAT TAKING. HAT PERCENTAGE
OF THE FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN
FROZEN BECAUSE OF YOUR
ASSESSMENT TURN OUT TO ACTUALLY
BE FRAUDULENT VERSES LEGITIMATE
CLAIMANTS. SO I WILL HAVE TO
COME BACK TO YOU WITH THE
SPECIFIC PERCENTAGES UP BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THEY SHIFT. WHAT'S
UP- AS OF RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
UNFROZEN APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
THOUSAND CARDS SO THE YOU KNOW
THE GRAND TOTAL CARDS OVER
FROZEN LIVE WORK GREATER THAN
400-405-0000 BUT WE'VE WORKED
WITH EDTA TO UNFREEZE
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THOUSAND
CARDS. OKAY I. AND. RIGHT NOW
THE SENATE IS AND HOW LONG IS
THAT TAKING. FOR PEOPLE TO FOR
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS WHO HAVE
GOTTEN SO YOU KNOW IT'S SOME
SAY 1015% OF FOLKS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY LEGIT THAT YOU HAVE
FROZEN. WHAT IS THEIR
EXPERIENCE HOW QUICKLY CAN THEY
EXPECT. A RESOLUTION. SO IN FOR
I CAN'T AND THAT FOR YOU GIVEN-
THAT EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR OF RESOLUTION IN READ
THEIR ID'S AND VERIFYING THAT
THEY ARE IN FACT CLAIM THAT AND
THE GIVEN THIS AND THE SCOPE OF
THE FROM THAT WE ALL EXTRA-
WEATHER'S CAL- THE OVERWHELMING
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS BOTH
LEGITIMATE AND ILLEGITIMATE TWO
EDT. YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE SPENT
A LOT OF TIME WITH THE DIRECTOR
HER STAFF ON THIS TOPIC- IT I'M
I'M SURE OF THAT AMOUNT OF THAT
THAT THAT PERCENTAGE OF TIMES
REPLACEMENT VARIES DEPENDING
CLOSE BY CLEMENT AND I'M SURE
IT ALSO VARIES DEPENDING ON HOW
QUICKLY THEY RESPOND BACK TO
THE EDT. OKAY AND I'M I'VE HAD
ONE QUESTION THAT WAS IS IT
TRUE THAT WE DIDN'T NOTIFY- YOU
DIDN'T NOTIFY CUSTOMERS BEFORE
FREEZING THEIR CARDS AND THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN ANSWERED BY EDT
AND INDEED WE DID NOT VERIFY
INDIVIDUALS IT'S ALSO IN THE L.
A. O.'S ANALYSIS IT IT SAYS
THAT BE HAVE A DOES NOT HAVE
CUSTOMER CONTACT INFORMATION.
IS THAT TRUE. AND SO YOU CAN'T
COMMUNICATE WITH PEOPLE. SO
INITIALLY THERE THERE WERE A
SERIES OF CARS THAT WERE FROZEN
WHERE WE DIDN'T SEND NOTICES WE
NOW SEND NOTICES WHEN A CAR IS
FROZEN WHEREVER AND WHENEVER WE
CAN- BUT THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
WE DON'T HAVE THE CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR A CARDHOLDER
BEYOND THE ADDRESS TO WHICH THE
CARD WAS SENSE. AND UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WE BELIEVE
THAT THE- THE ADDRESS COULD
ALSO CORRESPOND TO A FRAUDULENT
ACCOUNT. BOARD ELECTION
EQUIPMENT IT'S DIFFICULT TO
FIND AN ALTERNATE WAY OF
SENDING A NOTICE SO WE HAVE TO
WORK WITH THE DUTY TO DO SO.
I'VE HAD ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
AND I WOULD FIND IT REALLY
HELPFUL IF I COULD IF WE COULD
GET THE FOLLOW UP AROUND THE
PERCENTAGE OF AT THE PRISON
CARDS ON YOUR SIDE THAT TURNED
OUT TO BE LEGITIMATE WITH THE
PROCESSES FOR RECTIFYING NOT
AND IN SOME SENSE OF THE
TIMELINE- THAT SAID THAT IT'S
BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. AND
THEN I WILL I WANT TO TURN BACK
ACT REALLY QUICKLY TO YOU- EDT
SO IT WOULD WHEN YOU SHARED
YOUR OPENING REMARKS AND AS
WE'VE RESPONDED TO QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE FRAUD THAT'S BEEN
EXPERIENCED IT ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS YOU POINTED TO THE
FACT THAT IT WAS THE THIS NEW
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. ALL ALL
STATES IN IN IN IN THE COUNTRY
HAS BEEN AT VICTIMIZED BY
ORGANIZED FRAUD RINGS AND NIGHT
I CERTAINLY DON'T DISPUTE THAT
TIME UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES
THE BAD GUYS ARE A LOT MORE
CREATIVE THAN THE GOOD GUYS
BATES THAT BEING SAID- I THINK
THAT WE'VE GOT TO BE REALLY
HONEST WITH CALIFORNIANS CAN'T
WITH OURSELVES ABOUT THE PLACES
WHERE OUR PROCESS THESE FAILED
US AND I'M TO ME ARE THE MOST
OBVIOUS EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE PAID BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF FRAUD. TO
PRISONERS IN CALIFORNIA IN OUT
OF STATE AND THE REMEDY FOR
THAT AS THE PREVENTION FOR THAT
WAS ACTUALLY REALLY REALLY
STRAIGHTFORWARD THAT'S NOT A
SITUATION WHERE YOU KNOW WE
JUST GOT OUT WAITED BY THE
CRIMINALS- SO I GUESS THAT'S
THAT'S MOSTLY AN OBSERVATION
BUT I'M I FEEL LIKE BLAMING THE
P. YOU A AND BLAMING THE FEDS
REALLY SEEMS TO BE MISSING A
BIG PART OF THE POINT I'M SO IT
I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE WE DOING AS W MOVE
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
MAKING ANY OF THOSE. LIKE
STUPID MISTAKES AS WE GO
FORWARD SO AND CAN YOU COMMENT
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OKAY AT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. FROM ME
AND LET ME. YEP YEP LET ME
START LET ME START. ASK BY
TAPPED CLICK FOLLOW UP. THE
OPRAH. WHAT'S GOING ON LIKE A-
YOU DIDN'T HAVE WHO ARE AND
NANCY CAN HELP ME ON THIS.
THERE WERE NOT. GUARDRAILS FOR
THE PROGRAM LIKE THERE ARE ON
THE U. I. PROGRAM. BECAUSE THE
FRAUD HAD BEEN SO RELATIVELY
SMALL IN THE U. I. PROGRAM ALL
THESE YEARS AND AS WE POINTED
OUT IN THE U. I. PROGRAM. IT'S
ONLY 5% WHICH IS TYPICAL. ISN'T
TYPICAL OVER THE YEARS. THERE
WAS A RUSH WHEN THE FEDERAL AND
STATE LEVEL TO GET MONEY OUT TO
PEOPLE. THE DESIGN OF THE
PROGRAM WAS FLAWED. AND WE GOT
VERY LITTLE GUIDANCE FROM DEAL
WELL. BEYOND THAT FIRST RELEASE
OF THE PROGRAM'S. NEVER BEEN.
CLOSE THE COUNTRY AN INCIDENT
AS MASSIVE OF EXHIBITORS USING
STOLE THE NIGHT BEGAN TO APPLY
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. I
COULD NOT SPEAK BLAKE ABOUT
WHAT WAS HAPPENING. AT THE TIME
AT THE TIME BUT HAVING HAD
EXPERIENCE WITH BENEFIT
PROGRAMS THIS IS FUND PRESIDENT
HOW TO COOK AND PREPARE GIVEN
THE CARDINALS ON THIS PROGRAM.
OF FROM KIDS I JUST DON'T SEE
HOW THAT COULD HAVE HAPPENED. I
DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS A STUPID
MISTAKE I THINK IT WAS OF. WE
WERE JUST. ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT WORST PART ABOUT
IT OR ANYTHING LIKE THIS BOB
NOW I WANT TO MAKE SOMETHING
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT I'M SAYING. WE
GOT. STRONG PREVENTION SOONER
THAN EVERYBODY ELSE. NOT SOON
ENOUGH. BUT SOONER THIS WAS A
COMPLETE SHOCK TO THE SYSTEM.
EVERYONE WAS SO CONCERNED ABOUT
GETTING MONEY OUT. THE SOME OF
THE GUARDRAILS THAT WE USUALLY
HAVE WERE ACTUALLY CHALLENGING
IT SYSTEMS. AGAIN TO SLOW DOWN.
THERE WAS FEAR THAT THE SYSTEM
MIGHT CRASH AND THAT WE WOULD
REALLY BE NOT ABLE. TO- THE
PEOPLE. SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
THEY WOULD HAVE. PREPARED FOR
SOMETHING THAT HAD NEVER
HAPPENED AND HAD NEVER HAPPENED
ON THE SCALE. THAT DOESN'T HER.
PEOPLE ARE STILL SUFFERING WE
STILL LOST THE MONEY. THERE'S
NO HOPE FOR A SUGAR COATING
ACTS AS SECRETARY SINCE AT.
WOMAN I CAN ALSO YES I CAN
ALSO. MENTION A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT THAT YOU D. D. HAS
DONE OVER THE PAST FEW MONTHS
TO MEET ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS ABOUT THE KEY WAY OF
COURSE AS AS I MENTIONED IS
THAT YOU KNOW THE SELF ASKED AT
THE STATION WHICH IS BASICALLY
JUST YOU KNOW YOU SAY YOU'VE
LOST YOUR JOB BECAUSE OF
CULTIVATED AND YOU KNOW WE- IT
WAS. A PRODUCT OF THE OF THE
FEDERAL GUIDELINES THEY WANTED
TO GET MONEY INTO THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE QUICKLY TO STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY- AND THAT WAS PART OF
IT THE AUTOMATIC BACKDATING WAS
ANOTHER PIECE OF ART- YOU COULD
ALSO JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW YOU
YOU. LOST YOUR JOB BACK IN
MARCH AND YOU COULD GET- FONT
AND THERE WAS AGAIN THERE WAS
NO CHECK ON THAT IT WAS JUST
AUTOMATIC FACT EATING FOR THE
FEDERAL ON GUIDELINES. WHEN WE
WHEN HE DEFEATS SAW THAT THERE
WERE A HUGE SPIKE IN CLAIMS AND
I BELIEVE IT WAS AUGUST JULY
AUGUST- LATE SUMMER YOU KNOW WE
STOPPED. THE AUTOMATIC
BACKDATING. UP PRIOR TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TELLING THE
REST OF THE STATE'S TO DO THAT.
YOU KNOW WE DID SEE THAT WE DID
STOP THAT. THE STRIKE TEAM THEN
CAME IN YOU KNOW WE YOU BE USED
ID ME AS A- SORT OF A AN
IDENTITY. AS THE IDENTITY
VERIFICATION TOOL I'M SO PEOPLE
DO HAVE TO VERIFY THEIR
IDENTITY THAT'S A SELFIE THAT'S
PART OF IT- WE THEN INSTITUTED-
THOMSON REUTERS BASED ON- YOU
KNOW TASK FORCE THAT- GOVERNOR
NEWSOM PUT TOGETHER WITH. OH
YES- AND THAT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S- YOU KNOW HERE IN
SACRAMENTO PLASTER COUNTY AND
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- AND THEY
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS WAS TO USE.
THOMSON REUTERS TO TRY TO-
PREVENT SOME OF THE FRAUD
ESPECIALLY. YOU MENTIONED
SPECIFICALLY OF THE- THE PRISON
FRAUD WHICH YOU KNOW WE NOW AS
I BELIEVE YOU KNOW EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT WE NOW HAVE A DAY
THAT I'M SHARING AGREEMENT WITH
THE C. R. ALONG WITH STATE
HOSPITALS TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE
CROSSMATCH ON INMATE DATA AND
THOMSONREUTERS ALSO HELPED OUT
THROUGHOUT- THE COUNTRY AND IN
LOCAL JAILS LOCAL JAILS AND-
PRISONS- AND SO THAT THOSE ARE
JUST SOME OF THE BILL BASIC
STEPS THAT. YOU KNOW WE PUT
TOGETHER I MEAN WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH- YOU KNOW THE DA
IS AS I MENTIONED ON THE TASK
FORCE TO- COME UP WITH NEW.
WAYS WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR
ANYTHING THAT YOU KNOW IS
HELPFUL WE MEET WITH YOU KNOW
VENDORS ALL THE TIME ABOUT WHAT
SOME OF THEIR- YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY MAY HAVE
THAT. THAT THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL- WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO- HEY CLAIMANTS
FORCED THE BALL BUT PAY. THE
CLAIMANTS WHO ARE ENTITLED AND
ARE IN NEED- AND THEN OF COURSE
YOU ALSO AT THE SAME TIME TO
PREVENT THE MASSIVE AMOUNTS. OF
FRAUD WHICH THE IN. I FIVE WHEN
A LAST LAST. COMMON OR OR
QUESTION TO THIRTY OTHERS.
ALREADY SYSTEMS THAT DO CROSS.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CLAIMS
AGAINST. THE RECORDS AB SO ARE
WE PART OF ANY KIND OF LIKE
INTERSTATE INFORMATION SHOP
WHERE WE CAN GATHER BEST
PRACTICES AND IDEAS AND LEARN.
FROM OTHER STATES SO THAT WE DO
NOT MAKE OBVIOUS MISTAKES GOING
FORWARD. SO WE ARE WE ARE PART
OF- OUT. NO THAT'S A BRILLIANT.
OH I'M SORRY OKAY WE HAD A WE
ARE PART OF- NASSIM NOW AS WELL
WHICH IS THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF STATE WORKFORCE
IS AND WE DO- YOU KNOW THAT
THAT IS WE ARE PART OF THAT AND
WE DO TALK TO OTHER STATES AND-
YOU KNOW. I KNOW THAT EVERYONE
IS TIRED OF SAYING OF ME SAYING
THIS BUT EVERY STATE IS IN THE
SAME SITUATION AS CALIFORNIA WE
ALL HAVE THE SAME EXACT.
PROBLEMS ON THAT OTHER STATES
HAVE WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW
FRAUD OR YOU KNOW PAYING PEOPLE
TIMELY WHATEVER IT IS I MEAN
ALL STATES. ARE IN THE SAME
SITUATION I'M SO WE DO WE DO
WORK WITH NOW THAT'S WHAT AND
WE DO SHARE INFORMATION WITH
OTHER STATES WASHINGTON STATE
HAS BEEN. A GREAT PARTNER- WITH
US YOU KNOW WE ARE ON THE PHONE
WITH THEM MULTIPLE TIMES-
SOMETIMES A WEEK I FEEL LIKE
I'M TO TRY TO GET YOU KNOW. TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THEY'RE DEALING
WITH- YOU KNOW THEIR THEIR
SITUATION THERE SO WE DO. TALK
TO OTHER STATES YES. WHAT WRONG
BUT IN THE BEGINNING WHEN WE
WANTED TO SHARE THE INFORMATION
WITH CORRECTIONS WAS IT NOT THE
CASE THAT IT WAS THOUGHT THAT
IT WAS NOT LEGALLY POSSIBLE TO
DO THAT. CORRECT THAT THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS IN STATUTE
AND THE- ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE- HERE. AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL- BASICALLY ALLOW THE DATA
SHARING BASED ON THE AMOUNT OF
FRAUD- IN THE P. WAY SYSTEM-
SEEING THAT THERE WERE THERE
WAS THIS YOU KNOW MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF FRAUD THEY STATE.
FINDS THAT- THAT WE COULD SHARE
THE DATA CDCR. COULD SHARE THE
DATA WITH EDT. WELL THE GOOD
NEWS IS PACKING A BUNCH OF YOU
CAN ACTUALLY WRITE NEW LAWS ARE
UP TO DATE ARE OUTDATED LAWS
AND IN MAY IN FACT I HAVE
INTRODUCED A BILL. WITH MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE ROOM TO
ADDRESS THIS THIS SPECIFIC
ISSUE BUT BUT PLEASE I THINK
PART OF AS MOVING FORWARD IN A
PARTNERSHIP AND PART OF US
MOVING FORWARD INVOLVES BETTER
COMMUNICATION IF THERE ARE
ROADBLOCKS. REACH OUT TO US SO
THAT WE CAN HELP WRESTLING ON
AND YOU KNOW AND IF WE'RE IN A
MOMENT OF CRISIS AND WE'RE FOR
FREEZING ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
ACCOUNTS. PLEASE REACH OUT TO
US AND LET US KNOW SO THAT WE
CAN HELP MESSAGES START
CONSTITUENTS- SO. THAT IS MY
HAD MY PARTING COMMENT IS JUST
THANK YOU HE'S LET'S LET'S
IMPROVE THE COMMUNICATION SO
THAT WE CAN IMPROVE SERVICE FOR
TAKE YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
REALLY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT AND YOU CAN COUNT. ON IT.
WE WILL BE JACQUI. THANK YOU
FOR THEM IS PETRIE-NORRIS IN
THE THIRD OF A- COLLABORATION
AND SOLUTION FINDING I THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO BE. I
DO WANT TO ADDRESS SOMETHING
THAT YOU BROUGHT UP THOUGH AND
THAT IS IN TERMS OF. THE
SYSTEMS THAT WE USE COULD.
COULD THIS HAVE BEEN PREVENTED
COULD THIS HAVE BEEN AVOIDED
WATER THE GUARD RAILS ARE BEING
PUT IN PLACE IN THE FUTURE WHAT
THE SYSTEM. OF THE FUTURE THAT
WE NEED NOW LOOKING LIKE. A IN
PREPARING FOR THIS FOR THIS
HEARING. WE ALSO DISCOVERED ON
THE EDT WEBSITE. A DECEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY NINETEEN.
LEADERSHIP ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT IN WHICH THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF EDT ADDRESSED THE
LETTER TO. SECRETARY SU. AND IN
THAT REPORT ON PAGE ELEVEN. IT
LAYS OUT SOME OF THE MOST
PRESSING ISSUES STATING. THE D.
THE ET DE AND MIND YOU THIS IS.
FOR MONTHS BEFORE MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY BEFORE WE ALL
WENT INTO. A STAY AT HOME
ORDERS. THE EDT IS NOT
OPERATING WITH MAXIMUM MAXIMUM
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS
DUE TO VARIOUS WORKFORCE. AND
SUCCESSION COMPONENTS WHICH
HAVE EITHER NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED OR NOT FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. FEHLER TO RESOLVE
THESE ISSUES COULD REDUCE THE
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO
SUSTAIN. A ROBUST WORKFORCE AND
MEET ITS MANDATE AND VISION
MISSION AND OBJECTIVES. THIS IS
NOT A REPORT THAT IS
UNAVAILABLE IT IS ON YOUR
WEBSITE. IT STATES WHAT'S
NEEDED IN TERMS OF. WHAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE DO TO IMPROVE IT
THE THUMBS YET IT HAS DONE
NOTHING UP UNTIL THIS POINT.
HERE WE FIND OURSELVES NOW IN
THE SITUATION. I GEN WILMA
CARRILLO LET ME JUST SAY THAT
IT. EDT HAS DONE A NUMBER OF
THINGS IT HAS NOT DONE ENOUGH.
AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE
INFORMATION ON HOW ON HOW WE
HAVE IMPROVED OUR- OUR SYSTEMS
I WOULD BE GLAD TO PROVIDE THAT
TO YOU BUT REALLY. AREN'T I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR-
DIRECTION IN SEE WHAT WE CAN DO
IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO BE DOING A LOT OF
TEACHERS WE'RE GOING TO BE
INVOLVING. THANKS FOR THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE WITH
MEMBER QUESTIONS WE STILL HAVE
A ROOM FULL OF MEMBERS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS BOTH THE
EDT AS WELL AS BANK OF AMERICA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WAITING I HOPE THAT
WE HAVE RESOLVED THE TECHNICAL.
ISSUES I KNOW WE'RE A LITTLE
BIT LATER WE'RE LOOKING TO YOU
FOR THE NEXT QUESTION. GREAT
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN GET
YOU PLEASE CONTENT OKAY. GREAT
pGONNA START WITH SOME QUESTIONS
FOR BANK OF AMERICA REALLY
FOLLOWING UP ON MISTER SPEAKER
NORRIS'S QUESTIONS RELATED TO
HOW WE CAME INTO THIS CONTRACT
IN THE FIRST PLACE SO. I HAD A
CHANCE TO LOOK AT- THE ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL THAT BANK OF AMERICA
PROVIDED TO EDT AND WINNING THE
EXCLUSIVE CARE ACT AND IN THAT
PROPOSAL. BANK OF AMERICA
REPRESENTED THAT IT WOULD QUOTE
EMPLOY THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SECURITY AND FRAUD SAFEGUARDS.
QUOTE PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE TO EMERGING FRAUD
TRENDS. AND QUOTE EMPLOYEE
EXTENSIVE FRAUD MONITORING NOW
CLEARLY WE'RE HERE BECAUSE
THERE HAVE BEEN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS. OF EDT BANK OF
AMERICA ACCOUNTS THAT HAVE BEEN
COMPROMISED IN FROZEN MISTER
AHMAD I'M WONDERING. IF YOU
COULD SHARE WITH US DO YOU FEEL
THAT BANK OF AMERICA DID EMPLOY
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF SECURITY
AND FRAUD IN THIS INSTANCE. AND
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T HEARD OF
SIMILAR FRAUD WITH OTHER
CONSUMER DEBIT ACCOUNTS. IS
THERE A DIFFERENCE AND FRAUD
MONITORING. ON EIGHTY ACCOUNTS
VERSUS CONSUMER DEBIT ACCOUNTS.
BOB PRESS MY COLLEAGUE BILL FOX
REPORT TO ADDRESS THE- THE
DIFFERENCES APPROACH. THANK YOU
THAT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK I
THINK IT'S MOST IMPORTANT TO
REALIZE THAT THE TYPE OF PRIDE.
THAT WE HAVE PAID THAT MUCH
PORTFOLIO BY IN MARCH IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CALL BENEFITS
ELIGIBILITY FIVE SO THERE THEY
WERE THERE THE PRODUCT- FOR
FRAUD NETWORK IS ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY. DEPRIVING THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I BY BYE
EITHER'S FEELING AND I. AND
SUBMITTING THAT I. WORK AT A
DIFFERENT PLACE WITH PERSON TO
RECEIVE. BY STEALING CARDS OUT
OF MAILBOX WE THAT WITH WITH-
WITH CRIME NETWORKS DOING THAT-
ANY SORT OF THE- THAT WOULD IN
THAT NGUYEN NEIGHBOR THEM TO.
OVER THAT AT WITH. RIGHT AND
FIELD ACCOUNT THAT THE
APPRENTICE FROM TYPICAL TRANSIT
PRICE. AND IT SOME THAT WE- I
CAN YOU I I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR. ACT OF AMERICA POOR
FIFTEEN THAN AND I THINK WE'RE
PRETTY GOOD AT IT WILL GOOD AT
THE TRANSIT PRICE AND WE'RE
VERY GOOD AT ACCOUNT TAKEOVER
FRAUD BUT- I HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANY KIND OF ATTACK LIKE THIS IN
THE FIFTEEN YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN HERE. AND CANDIDLY I WAS
IN THE GOVERNMENT WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES BEFORE THEN. AND I
DON'T I THINK THIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED. SO WE STARTED
DETECTING THE- ALL PROGRAMS IN
IN LATE APRIL MAY. WE STARTED
DETECTING THE AND LATE JUNE AND
JULY. AND BY AUGUST WE HAVE WE
RECOGNIZED THAT WE WERE DEALING
WITH SOMETHING THAT WAS
UNPRECEDENTED. WE'VE HEARD FROM
COLLEAGUES IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT THEY BELIEVE- THAT THAT
CRIMINAL NETWORKS HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN SITTING ON A CASH. STOLEN
IDENTITIES OR SOME TALKING. AND
HAVE A WHEN WAITING FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO JUMP. AND THEY
HAVE FOUND THIS OPPORTUNITY.
AND I THINK THAT SO IN A WAY-
BDD IS EVERY BIT AS MUCH THE
VICTIM HERE AS AS AS YOU KNOW
THEY ARE YOU KNOW TOTAL SO THEY
THEY'VE BEEN THEY'VE BEEN
DECEIVED BY A LOT OF FALSE
IDENTITIES BY A LOT OF STOLEN
IDENTITIES THEY THEY BELIEVE.
ONE FOURTH OF BELIEVE THAT
IDENTITIES FROM ALL THE WAY
BACK TO THE TO THE- EQUIFAX AND
MASTERCARD BREACHES AND TARGET
BREACHES ARE ARE ALL IDENTITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN USED. FOR THAT-
THIS PERIOD I WOULD ACTUALLY
REALLY APPLIED EDT PUT THE
STEPS THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN WITH
WEB ID ME AND WITH AND WITH-
THOMSON REUTERS WE HAVE OUR OWN
PROPRIETARY FILTERS THAT WE-
THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE EMPLOYED
IN TRYING TO DETECT THIS FRAUD
AND FRANKLY THAT IS WHERE WE
HAVE FOUND. RIGHT THAT THE
CARDS THAT THAT REMAIN FROZEN
IS WHERE WE HAVE FOUND THAT
THAT THAT PRODUCT SO I THINK I
THINK YOU KNOW WORKING TOGETHER
WITH THE V. D. AS WE HAVE YOU
KNOW IF THEY CLEAR- WHAT
THEY'VE DONE WITH THOMPSON
REUTERS WE CAN. WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO GET THAT I'M
PRESIDENT I THINK IT IS YOU
KNOW IN A QUICKER WAY- BECAUSE
OF WHAT HE DID DOING WE CAN'T
WE CAN'T IDENTIFY MISTER WORK
VERIFY. THE PLANE I INTERRUPT.
SHORTLY COULD I. YOU KNOW AS I
COULD GET THAT HERE YOU YOUR X
IT SEEMS THAT YOU ARE
SUGGESTING THAT THERE'S FRAUD
BEYOND AMERICA CONTROL AND OF
THAT TO ADVANTAGE OF TOP AND
WHEN AFTER EDT SO ONE. ONE
QUESTION THAT THE PUBLIC IS
ASKING US EVERY DAY AS YOU WELL
KNOW IS THESE DEBIT CARDS THESE
EDYTA CARDS AT YOUR BANK HAS
PROVIDED DO NOT INCLUDE EMV
CHIP TECHNOLOGY AND YOUR OWN
WEBSITE SAYS THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
TWENTY YEARS IT'S THE CREDIT
AND DEBIT CARD SECURITY
STANDARD IN MANY COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN YOUR BANK
ANNOUNCED THAT YOU WOULD
INCLUDE EMV CHIPS AND ALL NEW
AND REISSUED CONSUMER DEBIT
CARDS. SOMEHOW THOUGH FOR THE
LAST SIX YEARS BANK OF AMERICA
EDT DATA CARDS TO INCLUDE THESE
ANTI FRAUD EMV CHIPS FOR
SECURITY AND MY CONSTITUENTS
ARE SAYING HOUSE AT THE BANK OF
AMERICA TREATS US LIKE SECOND
CLASS CITIZENS WHEN IT COMES TO
FRAUD. WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE
TO. WELL MY RESPONSE IS THAT
THE CHIPS WOULD DO VERY LITTLE
IF ANYTHING. FOR THE TYPE OF
PRODUCT WAS TALKING ABOUT- IT
WHICH IS VERY USEFUL IN A
CONTACT THE TRANSACTIONAL
FRAUD. RIGHT BECAUSE- I CAN'T
BE CAN'T BE COPIED ILLEGALLY OR
OR CAN BE CAN BE DUPLICATED MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE ON THE CALL
CAN TELL YOU MORE ABOUT CHIP.
TECHNOLOGY AND WHY WE MADE THE
DECISIONS WE MAKE THAT BUT I. I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THAT THAT
COME UP STANDPOINT OF DETECTING
BENEFITS CRIED. IF I IF I GO TO
THE V. P. AND I AND I USED TO
FEED THEM. AND THEY ISSUE ME A
CARD WHETHER IT'S GOT A CHIP OR
NOT. IT'S GOING TO IT'S GOING
TO I I'VE STILL GOT A I'VE GOT
AN ACCOUNT. THAT I SHOULDN'T
HAVE. THAT SO THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PRIDE THAT WE HAVE BEEN WE
SEAT BY THE WAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WE- WE SEE TRANSACTIONAL CRIED.
IN THE COURT OF. OF OUR WORK
HERE AND WE CAN MONITOR THAT
VERY CLOSELY. AND BUT THAT
TRANSACTIONAL PRODUCT QUITE
FRANKLY VERY CLOSE TO IF NOT
ALMOST THE SAME. AS THE TYPE OF
TRANSACTIONAL PRIDE THAT WE SEE
IN OUR IN OUR NORMAL CARD
BUSINESS. GO GO AND I THINK YOU
KNOW I. I DO THINK THAT THE
CHIP TECHNOLOGY IS A BIT OF A-
RED HERRING AS IT RELATES TO.
HELLO RELATE TO BENEFIT FROM.
YEAH SO WHAT CAN I. NUMBER TWO
WHY MADE THE TRIP. YEP STEPS IF
I IF I COULD JUST TO MY
COLLEAGUES. OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SAY IS THAT THE THAT
THE FRAUD HAS. HERE THAT HAS
BEEN. BUT AS VICTIMIZED EDT
SMALLS OURSELVES AND THE STATE
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IT
HAPPENS WELL BEFORE. THANKS OF
ALL THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
BENEFITS LEGIBILITY AND THAT'S
WHY GOTTEN. AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED HIS DISCUSSIONS WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. ONE PERSON
POINTED OUT TO US THAT THE
SOPHISTICATED NETWORKS HAVE
BEEN SITTING. ON TOP OF
MILLIONS OF IDPS THREE YEARS
LOOKING FOR THIS TYPE OF
OPPORTUNITY SO IS OF A SCALE
AND OF A TYPE BUT NO ONE HAS
EVER SEEN BEFORE. AND WITH
RESPECT TO YOU TO YOUR TO YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT- CHIPS PURPOSES
OF MAG STRIPES. REMEMBER THE
MAGS MAGNETIC STRIP OF MAGNETIC
STRIP. I BELIEVE MY COLLEAGUE-
ANSWERED IT AND IT HAS A EVEN
AS A SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT
WOULD SAY. IF SOMEONE POSSESSES
AN ACCOUNTS IT DOESN'T MATTER
IF THE UNDERLYING CARD IS A
CHIP OR A STRIKE. BECAUSE THEY
ARE IN POSSESSION OF THE
ACCOUNT ITSELF AND THEY CAN
STEP OUT OF THE WAY THEY WANT
THEY CAN BRING THE CARDS- IT'S
ONLY WHEN SOMEONE TRIES TO-
BASICALLY COPY A CAR THAT'S
BEING USED. ON BEHALF OF
LEGITIMATE CLAIM THAT THAT THE
CHIP STARTS TO HAVE AN IMPACT
ON TRANSACTIONAL FRAUD. THE
ORIGINAL RP THAT YOU REFERENCED
SINCE YOU YOU HAVE IT AND YOU
BROUGHT IT. THE ORIGINAL RP
REQUESTS MAGNETIC STRIP STRIP
CARDS A MAGNETIC STRIPE CARDS-
SO THAT'S WHAT THE. ORIGINAL RP
REQUESTED BEHALF THE PROGRAM.
DO YOU AGAIN FEEL THAT THOUGH
THE BANK OF AMERICA HAS
EMPLOYED THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SECURITY FRAUD SAFEGUARDS THE
SITUATION. EXACTLY THANK YOU I.
I DO AS FAR AS WE I WILL BE
ERY CANDID WITH YOU WE ALONG
WITH I THINK EVERYONE LAW
ENFORCEMENT EVERYBODY HAS BEEN
PLAYING CATCH UP ON THAT WE
HAVE DEPLOYED. SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES AND- ON THAT AND BY
THE WAY IT'S NOT JUST
CALIFORNIA ALONG CALIFORNIA
BEING THE SEVENTH LARGEST
ECONOMY ON THE PLANET IT IS IT
IS IT IS HUGE HERE. WE PROVIDE
THIS SERVICE TO OTHER STATE AND
WE HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM-
ACROSS THAT PORTFOLIO SO I
THINK I THINK WHAT WAS YOUR-
THE REALITY IS I THINK WE HAVE
FIGURED OUT HOW TO TRY TO
DETECT IT NOW THE PROBLEM IS NO
DETECTION. METHODOLOGY IS
PERFECT AND CAN CATCH INNOCENT
PEOPLE AND THEN THAT AND SO
FIGURING OUT HOW TO GET THOSE
INNOCENT PEOPLE OUT OF THAT AND
THAT AND GET THE MONEY THAT
THEY THEY SO DESPERATELY NEEDED
IS CRITICAL AND THAT THAT FOR
WORKING WITH THE EDT. BOND
VERIFICATION- OF IDENTITY AND
ELIGIBILITY IT'S SO KEY BECAUSE
ONCE TAT HAPPENS WE. CAN THEN
MOVE RELATIVELY QUICKLY. I TO
FOLLOW UP ON ON THE SITUATION
AND IN OUR WE IT WILL GIVEN
WHAT IS HOW. THERE ARE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
THAT ARE FAR FAR WORSE OFF AND-
I KNOW IN THE AGREEMENT BETWEEN
BANK OF AMERICAN EDT. YOUR BANK
COMMITTED TO A- RELIABILITY
POLICY FOR THE AUTHORIZED USER
BDD DEBIT CARDS AND- YOU
COMMITTED TO EDT CARD HOLDERS
THAT THEY WOULD NOT INCUR ANY
LIABILITY FOR THE UNAUTHORIZED
USE OF THE CAR I'M SURE YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THIS. BUT AS YOU
CAN LIKELY IMAGINE WE'RE
HEARING FROM MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS THAT THEIR CLAIMS
ARE SUMMARILY REJECTED OR
SIMPLY IGNORED WE'VE HAD EDT
CARDHOLDERS WHO REPORT
UNAUTHORIZED TRANSACTIONS. EVEN
THOUGH THEIR CARDS ARE
ACTIVATED OR EVEN USED AND SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION TO YOU IS.
YOU CAN TELL US RIGHT NOW OF
COURSE WE'RE ADDRESSING THESE
CLAIMS BUT WE'RE NOT HEARING
THAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
THOUSAND CONSTITUENTS FOR
THOMAS THE OPPOSITE. HOW CAN WE
AS POLICYMAKERS HOW CAN THE
PUBLIC HAVE A TRULY TRANSPARENT
COUNTING THAT- THAT INDIVIDUAL.
EDT HOPE- CARDHOLDERS ARE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO RESOLVE THEIR
CLAIMS AND HAVE ZERO LIABILITY.
YEAH SO FIRST OF ALL. LOOK
AGAIN WEEK WEEK WE RECOGNIZE
THE SCALE OF THE- REALLY THE
SCALE OF THE ISSUE AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S IMPACTING
INDIVIDUALS THAT'S NOT LOST ON
US IN ANYWAY THAT'S WHY WE
COMMITTED THOUSANDS OF
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO BOTH BE
CALL CENTERS AS WELL AS THE
CLAIMS PROCESSING. AND
EDUCATION UNITS THAT LOOK AT
EACH CORNER. I WOULD ALSO SAY.
THAT IF A CLAIM IS REJECTED. WE
SENT A CLAIM IN A LETTER
BECAUSE AT THAT POINT WE DO
HAVE THEIR CONTACT INFORMATION.
AND WE AGREE THAT THE CLAIMANT
WANTS TO REVISIT THE REJECTION
OF THE CLAIM. WE WILL
AUTOMATICALLY DO SO AND WE WILL
RECONSIDER THE CLAIM AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. WE DO ASK THE
CLINTON FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. BUT WE COMMIT TO
THAT AND WE COULD WE WILL
CONTINUE TO COMMIT TO THAT. IF
WE RECEIVE THE INFORMATION WE
NEED TO APPROVE A CLAIM WE
PROVIDE IMMEDIATELY. BUT THOSE
ARE ALL THE STEPS WE'VE TAKEN
AND WILL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW THE
STEPS- WORKED WITH RESPECT TO
THIS RELIABILITY BECAUSE OF
POLICY TRANSACTION FRAUD. WE
HOPE THAT POLICY IF IT'S A
LEGITIMATE CLAIM THAT.
LEGITIMATE CARD AND SOMEONE
HAS. USED HER CARD. A DIFFERENT
LOCATION IN AUTHORIZED MATTER
WE INVESTIGATE AND WE- REFUND
OR CREDIT THE FUNDS BACK TO THE
CAP. BUT WE DO. HOW MANY
REJECTIONS HAVE YOU SENT OUT AT
THIS POINT TO CLAIMS. I WOULD
HAVE TO GO BACK TO THAT
INFORMATION. OKAY I THINK THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL BECAUSE WE
WE'RE HEARING VERY DIFFERENTLY
FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS AND I
DON'T WANNA GET INTO THE BACK
AND FORTH THAT YOU HAD WITH
MISTER TANG ABOUT CUSTOMER
SERVICE BUT WHAT I CAN TELL YOU
IS WHAT YOU DESCRIBED AS FAR AS
THOUSANDS OF BANK OF AMERICA
EMPLOYEES ASSISTING CUSTOMERS
IS A VERY DIFFERENT. REALITY
FROM WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND IF I COULD
JUST QUOTE A RECENT ARTICLE IN
CALMATTERS FROM A BANK OF
AMERICA CUSTOMER SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVE WHO SAID QUOTE
WE'RE ACTUALLY NOT ALLOWED TO
TELL CUSTOMERS A TIMEFRAME
BECAUSE WE HAVE NO CLUE EVERY
DAY I TALKED TO THREE PEOPLE
WITH THE SAME STORY I PRAY FOR
THEM AFTER MY SHIFT MARKETS.
IT'S NOT JUST OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE TELLING US IT'S YOUR
EMPLOYEES. WHO BUT IN SAYING
THAT THE SERVICES ARE ADEQUATE
SO I JUST WANNA ONE STATE THAT.
YOU WANT ONE FINAL QUESTION FOR
YOU I KNOW YOU WERE ASKED A
QUESTION OF. HOW MUCH AS
BANKAMERICA MADE DURING THIS
TIME PERIOD. COULD YOU TELL US
BEFORE THIS YEAR. HOW MANY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO BANK OF
AMERICA MAKE ON FEES GENERATED
BY THE USE OF EDT DEBIT CARD
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PROGRAM. IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION WITH ME. OKAY IF
YOU COULD PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL- AND I WOULD ALSO ASK
AROUND CUSTOMER SERVICE I THINK
WE ARE HAVING A SERIOUS
DISCONNECT OUR- EXPERIENCE WE
ARE STAYING IN ON OUR END IS
THAT OUR- CONSTITUENTS ARE NOT
BEING ADDRESSED. BY YOUR
CUSTOMER SERVICE YOU ARE SAYING
THE OPPOSITE. CAN YOU PROVIDES
INFORMATION TO ASSURE US. THAT
STATISTICS OF HOW MANY CALLS
ARE BEING ANSWERED WITHIN WHAT
TIME PERIOD HOW LONG IT TAKES
RESOLVE CASES- REJECTION RIGHT-
THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING
BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T HAVE ANY
DISABILITY. I CAN UNDERSTAND
YOU DON'T TO THE BILL
VISIBILITY. WILL WORK WITHOUT
BRIAN BUTLER TEAM TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH THIS ABILITY. OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT SOME I WANT TO
ASK REALLY SORT OF ONE QUESTION
TO- MATTER DIRECTOR- AND MAKE A
COMMENT AND FIRST OF ALL AS I
SAID BEFORE JUST APPRECIATE
YOUR ENGAGEMENT TO. I WANT TO
SAY YOU KNOW WITH WITH YOUR
TEAM VERTICALLY WITH MISS
WILLIAMS AND THAT'S FOR ITS-
I'M HOPEFUL THAT THERE IS A
LEADERSHIP TEAM THAT I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE MORE
RESPONSIVE THAN THE TEAM WE
HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH IN THE
PAST. BUT A COMMENT- IT WHEN
YOU WERE DISCUSSING THE BACKLOG
WITH MISTER SALAS. I WOULD JUST
SAY THIS IS A QUESTION THAT HAS
ARISEN AT EVERY SINGLE HEARING
IT'S BEEN REALLY DIFFICULT FOR
US TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
BACKLOG IS. THE NUMBERS NOT
ONLY KEEP CHANGING BUT- WERE
CONFUSED AS TO WHAT'S IN AND
WHAT'S OUT SO I JUST SUGGEST.
THAT AS MUCH COMMUNICATION YOU
CAN PROVIDE. US ON THAT AS
REGULARLY AS YOU CAN WOULD BE
WITH THE INCREDIBLY HELPFUL. I
WANT TO I DO WANT TO ASK ONE
QUESTION AROUND WHERE ARE WE
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
STRIKE TEAM REPORT YOU KNOW-
THAT I HAD SENT IN A LETTER.
SIGNED BY SEVENTY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES THAT HAD SUGGESTED
THE STRIKE TEAM WERE HAPPY WHEN
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT WITH THAT-
WE THOUGHT THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE SENSE.
YOUR PREDECESSOR HAD COMMITTED
TO US THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
SEND US REGULAR UPDATES OF
WHERE THE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED AN UPDATE
IN QUITE SOME TIME TO ONE HOUR
STAND WHERE WE'RE- ALL. HEY
YEAH I HAVE THAT IN FOR. WHEN
SHE PARK AND WE WERE. YOUR
CHECK CAN'T FIND IN MIND. I
CAN'T YEAH KNOW THAT WE HAVE
DONE A BIT AND YOU START YOU SO
APART IF- IF WE MISUNDERSTOOD
AND YOU WORKS TO DO. OBJECT WE
HAVE ABSOLUTELY BEEN PUTTING UP
THE EVERY OTHER WEEK ON OUR
WEBSITE WE CAN MAKE THAT
AVAILABLE TO YOU IN THE PUSH OR
YOU KNOW SEND. IT IF THAT'S
WHAT YOUR MOTHER WOULD LIKE BUT
THEY'VE BEEN AVAILABLE ON THE-
EDT WEBSITE EVERY WEEK EVERY
OTHER WEEK WE MAKE UPDATES SO
TO GIVE YOU STEINORTH YOU KNOW
THERE'S ONE HUNDRED STRIKE
TEAM. RECOMMENDATIONS THERE WAS
SOME DUPLICATIONS AND- AT ONE
HOME. TO DATE WE HAVE COMPLETED
50% OF THOSE DIRECTING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND- WE'RE VERY
PLEASED WITH THAT- BASED ON
ALEJO'S TESTIMONY PURELY THERE
MUST BE SOME WITH YOU CAN GO
BACK AND LOOK AT NO PROBLEM DO
NOT. THE PICTURE COMPLETION IS
COMPLETION- SO. THAT'S THE
UPDATE BOARD AS OF TODAY.
SENATE WHEN THOSE REGULATIONS
WILL BE. YES WE ARE CAROL WE
DID HAVE IN MY TESTIMONY MMHM
SOME INFORMATION ON WHERE EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THE FORTY EIGHT.
TO FIFTY HAVE BEEN COMPLETED WE
HAD STARTED ONE OF THE MID TERM
ONCE. AND WE HAVE PRODUCTS ALSO
STARTED ON THE LONG TERM ONES
JUST CAN'T FIND IT IN MY OKAY
WE ARE OKAY LET ME GIVE THAT.
SO ALL THE FORTY TWO TERM
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED BY STAFF. THIRTY
EIGHT NEAR TERM RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE OUTLINED IN THE REPORT OF
BILLS. OUR HARD WORKING STAFF
HAVE COMPLETED 15% 73% ARE IN
PROGRESS. AND TWELVE HAD NOT
YET BEEN STARTED. NEAR TERM
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ANTICIPATED
TO REQUIRE BETWEEN THREE MONTHS
AND A YEAR TO IMPLEMENT. OF THE
LAW OF THE TEN LONG TERM
RECOMMENDATIONS 10% ARE
COMPLETE AND 90% ARE IN
PROGRESS. THESE LONG TERM
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ANTICIPATED
TO TAKE ABOUT A YEAR WE HAVE A
STRIKE TEAM AND INTERNAL STRIKE
TEAM THAT MEETS REGULARLY TO
STRATEGIZE AND DIRECT EFFORTS.
TO ACCELERATE THE COMPLETION.
OF THE STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS AND TO.
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY ALTHOUGH
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
WE NEED A BETTER STRATEGY SO
THE LEGISLATURE CAN WILL FORM
WE HAVE ALSO INCLUDED STRIKING
RECOMMENDATION TRACKER ON. THE
WEBSITE AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
ACCELERATING THE COMPLETION. OF
THE STRIKE TEAM RECOMMENDATIONS.
GREAT WHAT ONE QUESTION I
RELAYED TO I KNOW ONE OF THE
DASHBOARDS IT'S OUT THERE IS IT
APPEARS THAT FROM THE SECOND
WEEK OF THIS MONTH. THERE WERE
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND NEARLY
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND UNIQUE
CALLERS BUT ONLY SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THOSE CALLS WERE
ACTUALLY ANSWER BY STAFF. COULD
YOU TELL US WHAT HAPPENS TO
THOSE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
OTHER CALLERS I MEAN I'M
ASSUMING THAT IS WHY OUR STAFF
FOR LEGISLATIVE STAFFER WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK I WANTED TO
UNDERSTAND FROM YOU WHAT WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING WITH THE
SCHOLARS. CAROL ABSOLUTELY SO
AS WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING-
SINCE THE FALL SINCE AND PRIOR
TO ME JOINING CALL CENTER THE
CONTACT CENTER ABSOLUTELY NEEDS
TO IS UP TO BE MODERNIZED- AS
YOU ALSO AWARE. MORE CALLS THE
STAFF COULD HANDLE WE'VE
BROUGHT ON IN- BUT- WE HAVE
RESUMED HIRING IF YOU RECALL
FIFTEEN RECOMMENDED WE SEIZE
ALL HIRING THIS WAS IN
SEPTEMBER AND WILL ALLOW THE
MORE EXPERIENCED STAFF TO
ACTUALLY WORK ON THE CLAIMS
RESOLVED THE CLAIMS AND SO THAT
GAP CREATED A GAP IN SERVICE.
IN ONE THAT- STILL EXIST TODAY.
A PRIMARILY BECAUSE ON ANY
GIVEN WEEK. WE WERE SAVE
UPWARDS OF THREE MILLION CALLS
THREE MILLION CALLS WE HAVE-
SURE I HAVE THE STAMPING NUMBER
HERE IN FRONT OF ME- WELL WE
ARE ABOUT TO HIRE. TWO HUNDRED
MORE PEOPLE THE STAFF CUSTOMER
SERVICE SO TO ME WHAT RHETORIC
WHAT'S MORE PRESSING IN THIS
IS- YOU'LL HEAR A LOT MORE
ABOUT THIS FROM US IS IT WILL
NEVER HAVE ENOUGH EMPLOYEES FOR
THE CLAIMANTS THAT NEED US- THE
PAST THE PRESENT THE FUTURE ANY
MODERN DAY CONTACT CENTER. YOU
DON'T YOU DON'T STAFF ABOUT
WHAT YOU DO IS YOU PARTNER A
WELL FUNCTIONING CONTACT CENTER
WE ARE STILL IN THAT STATE
PREPARE WITH ROBUST AUTOMATION
SELF SERVICE TOOLS THAT A
PERSON COULD DO. ANYTHING THAT
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEE COULD DO
NEEDS TO BE REMOVED FROM THEIR-
YOU KNOW FROM THEIR TRAINING
MANUAL I MEAN WE ALLOW THAT
AUTOMATION TO HAPPEN WE ARE
MODERNIZING THE CONTEXT AND WE
FINALLY STOOD UP THE COMMAND
CENTER- YOU PROBABLY YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD ABOUT THIS IN
OCTOBER DURING THE TESTIMONY.
SO THAT. THE COMMAND CENTER
WILL BE FULLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALL THE TRAINING FOR ALL THE
MODERNIZATION OF TOTALS WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY INTERESTED IN
BRINGING IN THE VIRTUAL HOLD
TECHNOLOGY WHICH ALLOWS. A
COLOR. TO ACTUALLY SCHEDULE A
CALL BACK NO EVEN WITH THAT
MODERN TECHNOLOGY IF THEY'RE
STILL CAPACITY ISSUES BUT WE
THINK WITH THE ADVANCEMENT IN
THE PASSAGE OF TIME THERE'S
TECHNOLOGY THAT TO ACTUALLY
WORK FOR EATING. SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE INVOLVED IN RIGHT NOW
WHEN IT COMES TO CONTACT
CENTERS YES COLORS ARE STILL
WAITING FOR HOURS. THEY ARE WE
HAVE FINALLY MODERNIZE THE
PLATFORM THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE WHOLE TWO ONE TO HEAR
TO ISSUE SO THERE IS ONE
PLATFORM THAT ALL OF OUR
CONTACT CENTRE STAFF. OR
FUNDING ON AND THAT'S WORKING
FINE WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED
TECHNOLOGY THAT ALLOWS IT'S
CALL. SMART ROUTING AND IT
SHOULD LITERALLY IT'S STILL IN
ITS INFANCY TAKE THE CALL TO
WHERE THEY NEED TO GO. BASED ON
THEIR PROFILE IN THEIR HISTORY
AND WHAT THEIR TRUE NEEDS ARE
WHERE THEY. ARE IN OUR SYSTEM
THEY DON'T HAVE TO KEEP. LIVING
THROUGH THE LEVELS STAFF. SO
I'LL STOP THERE AND LET'S. AND
YOU CAN IN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THAT. EACH E. G. R. HAS GOTTEN
ANY MAJOR UPGRADES IN AT LEAST
TEN YEARS. THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS UNDER WHICH IT
OPERATES HAVE NOT BEEN REVIEWED
LOOK FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS. AND WE
THIS IS THIS IS A NEW DAY AND
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE BETTER SHAPE
UP HERE. ARE WE NEED TO DO MORE
EDUCATION OF PEOPLE WE NEED TO
SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS SAYS ARE
PEOPLE YOU KNOW I KNOW YOUR
YOUR OFFICE STAFF HAVE BEEN. I
CAN DEFICIT IN WORKING WITH OUR
STAFF TO HANDLE THESE CLAIMS I
GET CALLS. I GET EMAILS FROM
PEOPLE THIS IS JUST IT'S GOT TO
GET BETTER AND WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE IT BETTER. THANK YOU UP I
BY THE WELL JUST NOTICE YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE LAST TEN
YEARS- YOUR DEPARTMENT DID
RECEIVE. TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WENT TO
THE DEVOID CONSULTANCY TO
UPGRADE YOUR I. T. SINCE THE
GREAT RECESSION WITH OBVIOUSLY
VERY LITTLE. YOU THAT- YOU HAVE
IN THE LEGISLATOR VERY WILLING
PARTNERS TO BOTH WORK WITH YOU
TO OPERATE THAT TECHNOLOGY AND
TO SIMPLIFY WHAT YOU JUST
REFERENCED I KNOW I THINK IT
WORKS WITH OTHER QUESTIONS. I
JUST WANNA ASK ONE FINAL
QUESTION TO MYSTERIUM SANTANA-
BECAUSE I IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ME
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE ISSUE OF LANGUAGE ACT. AND
40% OF CALIFORNIA NOT SPEAK
ENGLISH AT HOME. WHEN THE
RECENT STRIKE TEAM REPORT
INDICATED THAT IF ENGLISH IS
NOT YOUR FIRST LANGUAGE YOU ARE
COMPLETELY COMPLETELY- UNABLE
TO ACCESS ITS EDT SYSTEM- THE
SYSTEM'S FAILURE TO ADDRESS
LANGUAGE ISSUES HAS BEEN VERY
STARK FOR ME BUSTS AND I'D LIKE
TO ASK A MIST SERUM SANTANA- I
KNOW YOUR TESTIMONY A LITTLE
CUT OFF BEFORE COULD YOU.
SKETCH OUT ABOUT WHAT YOU THINK
IS THE ROAD MAP FOR WHAT EDT
SHOULD DO WHEN IT COMES TO
LANGUAGE ACCESS. THANK YOU-
THIS ISN'T SHOWS CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES GREAT SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND
THESE- MY RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
NOT JUST MINE ALONE WE HAVE
WORKING WITH A COALITION OF
LANGUAGE ACCESS ADVOCATES AND
ATTORNEYS. SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE WANTED TO- LEAVE THE
COMMITTEE WITH IS THAT THERE IS
NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
IN PROVIDING LANGUAGE ACCESS IN
STATES AS DIVERSE AS
CALIFORNIA. AS THIS REQUIRES
EDT TO BE FLEXIBLE IN HOW IT
SERVES VARIOUS INTERESTING TO
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
AND THAT EDT SHOULD ACT UPON IT
EXERCISE THAT FLEXIBILITY IN
MEETING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WHO DO NOT SPEAK
THE DOMINANT LANGUAGES AND
COMMUNITIES WITH LOW LITERACY
UNLIMITED ACTIVE ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY THAT BEING SAID.
VERY PRACTICAL THINGS EDT COULD
DO ADDITIONAL LANGUAGES ON THE
PORTALS IN TEN TO TWELVE
WRITTEN LANGUAGES MOST SPOKEN
BY ELLIE PIECE OF THE STATE'S
ADDITIONAL DEDICATED TELEPHONE
LINES IN TEN TO TWELVE
LANGUAGES SPOKEN BY ELLIE PIECE
OF THE STATE. AND A AND WHAT
THE FOCUSED ON SERVING PEOPLE
WITH LOW LITERACY AND THAT
BELONG TO SMALL REQUESTED
GROUPS. IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
FEEL THE PDD SHOULD PRIORITIZE
EXPANDING ACCESS TO BENEFITS ON
THE PHONE LINES ONLINE IS NOT
ENOUGH IT MUST BE AUGMENTED BY
A ROBUST OF PHONE LINE WHERE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO REACH A
LIVE TRAINED STAFF MEMBERS BY
PHONE. AND IN A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME WHO IS EITHER
PROFICIENT AND THE COLORS
LANGUAGE ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
QUALIFIED INTERPRETERS AND SO
WE JUST ASK THAT THERE'S A
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH. FOR THE
DIVERSE CITY THAT EXISTS IN
CALIFORNIA THESE ARE SOME OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS. THAT WE
HAVE BUT ALSO. BUT THINGS LIKE
TRAINERS. SO THEY KNOW. HOW TO
USE THAT LANGUAGE LINE AND THEY
KNOW WHAT LANGUAGES- OFFERED
PROVIDE INTERPRETATION IN REAL
TIME WE WILL WE WERE TOLD. THAT
THAT WAS HAPPENING BUT WE JUST
DON'T SEE IT ON THE GROUND AND
WE WOULD ASK THAT THEY JUST
BASICALLY ACCEPT. APPLICATIONS
IN MORE THAN SPANISH AND
ENGLISH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND AGAIN APPRECIATE I HAVE A
MILLION OTHER QUESTIONS BUT
OBVIOUSLY I RESPECT THE TIME
AND OTHER COLLEAGUES LOOK FOR
THE CONTINUE CONVERSATION I
JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
THANK. ALL THE FRONT LINE
WORKERS WHO ARE WORKING ROUND
THE CLOCK TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION. WE HAVE TO REFORM
THE SYSTEM- AND WE WILL ONLY DO
IT IF WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER
WITH THAT MANAGER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN A CHU MISTER
LUCKY. YEAH THANK YOU ARE JUST
REAL QUICKLY I HAVE A QUESTION
FOR DIRECTOR SIGNS THE- THE
RECENT STATE AUDIT FOUND THAT
BECAUSE OF REDUCE TROUBLING
HANDLING OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. ROUGHLY TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION CLAIMANTS MAY NEED
TO REPAY SUCH BENEFITS TO THE
STATE BECAUSE EIGHTY D. DID NOT
PROPERLY ASSESS THE ELIGIBILITY
OF SUCH CLAIMS. OVER AN EIGHT
WEEK PERIOD ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION CLAIMANTS. MAY HAVE
INCORRECTLY RECEIVED FIVE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN BENEFITS. I MAY
HAVE TO REPAY THE STATE MY
QUESTION IS THERE. ANY KIND OF
PLAN TO ALLOW FOR REPAYMENT. OF
VISA THESE CLAIMS WHEN IT WAS.
YOUR NO FAULT OF THESE PEOPLE
AND THE CURRENT CONDITIONS IN
THE CURRENT ECONOMIC CLIMATE IS
VERY DIFFICULT I'M SURE MOST OF
THOSE. PAYMENTS HAVE BEEN
EXPENDED. SO I JUST WONDERED IF
THERE WAS ANY PLAN IN PLACE FOR
REPAYMENT. EDT IS GOING TO
VALUE THE CLAIMANT FIRST. AND
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE SITUATION WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT IT WE HAVEN'T COME TO A
FINAL CONCLUSION AND I PROMISE
YOU YOU'LL BE AMONG THE FIRST
TO KNOW I WOULD DECIDED TO
HANDLES WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR
SOME OF GUIDANCE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE'RE HOPING
THAT WE WILL NOW BE ABLE TO
HAVE A MORE RESPONSIVE-
RELATIONSHIP WITH DEAL WELL
WITH ADMINISTRATION. AND
OPERATION THIS ISSUE OURSELVES
SO I PROMISE YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACQUI WILL BE FIRST IN
LINE TO FIND OUT WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO LOOK FORTY HEARING
THAT THANK YOU. WHAT THANK YOU
MR LACKEY WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NECESSARY IN AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG. THE
CLOSEST OUT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I'M GONNA HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS AND THERE'S PROBABLY
BEEN A FEW OTHER QUESTIONS THAT
HAVE DEVELOPED OVER THE COURSE
OF THE HEARING SO FIRST OF ALL
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU
STEPPING UP TO THIS POSITION
DURING THIS CHALLENGING TIME
MISSED SIGNS AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR
TEAM AS WELL- GETTING RIGHT
INTO THE HEART OF THE QUESTIONS
I. ONE OF THE FIRST JUMP INTO.
SOMETHING THAT CAME UP DURING A
RECENT DVD CALLED SPECIFICALLY
ON. JANUARY TWENTY SECOND-
DURING A STAFF CALL EDT STATED
THAT IT TAKES AN AVERAGE OF
EIGHT TO TEN DAYS. AFTER FROZEN
CLAIMANT'S IDENTITY IS VERIFIED
TO RESUME PAYMENTS TO THEIR
ACCOUNT. WHY DOES THIS THE LATE
EXIST. AND WHAT CAN BE DONE TO
SHORTEN IT HOW MANY CLAIMANTS
HAVE EXCEEDED THE TEN DAY MARK.
SINCE VERIFICATION WITHOUT
PAYMENTS BEING RESUMED. DO WE
HAVE ANSWERS TO ANY OF THESE
QUESTIONS AND THIS IS JUST MY
FIRST QUESTION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I CAN ANSWER THAT NEED TO
VARIAS THAT EDT- SO THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO- WHAT WE SPOKE
ABOUT YOU KNOW A FEW MINUTES
AGO ON THE- THE STOP PAY THAT
WE DID BACK IN IN DECEMBER- AND
THAT THAT IS YOU KNOW ONCE ONCE
PEOPLE CLEAR ID ME- IT DOES
TAKE. YOU KNOW SOME TIME FOR US
TO GET THE FILES FROM I. D. ME
AND THEN FOR US TO PROCESS
THOSE FILES AND TO CHECK FOR
CERTIFICATION. THAT PROCESS IS
AUTOMATED NOW I MEAN WE SAY
ABOUT A WEEK SEVEN TO TEN DAYS
OR YOU KNOW WHATEVER THAT THAT
THAT YOU JUST MENTIONED BUT- IT
IS AUTOMATED NOW- SO. LET'S BE
SPECIFIC HERE THOUGH HOW MANY
CLAIMANTS HAVE EXCEEDED THE TEN
DAY MARK DO WE KNOW. I DON'T
KNOW OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD. I
DON'T KNOW THAT AND YOU GET
BACK TO ME ON THE- YEAH
ABSOLUTELY THANKS. THANK YOU-
AND IF YOU HAVE DATA THAT YOU
CAN PROVIDE TO ME BOTH
PERCENTAGE AS WELL AS RAW. THAT
EXPLAINS HOW MANY. CLAIMANTS
HAVE RECEIVED IT RIGHT AWAY OR
WITHIN HOW MANY DAYS I'D
APPRECIATE THAT AS WELL- TOOK
TO NOW THIS QUESTION IS MORE
FOR B. OF A WELL AS WELL AS AS
WELL AS WELL AS EDT BUT- TO
GAUGE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
FREEZE OF THE ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION CLAIMS. HOW MANY
VERIFIABLY FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AMONG
THOSE FROZEN. SO I CAN TAKE
THAT THAT QUESTION- THIS AGAIN
GOES BACK TO THE SPOTS THAT
WERE PLACED- AT THE END OF
DECEMBER- I BELIEVE THE NUMBER.
THAT HAVE COME THE NUMBER THAT
HAVE GONE THROUGH IDEA ME. AND
HAVE HAD THEIR ID VERIFIED OF
THE APPROXIMATELY JUST OVER ONE
MILLION HAS BEEN ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. ALL OF THOSE
THAT- ARE CONSIDERED CONSIDERED
FRAUDULENT I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT NUMBER OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD BUT I'M GOING TO SAY IT
WAS ABOUT SIX OR 7% THAT HAVE
TRIED TO GET THROUGH ID ME HE
THAT HAVE FAILED. REST OF THE
POPULATION- THERE ARE SOME THAT
HAVE OPENED UP THE EMAIL TRIED
TO GET ON THE LAKE- BUT I WOULD
SAY OVER HALF OF THE POPULATION
HAVE NOT ATTEMPTED TO GO
THROUGH IT ME. WAS AROUND ABOUT
NUMBERS YOU KNOW FROM FROM
YESTERDAY BUT BUT THE AND I CAN
GET CERTAINLY GIVE YOU THE MOST
UPDATED NUMBERS- AT ANYTIME BUT
THAT THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
AND LEST CAROL IF YOU KNOW
DIFFERENTLY BUT NO THAT'S-
THAT'S IT NANCY AND I WOULD
SUGGEST OR I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
ADD THAT- AFTER ARE. THE
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME WE-
GAVE EVERYONE THE ADDITIONAL
TIME TO GO THROUGH IT ME
BECAUSE THE WAIT TIMES SO AFTER
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH WE SHOULD
START TO REALLY SEE THE MEASURE
AND ATTRIBUTE FRAUD. OR UNDUE
INTEREST OR LACK OF NEEDING A
CLAIM TO A CERTAIN POPULATION
VERSUS THE POPULATION THAT HAS
ABSOLUTELY GONE THROUGH ITS
CERTIFIED- IN THAT WE- WILL BE
ABLE TO MAKE A PAYMENT TO. HELP
OKAY BUT- THESE NUMBERS WOULD
BE CRITICAL IF AGAIN. I CAN GET
RAW DATA NOT JUST THE
PERCENTAGES. OF AUGUST JUST. I
HAD AN THIS BEFORE ABOUT THIS
THIS PERCENT BEFORE. AND THAT
RIGHT THERE EXPLAINS ALSO. THE
CHALLENGES THAT MANY OF THE
CLAIMANTS ARE FACING WITH WHEN.
IF ONLY 67% SO FAR. YOU'VE SEEN
AS FRAUD CASES THAN- THERE ARE
MANY MORE INDIVIDUALS. THAT ARE
STILL WAITING FOR THEIR MONIES
TO BE FREED UP- IF I COULD IF I
COULD CLEAR FIVE THAT THOSE
CATEGORIES SO AS NANCY SAID.
THREE HUNDRED SOME THOUSAND
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY GONE THROUGH
AND- VALIDATED THEIR ID RIGHT
BUT THAT'S ALMOST ABOUT.
282930% THAT 70% THERE THAT'S
WHAT NANCY IS TALKING ABOUT
THEIR DIFFERENT CATEGORIES SOME
HAVE NOT ATTEMPTED SOMEONE OPEN
THE EMAIL- SOMEHOW IN SOME
START ANY PROCESS AND THEY COME
BACK ATER THERE'S OTHER
CATEGORIES WERE PERHAPS THEY'RE
IN PROCESS AND THEY'LL FINISH
BY FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH PERHAPS
THEY'LL ABANDON. SO WE CAN GIVE
YOU THE STRATIFICATION WE GET
IT EVERY NIGHT- THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. TO THE ENEMY GO
BACK. THE 67% IS FROM THE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. NUMBER ONE
MILLION IS FROM BUT WENT OVER
ONE BILLION OKAY. JUST TO BE ON
THE SAME PAGE I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE GET. NUMBERS
AND PERCENTAGES. AND THIS GOES
BACK TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO HAD BROUGHT UP
WEEK WE HAD TALKED ABOUT THIS
DURING THE OF SEPTEMBER AS WELL
AS A PREVIOUS HEARING. ON
GETTING REGULAR UPDATES- I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THESE UP
THESE UPDATES ARE BEING
PROVIDED ON THE WEBSITE BUT
IT'S- CRITICAL THAT WE GET IT
OURSELVES. SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
A CONTINUED OPEN COMMUNICATION
AND DIALOGUE I THINK THE
COMMUNICATION IS GONNA ADDRESS
A LOT OF THESE CHALLENGES- I
LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING THOSE
NUMBERS. OF CANDY EDT PUT A
NUMBER TO THE AMOUNT OF DOLLAR
BENEFITS THAT HAVE GONE UNPAID
TO FROZEN CLAIMS SINCE DECEMBER.
WELL AS YOU DON'T HAVE THE
SENSOR I'D I'D AGAIN I'D LIKE
TO GET THIS. ALONG WITH YOUR
OTHER. RESPONSES THAT I'LL BE
WAITING FOR. CAN YOU CAN YOU
ASK THAT QUESTION AGAIN I'M
SORRY SURE SURE CAN THE EDB PUT
A NUMBER TO THE AMOUNT OF
DOLLAR BENEFITS THAT HAVE GONE
UNPAID TO FROZEN CLAIMS SINCE
DECEMBER. I'M NOT SURE THAT I
HAVE THAT OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD WE CAN WE CAN GET YOU THAT
NUMBER. K. SO HE CAN PER THE
FINDINGS OF THE GOVERNOR'S EDT
STRIKE TEAM AND THE REPORT THEY
RELEASED ON- LAST SEPTEMBER-
PAGE SIXTY OF THE STRIKE TEAMS
FINAL ASSESSMENT STATES THAT
THE EDT HAS CONSISTENTLY MET US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR MANDATES
THAT THE RATE OF IMPROPER
PAYMENTS AND NOT EXCEED 10%
WITH AN IMPROPER PAYMENT RATE
OF EIGHT POINT. 2% BETWEEN
JULY. OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
AND JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- HOWEVER THOSE SAME
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS REQUIRE
THAT 87% OF FIRST TIME PAYMENTS
BE MADE WITHIN TWENTY ONE DAYS.
AND THAT'S A STANDARD THAT THE
EDT HAS NEVER MET IT WAS
SEVENTY FIVE POINT 6% FOR THE
FOURTH QUARTER PERIOD ENDING
MARCH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. EDT
HAS AN ENTIRE DEPARTMENT AND
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES DEVOTED
TO PREVENTING FRAUD OR IMPROPER
PAYMENTS WHILE NO SUCH
DEPARTMENT EXISTS OR- TO
PREVENT. UNDERPAYMENT BUT THE
MOST URGENT ISSUE FACING OUR
CONSTITUENTS IS NOT OVER
PAYMENT OF FRAUDULENT CLAIMS.
SIX MONTHS FROM NOW YOU CAN
INVESTIGATE AND CHARGE SOMEONE
WHO DID FRAUD IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY. SO WHAT YOU
CAN'T RECTIFY IS A FAMILY THAT
GETS AND THIS HAS BEEN NOTED ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS NOW BY MY
COLLEAGUES BUT- WHAT WE WON'T
BE ABLE TO RECTIFY IS A FAMILY
THAT GETS EVICTED THIS WEEK OR
A SENIOR THAT CAN AFFORD.
MEDICATION RIGHT NOW AND IT'S
CETERA. THE ED'S APPROACH TO
DATE HAS PRIORITIZED PREVENTING
A SMALL HANDFUL OF BAD ACTORS
THAT. FROM RECEIVING FUNDS AT
THE EXPENSE OF A SIGNIFICANTLY
LARGER NUMBER OF- LEGITIMATE
CLAIMANTS. SO THAT SAID. THE
STRIKE TEAM ADVICE EDT TOEHOLD
UNDERPAYMENT PREVENTION AND
HIGHER PRIORITY THAN
OVERPAYMENT PREVENTION. WHAT
STEPS HAS THE EDT TAKEN TO MEET
THIS RECOMMENDATION AND HOW
DOES THE SUSPENSION OF ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION CLAIMS
ADVANCE THIS GOAL. WE WOULD
LOVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
I DO NOT HAVE THAT ANSWER TODAY.
ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL POINTS.
I'M SORRY TO HEAR THAT- THAT
SAID I DO WANT TO ALSO TAKE A
MOMENT AND JUST RECOGNIZE THE
WONDERFUL WORK OF- A LOT OF
YOUR STAFFERS WHO HAVE DONE
TREMENDOUS WORK WHILE WE STILL
TILL TODAY GET CALLS FROM
CONSTITUENTS WHO SAY THAT A
EMPLOYEE I. D. D. D. SUGGESTED
THAT THEY CALL OUR OFFICE. HAS
BEEN ONGOING. I DO ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT MANY OF
YOUR STAFF HAVE WORK WORKED
EXTREMELY HARD IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO HELP SERVE SOME OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS. FOR
A MYRIAD OF REASONS THAT HAVE
BEEN OUTLINED TODAY WHETHER
TECHNOLOGY. OF WEATHER- THE-
CONFUSION DUE TO TECHNOLOGY DUE
TO NOT ABLE TO GET. THE RIGHT
TO THE RIGHT PLACE AT THE RIGHT
TIME OR OR MIX THINGS UP- AND
OR AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AGAIN POINTED OUT
LANGUAGE BARRIERS. SO I ALSO DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT I DO
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE MR SITE
MISS SIGNS. ON YOU IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS PRIORITIZING
THE NEED TO GET CLAIMANTS PAID
FIRST AND THEN THINK ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF HOW TO GO AFTER THE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE COMMITTED
FRAUD- I. YOU KNOW I FOUND DATA
COMMENTS FROM OUR BANKING
PARTNERS VERY INTERESTING-
MISTER FOX AND MR MAD. IBM I
WOULD HAVE EXPECTED THAT IN
ELEVEN YEARS. TEN YEARS. SINCE
WE'RE ONLY IN THE ELEVENTH YEAR
BY FEW DAYS- THAT WE WOULD HAVE
AND COMING FROM ONE OF THE
WORST ECONOMIC RECESSIONS
CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN. IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN WHEN YOU GOT YOUR
CONTRACT FROM REMEMBERING THIS
CORRECTLY. PART OF THE DESIGN
OF BRINGING YOU IN. PART OF THE
INTENT OF BRINGING YOU END WAS
ALSO TO UTILIZE THE CAPABILITY
OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR'S ABILITY
TO MANEUVER QUICKLY. AN
SECURITY SYSTEMS BECAUSE THE
BUREAUCRACY AND THE STATE HAS.
CAUSED QUITE A BIT OF
DEFICIENCIES AND INABILITY TO
MOVE FORWARD QUICKLY BUT ON THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. WITH ALL THE
PRECAUTIONS YOU TAKE. THERE WAS
A BENEFIT OF YOU COMING IN- AND
THIS IS WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO WAS TRYING TO
POINT OUT TO BECAUSE WHEN HE
ASKED A SPECIFIC QUESTION HE
WOULD RECEIVE THE SPECIFIC
RESPONSE FROM YOU MISTER FOX.
BUT THE INTENT OF WHAT HE WAS
SAYING WAS THAT YOU SIGNED A
CONTRACT THAT WOULD BRING TO
THE STATE A SERVICE THAT WOULD
OFFER THE BEST PROTECTION
INVOLVED IN THAT ELEVEN YEAR
PERIOD. AND SO- I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT HAS BEEN MET.
SUBSTANTIVELY NOR AT A PLACE OR
AT A LEVEL THAT HAS OFFERED THE
PROTECTION TO. OUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT THE STATE WAS LOOKING FOR
WHEN YOU WERE BROUGHT IN. AGAIN
YOU WERE BROUGHT IN AT A TIME
WHEN HE STATE WAS DEALING WITH
ONE OF THE WORST ECONOMIC
CALAMITIES. SO I EXPECT A LOT
BETTER OF A RESPONSE FROM BOTH
OF YOU. WHEN A QUESTION IS
COMING TO YOU TALKING ABOUT THE
VERY ESSENTIAL AREA. OF WHERE
YOU ARE AT THE FOREFRONT WHEN
YOU DEAL WITH SUCH A SENSITIVE
ISSUE OF. INDIVIDUALS BANK
ACCOUNTS. YOU ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF SECURITY. AND YOU
SHOULD HAVE TREATED YOUR STATE
PARTNERS AND ITS CONSTITUENTS
WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF.
CONCERNED AS YOU WOULD HAVE
ADDRESSING YOUR OWN CLIENTS- SO
MANY SIGNS YOU YOU HAVE A TALL
ORDER AHEAD OF YOU. TO ME THE
THREE BIGGEST ISSUES WHETHER
IT'S THE OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY
WHETHER IT'S WHETHER IT'S THE
CHANGE IN CULTURE THAT'S
GREATLY NEEDED IN THAT
DEPARTMENT. AND ALSO THE CHAIN
OF COMMAND WITHIN A
BUREAUCRACY. I WHICH WHICH IS
PART OF THE CULTURE. BECOMES
VERY INHIBITING FROM PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY. VENTURING OUT A
LITTLE BIT AND TRYING TO ADD
NEW TRIED TO DO NEW THINGS OR
BRING ATTENTION. TO CERTAIN
LACKING ISSUES I SEE THIS AS
BEING A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE NOW FOR. OF AT LEAST
SIX YEARS. AND I'VE HAD THE
BENEFIT OF SITTING THROUGH
THESE COMMITTEES THE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
COMMUNICATION SO MUCH OF THESE
PROBLEMS WILL GET HANDLED
QUICKLY. WHEN COMMUNICATION IS
N. WHEN WE'RE COMMUNICATING
WITH ONE ANOTHER EFFECTIVELY-
SO WITH THAT I DON'T KNOW IF-
IF THE BANK OF AMERICA
REPRESENTATIVES HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON WHAT I'VE JUST
POSTED THEM BUT WANT ONE
QUESTION SPECIFIC I DO HAVE FOR
THEM IS. WHAT IS THE PROCESS OF
GETTING CLAIMANTS PAID. ONCE
THEY HAVE BEEN CLEARED. I WANT
TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE
PROCESS IS AND HOW MANY DAYS IT
TAKES. OKAY SO ON AVERAGE FOR
YOUR OR YOUR FRIENDS YOUR
CLIENTS WHOSECARS BEING FROZEN
OR YOU'RE REFERENCING EIGHT
EIGHT YOU CLIP IT TO THE
PROGRAM. YOU CAN ANSWER BOTH I
MEANT FOR THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE HAD THEIR ACCOUNT FROZEN
BUT YOU CAN ANSWER BOTH BECAUSE
I'D BE INTERESTED TO KNOW THE
DISTINCTION. OKAY SO FOR A NEW
CLIMATE. WE MAKE PAYMENT THE
MOMENT THE SAME DAY AS WE
RECEIVE INSTRUCTION FROM THE
EDT THAT MAKE PAYMENTS TO THE
CLINTON. SO BOTH THE FILES
RECEIVED A TUESDAY. OF THE
EIGHT THE OTHER CARDS ARE
LOADED ON TUESDAY LATEST
WEDNESDAY SO IT'S SAME DAY OR
NEXT DAY. FOR CARDS THAT HAVE
BEEN- REFER CLAIMANTS WHOSE
CARS WERE FROZEN AT THE EDT HAS
VERIFIED. THEIR ACCOUNT AND
VERIFY THAT THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE CLAIM. I BELIEVE AT
THIS POINT I FOR THE HE DID THE
STATE'S ALSO BEING RUN THROUGH
HOW THOMSON REUTERS AS WELL
WHICH- IS A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN INSTANT IN FRAUD
AND SECURITY ROUTES BROUGHT
THAN. ON AVERAGE VIDEO CARD IS
A FROZEN THE FOLLOWING DAY. ON
EXCEPTIONS. I DON'T KNOW IF I
MISSED SOMETHING BUT EIGHT
EIGHT SORRY I SO HOW LONG DOES
IT TAKE. D. WEISS. AND A NUMBER
OF DAYS. SO OR A NEW PERRIN YOU
CLAIM IT IS THE SAME DAY OR THE
NEXT DAY. FOR AN EXISTING
CLIENT BUT WHOSE CARD OR
ACCOUNT HAS BEEN FROZEN. AS A
RESULT SUSPICION OF BENEFITS
LEGIBILITY FRAUD. IF THE EDT
KIRKLIN S. PROVIDED WHAT THEY
NEED TO THE EDT. AND THE
CLAIMANTS LEGIBILITY HAS BEEN
VERIFIED. ON AVERAGE THAT CLAIM
IT HAS ACCESS TO THE FUNDS ON
THE CARD THE FOLLOWING DAY ONE
DAY. THERE ARE ALWAYS
EXCEPTIONS AS A RESULT THE TYPE
OF ROBERT FACING. BUT ON
AVERAGE IT IS THE NEXT DAY SHIP
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A
BREAKDOWN OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE BEEN VERIFIED. AND
THEY SHOULD BE RECEIVING THEIR
PAYMENT THERE'S NO OUTSTANDING
QUESTION THEY'VE BEEN VERIFIED
THEY'VE BEEN VETTED EVERYTHING
HAS BEEN. IT'S JUST A MATTER OF
EXECUTION OF THE CHECK TO BE
RECEIVED BY THEM. CAN YOU.
PROVIDE NUMBERS TO US TO THE
CHAIR AND TO MYSELF AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WHAT WHAT
THE BREAKDOWN IS OF HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE THEIR
CHECKS OR THEIR PAYMENTS-
WITHIN. WHAT PERIOD OF DAYS. IF
IT'S A ONE DAY I. START OKAY
START OPTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
DO WANT TO CLARIFY THE- CHECKS
ARE SENT DIRECTLY BY THE EDT-
TO CLEMENS UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE CHECKS ARE SENT WE ARE
NOT INVOLVED WITH THAT PROCESS.
BUT BUT TO THE WHEN THE
ACCOUNTS ARE UNFROZEN OR WHEN
THE ACCOUNTS ARE- MADE HOLE
WITH THE SUMS THAT WERE
COMMITTED TO I DON'T WANT TO
GET STUCK ON A HICK UP OF THE
WRONG TERMINOLOGY. SO IN IN THE
AREAS THAT YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE
AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
FUNDING IS PUT IN PLACE WARM.
THE CLAIMANT IS MADE WHOLE I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW MANY
DAYS IT TAKES. I THINK THE BEST
THING THAT WOULD LOOK AT WHAT I
WOULD SUGGEST IS WE WORK WITH
EDTA YEAH WE PROVIDE YOU WITH A
RESPONSE. TO YOUR TO YOUR
QUESTIONS BECAUSE IT SPANS MORE
THAN ONE MEANS OF PAYMENT TO
EQUIPMENT. OKAY I WHEN CAN I
EXPECT THAT. WHAT WILL HAVE TO
DISCUSS THE I'M SURE WE'LL TRY
TO PROVIDE RESPONSES TO YOU AT
ALL BASED. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU MISTER MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN AND THINK
THERE'S A SERIES OF QUESTIONS
BOTH FOR BANK OF AMERICA N. EDT
THAT NEED A LOT OF FOLLOW UP
AND WILL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO
THAT AS WELL. I WANT TO BE
CONSCIENTIOUS OF TIME THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION MUCH NEEDED
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF PEOPLE ARE
WAITING ON PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR WAITING. UP
MR FONG. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I WILL TRY TO BE
BRIEF- I JUST HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS I WANT TO ASK THEM.
TO- A TO THE E. D. TO THE
DIRECTOR- YOU KNOW AS YOU CAN
HEAR FROM MY COLLEAGUES AND
MYSELF- WE ARE CHANNELING. OUR
CONSTITUENTS IS- FRUSTRATION
AND ANXIETY I THOUGHT YOU HAD
MENTIONED AND- AND I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE I HEARD IT CORRECTLY-
IN THIS COURT AND THE STATEMENT
WAS MADE BY THE DIRECTOR. OF
THE D. THAT YOU THAT YOU HAD
SAID THAT THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS OF THE EDT. HAVEN'T
BEEN REVIEWED IN EIGHTEEN YEARS
IS THAT CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT
SO I MEAN OF COURSE THIS IS
YOUR PREDECESSOR YOUR NEW WITH
THE NEW AND NEW MANAGEMENT TEAM.
WHY HOW DID THAT HAPPEN HOW IS
THAT POSSIBLE YOU KNOW THE
RULES YOU KNOW VERSIONS OF AN
AGENCY AS IT AS IMPORTANT AS HE
D. THAT'S DELIVERING. BENEFITS
TO THOSE WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED HOW
IS THAT POSSIBLE THAN EIGHTEEN
YEARS. THAT THERE WAS NO REVIEW
OF THE RULES AND REGULATIONS OF
THE OPERATION OF YOUR
DEPARTMENT OR LEVEL LET ME GIVE
YOU A- LITTLE BACKGROUND WHEN I
TOOK OVER THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. WHAT WE
CONDUCTED A REVIEW OF ALL OF
OUR RULES AND REGULATIONS. AND
HOW THEY RELATED TO THE FEDERAL
RULES AND REGULATIONS. MY
EXPERIENCE IN GOVERNMENT IS
DATA ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT BE AWARE OF
IS THAT. THE AMOUNT OF STAFF AT
LEADING LUXURY WAIT WITH ME OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT. SITUATION. YOU
HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SOME HISTORY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. WHO ARE NOT CAUGHT
UP. IN OUR JUDGMENT OUR TRYING
TO ACCOMMODATE FOR NEW LAWS NEW
RULES NEW REGULATIONS. FOR IS
USUAL- I THINK THIS IS WHAT
GOVERNMENT PEOPLE ARE SO BUSY
DOING WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO NOW.
THEY DON'T THE EITHER IT
DOESN'T TO THEM OR THEY DON'T
CONVERT THE TALK TO DO THAT. WE
NEED TO DO THAT. AND IT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I'M GOING TO
BE A WORK OF MY STAFF ON AYE.
IS A QUESTION THAT I THE REASON
THAT I KNOW HOW LONG IT'S BEEN
IS BECAUSE I ASKED. HOW LONG IT
HAD BEEN. SO THIS IS SOMETHING
ELSE THAT I'M TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION IN TERMS OF.
WHETHER ANY OF OUR RULES AND
REGULATIONS. ARE INITIATED BY.
WE HAD MINISTRATION WORK A
LEGISLATURE. NEEDS ARE IN. PART
RESPONSIBLE FOR SOME OF THE
WHAT APPLICANTS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE- PRIVATE SECTOR GO
THROUGH. IN ORDER TO GET.
THROUGH THE SYSTEM. SO I THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE EIGHT THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE A QUICK.
REVIEW- I'VE GOT TO DOING. SO I
HEAR YOU'RE AND I. S. ON THE
HELLO FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND MY COLLEAGUES WILL BE
WORKING WITH YOU AS AS YOU CAN
HEAR- HONOR AND A REAL TIME
BASIS. ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
BECAUSE IN SOME SENSE IF YOU IF
FOR THE PUBLIC THAT'S LISTENING
THIS IS A REFLECTION OF
LEADERSHIP AND THAT PART OF
BEING A GOOD LEADER AND A
MANAGER OF A DEPARTMENT IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT TOP OF THAT
THAT THAT THAT THAT ANY AGENCY
THEIR LEADING IS. IS WORKING.
HI AND ON A FUNDAMENTAL LEVEL-
AND SO I THINK THAT'S A-
CLEARED THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT IS ABUNDANTLY CLEAR NOW I
ALSO SAID I WILL WILL. OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT THE PANDEMIC
THEY CREATE CHALLENGES. TO THE
ORGANIZATION BUT AS WE SEE AS
WE'VE SEEN IN OTHER AGENCIES
AND DISTANCE TO SOCIETY IN
GENERAL THE PANDEMIC ALSO
REVEALS STRUCTURAL ISSUES THAT
EXISTED. AND SEVEN READING THE
AUDIT THAT CAME OUT TODAY-
COMMITTEE EIGHT PRETTY MUCH
BEEN A STATED THAT THE E. D.
HAS HASBEEN AWARE OF THE
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES AND
ISSUES FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS
DO YOU DISPUTE OR DOES YOUR
BILL FIFTEEN DISPUTE ANY OF THE
FINDINGS OF THE OF THE AUDIT.
THAT WAS RELEASED TODAY AND ARE
YOU PREPARED TO- IMPLEMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE HIGH. IT
WAS MY UNDERSTANDING CHAIRWOMAN
HAD WANTED TO HOLD QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE ARCTIC UNTIL THE CAR.
UNTIL THE NEXT HEARING THAT'S
THAT'S DEL NOT THE CASE THEN I
WILL RESPOND. I APOLOGIZE I
WILL I STEPPED OUT FOR A
HEARING THAT MEETING SO IF
THAT'S THE CASE- I CERTAINLY
APOLOGIZE- AND I WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT THAT ANSWERED
THE NEXT HEARING BUT I GUESS
MAYBE YOU CAN GIVE ME A BRIEF
PREVIEW IN TERMS OF DEAL WITH.
THAT WELL. THIS IS WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU WHAT IN ORDER TO THE
CHAIR. I WOULD SAY. BY STIR
FONG YOUR QUESTION IS TOTALLY
LEGITIMATE THERE WILL BE
ANOTHER HEARING I BELIEVE THIS
THURSDAY. THAT WILL BE. AS
AMERICA NEXT WEEK THAT WILL
WRITE DIVE DEEPER INTO THE
AUDIT OF TODAY SO THAT GIVES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYONE TO
REVIEW. BUT MISS SIGNS YOU ARE
WELCOME TO GIVE REMARKS AND IN
TERMS OF THE QUESTION POST.
OKAY I AM LOOKING FOR EVERY
SOURCE OF IMPROVEMENT OF EDT.
HELLO ANALYTICAL
RECOMMENDATIONS. FROM THE
AUDITOR I'M GOING TO TAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. HELLO TO TAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM OUR STAFF
AND PROMOTE CLAIMANTS. WHAT YOU
WILL FIND IN ME IS
RECEPTIVENESS. AND SO I JUST
HAVE TO TWO LAST QUESTIONS THEN
AND I WILL- CONCLUDES- IN TERMS
OF AND I APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWER
AND- AND I KNOW AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEED FOR THE D.
TO SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE. OUT
IN TERMS OF YOUR CUSTOMER
SERVICE TRAINING- I WE HEAR
FROM CONSTITUENTS JUST IN IN
GENERAL ABOUT. THAT THE
FRUSTRATION OF THIS THE
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN I KNOW
IT'S A TENSE SITUATION.
EVERYONE IS OVERWORKED AND
THERE'S A LOT OF- ANXIETY WHO
OVERSEES THE CUSTOMER SERVICE
TRAINING OF THOSE AT THAT ARE.
WORKING AT WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS IS THAT AN
INTERNALLY IS THAT DONE. IT IS
IT DO OUTSIDE. INDIVIDUALS OR
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS ASSESS HOW
DOES THAT WORK. CAROL. THIS IS
CAROL WILLIAMS THE OF THE
TRAINING IS PROVIDED-
INTERNALLY AFTER EATING. OKAY
SO THAT'S DONE TO IT THAN
INTERNALLY IT'S THE SO YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A DEPARTMENT OR YOU
HAVE A INDIVIDUAL CORRECT
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH YES CORRECT AND- YOU KNOW
IT'S- SEVERAL WEEKS. FOR-
CERTAIN STAFF IN THIRTEEN WEEKS
FOR THE MOST EXPERIENCED STAFF
THAT WE NEED HER AND THEN IN
TERMS OF- I KNOW THAT IN TERMS
OF THE FOR THE CURE OF THE
FRAUD THAT WE WORK WE'RE TRYING
TO KIND OF GRAPPLE WITH AND THE
EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM I KNOW
THAT YOU BROUGHT AND-
ADDITIONAL. SCREENING AN
ADDITIONAL HELP- AND YOU'VE
ALSO OF COURSE MAKE AMERICA IS
PROVIDING- SOME FRONT END OF
FRAUD DETECTION AS WELL BUT IN
TERMS OF YOUR ORGANIZATION%
WITHIN THE D. HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK IN THE
FRAUD DEPARTMENT. OR AN
ORGANIZATION. THAT COORDINATES
AND WORKS WITH WITH WITH THE
YOU KNOW UP WITH. WITH THE BANK
AMERICA AND THOMSON REUTERS
WHOSE COURTNEY THAT HOW MANY
PEOPLE ACCORDING. SENATE SO WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEEDED
VARIES WITH EDT- WE HAVE- TWO
SEPARATE DEPARTMENTS WE HAVE AN
INTEGRITY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
DEPARTMENT THAT FALLS UNDER THE
U. Y. AND WE ALSO HAVE-
INVESTIGATIONS DEPARTMENT- AND
SO I'M NOT AND- THE
INVESTIGATIONS DEPARTMENT HAS-
SEVENTEEN INVESTIGATORS
CURRENTLY. THERE ARE- A FEW
VACANCIES THERE. AND THEY THEY
WORK WITH LET THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO INVESTIGATE-
YOU KNOW TOOK THEY WORK WITH
THEM TO PROVIDE INFORMATION XIN
AND THEY IN INVESTIGATE CLAIMS
INTERNALLY IT EDT SEPTEMBER
USING CAL O. S. TASK FORCE AND
SEVERAL OTHER DEPARTMENTS TO
SUPPORTERS ENOUGH WHAT WE'RE
DOING. OKAY THE SERVICE I
UNDERSTAND SO SEVENTEEN AND
INVESTIGATIONS UNIT WITH
ASSISTANCE FROM CALLER YES AND
THEN HOW MANY WOULD BE IN THE
INTEGRITY DEPARTMENT. I AM NOT
SURE OF THAT NUMBER WOULD LOVE
TO CHECK OUT I WOULD SAY SIX
HUNDRED BUT I'D LOVE TO CHECK
AND GET BACK TO YOU. SIX
HUNDRED. OKAY YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THAT'S THAT'S AN AREA
I I'M I'M I'M GOING TO. PRESUME
THAT- WILL BE RE EVALUATED AND-
AND IN TERMS OF ITS
EFFECTIVENESS AND HELP ITS
ROBUSTNESS- IN TERMS OF
COORDINATING EVERYTHING- YOU
KNOW. AS WE CAN SEE THE EXTENT
OF THE FRAUD IS. I MEAN IS A
STAGGERING TWENTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. AND AS AS AS AS I
GUESS THAT'S THE NUMBER RIGHT
NOW AND CONTINUES TO GROW I
GUESS. EACH TIME THERE SEEMS TO
BE- MORE ATTENTION TO IT- LET
ME JUST END BY SAYING THAT- AS
AS MY COLLEAGUE MISTER NAZARIAN
SAID I DO BELIEVE THAT. IF YOU
WANT TO. KIND OF SUMMARIZE I
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE THREE
FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS OR STRUCTURAL
ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED. FIRST IS. MANAGEMENT
CULTURE. SECONDLY IS PROCESS
AND SYSTEMS AND THIRD IS
TECHNOLOGY AND- AND OF COURSE
THERE'S A NUMBER OF AREAS AND
ISSUES WITHIN THOSE THREE-
BROAD. AREAS BUT- YUP I THINK
TIME'S RUN OUT FOR ALL THE
EXCUSES. AND AND ARE
CONSTITUENTS OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS ARE UPSET WERE UPSET
AND FRUSTRATED I KNOW YOU ARE
UPSET- AND SO- WHAT WE WERE
GONNA HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE AND-
AND THERE'S AND THE BUCK STOPS
WITH YOU GUYS. AND SO I DO
APPRECIATE- YOU BEING HERE AND
TESTIFYING AND I IN YOUR
ANSWERS- PATIENCE IS RUNNING
OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND AGAIN-
THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE FOLKS
THAT HAVE BEEN. WAITING IN THE
QUEUE- I DO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL JUST RIP SOME RAPID
FIRE QUESTIONS BOTH FOR- D. D.
D. AS WELL AS- BANK OF AMERICA.
SO I'LL START WITH BANK OF
AMERICA AND JUST EXPRESS YOU
KNOW BANK OF AMERICA CUSTOMERS
GET A TEXT MESSAGE OR AN EMAIL
ALERT WHEN THEIR CARD NUMBERS
USE WITHOUT A CAR PRESIDENT OR
WHEN THEY DETECT SOME KIND OF
FRAUD. BUT AND EIGHTY DB OF A
CUSTOMER DOES NOT WHY DOES THE
TYPICAL V. OF A CUSTOMER GET AN
ALERT- IF THEIR CARD IS BEING
USED IN ANOTHER STATE OR
OVERSEAS. BUT COST BUT EDT
CUSTOMERS GET THEIR ACCOUNTS
FROZEN FROZEN AT A RATE OF
FIFTY THOUSAND PER MONTH- THAT
ARE BEING UNFROZEN WITH FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO GO WHAT IS
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS HEARING.
THAT THIS WILL BE RESOLVED.
WELL WE ARE. THE SINGLE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE IS THAT WE DON'T
POSSESS. CELL PHONE NUMBERS OR
EMAIL ADDRESSES FOR A
SIGNIFICANT PROPORTION. IT'S
NOT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
CLAIMANTS TO WHOM WE ARE
SENDING PREPAID CARDS- OTHER
PROGRAMS OF OTHER STATES WHERE
WE DO HAVE. CELL CELL PHONE
NUMBERS OR EMAIL ADDRESSES AND
WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE
NOTIFICATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT THAT'S INCREDIBLY
INSIGHTFUL ADVENTURE A SMALL
LITTLE FACT THAT CAN MAKE THE
TWO HUGE DIFFERENT. AS THE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION FOR EDS WHAT
IS A COLLABORATION THAT CAN
CHANGE FROM THE DEPARTMENT FROM
EDT WITH BANK OF AMERICA TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE. BASIC CONTACT
INFORMATION SO THE BANK OF
AMERICA CAN ALERT. UP
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE DEBIT CARDS
MAY POTENTIALLY BE FROZEN DUE
TO FRAUD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER- NEED
TO VARIOUS WITH EDT- WE CAN WE
WILL WE CAN DEFINITELY WORK
WITH BANK OF AMERICA TO PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD I DO
KNOW THAT IT IS NOT REQUIRED TO
HAVE AN EMAIL ADDRESS TO APPLY
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS- I AM
NOT. SURE ON THE CELL PHONE
NUMBER BUT I DO KNOW THAT- YOU
DO NOT HAVE TO HAVE AN EMAIL
ADDRESS. TO APPLY FOR BENEFITS-
BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY WORK WITH
BANK OF AMERICA. YOU KNOW SHARE
WHATEVER INFORMATION WE DO HAVE
THAT IS ALLOWED. THANK YOU- I
THINK THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PLACE IN TERMS OF TWO
DIFFERENT. THE DEPARTMENT
VERSES ANNOUNCED A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION TO BE ABLE TO AT
LEAST COMMUNICATE WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE EXPECTING
THEIR CARDS TO WORK. I THINK
THAT'S POTENTIALLY A SOLUTION
THAT WE CAN WORK ON RIGHT AWAY.
I'M ADDITIONALLY A. R. MY
QUESTION IS- IN REGARDS TO
TRAINING BOTH FOR EDT AS WELL
AS- A BANK OF AMERICA. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN HIRED AT EDT WHAT IS THIRD
WHAT IS THE PROCESS OF THEIR
TRAINING AND HOW DO THEY GET
TRAINED. SAME QUESTION FOR BANK
OF AMERICA I MY IN THE POINT
THAT I'M TRYING TO MAKE I WANT
TO KNOW IF THEY UNDERSTAND.
YOU'RE NOT JUST IN A JOB
PROCESSING CLAIMS. THIS IS A
PANDEMIC THAT IS IMPACTING
PEOPLE'S LIVES. HOW IS THAT
WORKING. SO FOR ATV WE I THANK
JOURNAL EARLY WE HAVE RESUMES
TRAINING- THAT MAY THROUGH
NOVEMBER WE HAVE HIRED ON
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW THAT'S
BECAUSE WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
ATTRITION THREE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES WE ARE HIRING NOT
NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
ADDITIONAL PLOYS FEBRUARY
THROUGH APRIL ALL OF THEM
CONTRIBUTE TO CLAIM FILING AND
RESOLUTION BE MORE ADVANCED
FOLKS THERE THE AT BAT BUT
CLING COOPER- BUT IT'S- STAY IN
TRAINING ABOUT THIRTEEN WEEKS
VANCE WORKLOADS AND SUCH AND
OUR OFFICE TECHNICIANS TRAIN
FOR ABOUT TWO TO THREE WEEKS.
JUST ON CLAIM FILING BUT THEY
ALSO ARE THE GROUP THAT MAKES
THE- OUTBOUND CALLS TO CLAIM
ITS REGARDING- THE NEED TO
RECERTIFY THEIR CLAIMS EVERY
OTHER WEEK SO I HOPE THAT THE
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. AND THE
OTHER. SO WE'VE WE'VE HIRED
SEVERAL THOUSAND PEOPLE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ACROSS ALL
ELEMENTS OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT-
CONTRACT. WELL WHAT WE'VE DONE
AND WE HAVE WE HAVE AN IN DEPTH
TRAINING MOCK MODEL FOR ALL
THOSE PEOPLE DEPENDING ON WHICH
ASPECTS OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO BE
INVOLVED IN. WHAT I CAN ASSURE
YOU IS THAT WE HAVE A MODEL
WHERE THE MOST EXPERIENCED
PEOPLE WE CAN TRACK THEM BY THE
TIME OF SERVICE- AND BY
TRACKING VIA COMPLEXITY FOR THE
COMPLEX NATURE OF THE CASE
ADULT. MOST EXPERIENCED PEOPLE
ARE THE ONES WERE ASSIGNED THE
MOST COMPLEX CASES WHETHER IT'S
BROUGHT FIVE MEDICATIONS OR
CLAIMS RESOLUTION AND SO WE ARE
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT-
EXPERIENCED AGENTS AND
EXPERIENCE SALAS WITH ONES WERE
ASSIGNED TO THE MOST DIFFICULT.
ASPECTS OF THE SITUATION WE
FIND OURSELVES IN. THANK YOU
FOR THAT IN THIS IS A FOLLOW UP
AND COMPLETELY COMING FROM A
DIFFERENT SPACE BUT- AS I
SHARED IN MY OPENING REMARKS.
WE HAVE HAD- RESIDENTS OF MY
COMMUNITY THAT HAVE FALLS WITH
INCREDIBLE ANXIETY ANGST-
TALKING ABOUT SUICIDE AND I'M
SURE THAT. EDT EMPLOYEES HAVE
ALL ALSO HEARD THE SAME ORDER I
WOULD IMAGINE THAT YES AMERICAN
POLICE HAVE ALSO I HEARD THE
SAME. WHAT IS THE TRAINING THAT
YOU'RE OFFERING. YOUR WORKERS
TO BE ABLE TO. COME FROM A
PLACE OF COMPASSION AND
KNOWLEDGE. AND ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL IS AT
THAT LEVEL THERE ARE STEP THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL STEPS THAT NEED
TO BE TAKEN AND I'D I'D BE
CURIOUS TO KNOW. HOW YOUR
PROCESSING THAT KIND OF
TRAINING. ALTHOUGH I'LL GO
FIRST FROM- BANKAMERICA UP. UP
ALL ALL OF OUR- STAFF WHO
INTERACT DIRECTLY WITH.
CLAIMANTS RECEIVE SPECIFIC
TRAINING ON HOW TO IDENTIFY.
AND ESCALATE WHAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED HARDSHIP TYPE OR-
SIMILAR CASES INCLUDING CASES
YOU JUST REFERENCE YOUR
INCLUDING SAUNA AND SPACES THAT
YOU JUST REFERENCED. SO- WE DO
ACTUALLY TAKE NOTE OF IT AND WE
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE RECEIVE
TRAINING SO THAT THEY DON'T
RESPOND TO. EVERY CALL EXACTLY
THE SAME WAY AND WERE ABLE TO-
TRY TO FIND RESOLUTION FOR
CASES WHERE- ASSEMBLY ASPECTS
OF- OUTSIDE THE ISSUES WERE
FACING ARE IDENTIFIED IN THE
CALL SO WE ARE WORK AND STUFF
WE ARE AWARE OF THAT. WATER-
FOCUSED ON IT. THANK YOU CAROL
WILLIAMS ET DATE. FROM DAY ONE
OF TRAINING- OUR FOLKS. ARE NEW
HIRES UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE
THE FACING FRONT LINE OF E. D.
THEIR JOBS ARE DIFFICULT AND
MANY ENTERING ALREADY
UNDERSTAND THE- DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS- CLAIMANTS ARE IN.
THAT THEY WILL NOW NEED TO
RESPOND TO WE ABSOLUTELY
PROVIDE TRAINING IN THE ON THE
TERMS OF LISTENING- SB
COMPASSIONATE BEING THOUGHTFUL
AND THOSE ARE JUST THE BASIC
KEY TOOLS THAT. YOU KNOW TEND
TO BE ESCALATE BUT TYPICALLY-
pHEARD AND THE- AND VALIDATED-
AS WE PROCEED TO RESOLVE THE
SITUATION BUT THE TRAINING IS
ABSOLUTELY PROVIDED AND
REFRESHER TRAINING IS SOMETHING
THAT I WILL LOOK INTO. THANK
YOU FOR THAT I AND I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR BEING HERE AND OF
COURSE ALL OF YOU THE PANELISTS
FOR. A IN DURING THIS VERY
PROVOCATIVE AND I THINK VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AROUND
EDT BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY HOW WE
ARE GOING TO FIND. SOLUTIONS
LET'S THAT LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES THEA IF WE CAN OPEN
UP. PUBLIC COMMENTS- AND WE CAN
START TAKING SOME QUESTIONS
FROM A INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
BEEN PATIENTLY WAITING. ON THE
PHONE. LET ME THINK. MAYBE EVEN
JOHN AMENITY WISH TO COMMENT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN ONE
THEN ZERO. I NEED HAVE ABOUT
FOURTEEN IN THE QUEUE. WELL
FIRST RELYING TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ERIN PACKED FOR THE EASILY OF
CALIFORNIA- CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
URGES EDT TO EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF LANGUAGE SPECIFIC PROBLEM
LYING. AND REPRESSION
INTERPRETERS ARE INSURED REAL
TIME SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. EATING URGENT
SUPPORT FROM THE EDT. TAP INTO
WITH CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED
LINGUISTICS MUST BE TRAINED AND
ALSO UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE
THOSE SERVICES. THE HIGH LEVEL
OF CUSTOMER SERVICE THANK YOU.
NEXTONE MULTILINE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU YES WE CAN'T. HI
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MANAGED TO SOME AMOUNT
BUT THEN ON THE POLICY THAT THE
THING THAT YOU'RE FOR THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA OFFICE. OF THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS- THE UNITED STATES
LARGEST LOCAL CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION I'M HERE ON BEHALF
CARE CALIFORNIA AND CARE
SACRAMENTO'S URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT REAL TIME
ACCESS TO LANGUAGE AND
TRANSLATION SERVICES BY THE EDT
FOR CALIFORNIANS. WHOSE FIRST
LANGUAGE IS NOT ENGLISH THIS IS
BECOMING A MORE AND MORE
PREVALENT AN URGENT ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE NIPPED IN THE BUD
AS MORE AND MORE CALIFORNIANS
ARE BEING TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF BY
THIRD PARTIES THAT EXPLOIT
THEIR LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF
THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE IN ORDER
TO ROB THEM OF THEIR DATE. IT'S
NOT ENOUGH THAT CALIFORNIANS
ARE NOT PROFICIENT OR NOT
PROFICIENT ENGLISH MUST WAIT
FOUR TO SIX WEEKS WITHOUT
INCOME IN ORDER TO JUST GET A.
CALL BACK IN A LANGUAGE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND. WE'RE
EXPERIENCING A MORE VETERANS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS IN OVER.
WHICH IS OVER FROM THE RIGHT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INTO OTHER
AREAS OF LIFE. IN CALIFORNIA
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO RISK BEING
VICTIMS OF FRAUD. OR LIVING
WEEKS TO MONTHS WITHOUT AN
INCOME OR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BECAUSE OF THEIR LACK
OF ENGLISH CRICKET PROFICIENCY.
AGAIN I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
REAL TIME ON DEMAND OVER THE
PHONE INTERPRETING BY TRAIN EDT
STAFF. AND INVEST IN THAT. FOR
THESE CALIFORNIANS WHO LIKE ALL
OF US ARE JUST TRYING TO
SURVIVE THE- TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND AGAIN
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION PUBLIC
COMMENT IS ONE MINUTE THANK YOU.
MAXIMO FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JENNA
CASSIDY AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION AND I JUST WANT TO
ECHO THAT CALL ON THE DVD TO
TAKE AN APPROACH THAT IS THE
LANGUAGE STAFF THAT THE
APPROACH FOR- CLAIMANTS AND IT
DOES HAVE TO BE ON THE PHONE
AND IN MORE LANGUAGES THAN
ENGLISH AND SPANISH AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT.
I'M HEARING TODAY ON THAT THANK
YOU. MAX FOR MORE PHOTO LINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MATTER CHAIRMAN LOOKING-
MY NAME IS CHINA AB FROM FOR
ACTION AND I TRAINED CUSTOMER
FROM YEAH FROM TAMPA TO ON THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS AREAS THAT SHE-
IN MARCH TWENTY- I THOUGHT
EMERGED TWENTY I LAID OFF PATEL
HOW. C. A. HELP ME APPLY FOR
YOU ARE YOU THE PAPER FORM FROM
EMPLOYER BUT IT'S ONL IN
ENGLISH I TRIED CALLING EDT ME
FROM MYSELF TIMES A WEEK WE
OVER WITHOUT EVER GET CONNECTED.
NUMBER TWENTY TWO MATCH THAN A
STOCK I ONLY RECEIVED A SINGLE
D. G. CONFUSINGLY IN FAN
EXPEDITED AND A COUPLE BE A
CONTACT THE EACH OF THE TO THE
IN ENGLISH THAT HELPING TREND
EDT LETTER WRONG DENY HE SAID
AT AN YOU A I NEEDED TO WRITE
AN ENGLISH KILLER. NOW MY
ACCOUNT IS SPEND IT I THERE BUT-
IDEAS ALL IN ENGLISH AND ON HAD
ENGLISH COURSE CONSTRUCTION. HI
THERE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
VAN AND I'M A COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE WITH CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. I WILL
INTERPRET THE TESTIMONY GIVEN
BY CHOICE LEE. WHO IS STILL
ABLE TO RECEIVE THE CORRECT
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT AMOUNT
BECAUSE OF LANGUAGE ACCESS TO
CARRIERS. AYE YI. OKAY YOUR MOM
AND YOUR UNANIMOUS SPENDING UP
AS THE A YEMENI COMMANDER TOM
NOT CLOSING DOWN ALL THAT FOR
YOU I'M NOT. YOU KNOW WHAT THE
AT THE COMPLIMENTS FOR YOU
THOUGHT HE STOPPED. ALL OF THE
MARVEL USING CORPORATE
GOVERNMENTAL YOU CANNOT ABOUT
BONTA. FOUNDED THE MY AT THE
RIGHT TIME HOME TO ONE DOLLAR
BILLION SOMEONE UNION THE
FORMER WITHOUT. HI EVERYONE
MONEY IS DORIS AND SAMPLES. MY
FOR INCOME CAL BECAUSE OF THE
TYPE DURING THE INITIAL. I CALL
THE TIME TRANSLATION VERY TIMES
FOR LONG HOURS TRYING TO. AT
THE- TO OF MY- ENGLISH
PROFESSOR. ENGLISH IS A-
HOWEVER I NEVER ONE RECEIVED A
RESPONSE TO A CALL BACK. ARE
YOU EATING FROM WHAT. ACT BONTA
LACKS SO THEN THE WHOLE BAG IN
NUMBER THING UP WHEN YOU'RE-
HIM- THIRTY BOWMAN OKAY GOING
SOMEONE THINGS THEY HAVE ONE
YOUR TOTAL. UNION MEN WHAT THEY
KNOW OKAY I CAN IT ALL YOU
MIGHT. BUT THEN I GOT. BECAUSE
OF. THE OF THE LANGUAGE.
BARRIERS AND CHALLENGES. THIS
PROCESS GAVE ME. IN DISTRESS
AND FINER BURDEN. I HOPE THAT
YOU DO DO YOU PROVIDE THEM THE-
LANGUAGE SERVICES AND
INTERPRETATION. TO RESOLVE MY
PROBLEM. I HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF
MY THREE CHILDREN AND YOU AYE
IS NOT ONLY FINANCIAL SUPPORT
DURING THIS TIME OF EMPLOYMENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM LIM
ONLINE FORTY THANK LET ME JUST
MAKE A COMMENT THAT. WE WILL
ALWAYS MAKE TIME FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT SPEAK A
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE AND REQUIRED
TRANSLATION THANK YOU LET'S
CONTINUE. ENACT A MOTEL NINE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
LINE MAY BE NEEDED. HELLO FORTY
SIX ALL RIGHT MAXIMO TIMELINE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS A MUSLIM AND I'M A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE FOR THE
TITANS WHICH CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION. I'M
CONFLICTING TESTIMONY FROM
INSTALLATION FONG FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND WHITE GOOGLE
TRANSLATE IS INSUFFICIENT FOR
MONOLINGUAL COMMUNITIES. AND
WHITE EDT SHOULD HAVE
FLEXIBILITY TO WORK WITH
MULTIPLE PARTNERS TO SERVE SUIT
SIMILAR LANGUAGE GROUPS HIS
TESTIMONY IS AS FOLLOWS. I WAS
FOLLOWED FROM MECHANICAL JOBS.
IN APRIL TWENTY TWENTY AND CUT
FOR TWO WEEKS TO CALL EDT TO
APPLY FOR YOU AYE. BUT I WAS
UNABLE TO GET TO I WAS REFERRED
TO SEE A AND FINALLY MANAGED TO
TWENTY. MY LIMITED ENGLISH AND
COMPUTER ELECTRICITY WAS A
BARRIER TO ACCESSING EDP
BENEFITS I'M SIXTY YEARS OLD
IMMIGRATED TO THE U. S. IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE AND SPEAK ONLY
PROTECTIONIST LANGUAGE HI
SUNLAND DIALECT OF CHINESE.
SKEWS ME WHICH IT DOES NOT
PROVIDE SERVICES IN. I DON'T
USE A COMPUTER AND CANNOT READ
HE D. D. CORRESPONDENCES SENT
IN ENGLISH I READ LIGHT ON
FRIENDS AND C. H. HELP TO
CERTIFY FOR BENEFITS. MY U.
EYES NO SUSPENDED AND I NEED
THE MONEY TO STAY IN MY HOME
FAILING WHICH MY FAMILY WILL BE
EFFECTED. THE DIGITAL BAY AREA
AND LANGUAGE BARRIERS I FACE IN
ACCESSING BENEFITS HAS MADE MY
LIFE VERY STRESSFUL. AND
DIFFICULT THANK YOU. WELL NOW
MOVES TO LINE SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
JESSICA MAGDALENO ASSEMBLY
HISPANIC JEFFERSON FOR THE HOT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FAMILIES OUT
THERE AND I WAS. NUMBER FOUNDER
OF FOUNDED BUSINESS BEING. IN I
AM CALLING YOU TODAY ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO INVOICE IS NOT THEIR
FIRST LANGUAGE. ONE VERY CALL.
THE CLAIM IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY HAVE IF
YOU. WELL I'M GLAD YOU DID THE-
TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
LANGUAGES IF YOU THINK ONLINE
AND PROFESSIONAL PHONE LINE FOR
INTERPRETERS. TO ENSURE WE ALL
THE TIME BEFORE ALSO THEY ARE
SLEEPING. ANOTHER SIGN WAITING.
THREE HAVE BEEN OF THIS.
SACRAMENTO NINE THEM. PROVIDERS
WAITING AND NOW WE'RE MORE ON
BEING. FOR INTERVIEW THANK SHOW
THEIR- AND OTHER ITEMS WILL. TO
TAKE BEACH. ALSO WANTED TO ASK
YOU. AB DE MOVEMENT DOCTOR
STOCK IN THE LAST WITH FANS.
HAVE BEEN WITH THE SUPPORT OF
BREAKING AND NUMBER HOW TO DO
THOSE SERVICES IN THE BARBARA
STARR. FIVE IT HAS FOUGHT THE
MARCEL THAT IS VERY FOR US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS WELL AGAIN JUST A
GENTLE REMINDER THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT IS ONE MINUTE. MAXWELL
MORE CLIENTS SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BARBARA
GIVEAWAY ON THE COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE WITH CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION I'LL BE
TRAVELING TESTIMONY FROM MR
YEAR WHO'S THE SAN FRANCISCO
RESIDENT- SO I IMMIGRATED TO
THE U. S. OVER THIRTY YEARS AGO
AND CURRENTLY LIVE WITH MY WIFE
IN A SINGLE RESIDENT OCCUPANCY
LOW INCOME GROUP HOUSING UNIT
IN CHINATOWN. I WORKED AS A
COOK BUT I LOST MY JOB GOT
BECAUSE THE KOBE I EVENTUALLY
APPLIED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE WITH HELP FROM
FRIENDS WHO HAVE BETTER ENGLISH
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T PROVIDE
LANGUAGE AFFECT MY CLAIM WITH
THE EXPANDED IN DECEMBER AND WE
DIDN'T KNOW WHY. AND I DIDN'T
KNOW WHERE TO GO FOR MORE
INFORMATION AND I'M THINKING OF
ACTION AT THE END OF THIS MONTH
BECAUSE OF DELAYS IN BACK
PAYMENT I CALLED THE EIGHT FOR
HELP LAST WEEK AND EXPLAINED
THAT I HAD A PHYSICAL EMAIL IN
MY U. I. INBOX NOTIFYING ME IN
ENGLISH BUT MY ACCOUNT WITH THE
FENDED FOR ID VERIFICATION. THE
EIGHT THEN HELP ME TO COMPLETE
THE PROCESS BECAUSE THE PRODUCT
IS ONLY AVAILABLE IN ENGLISH
HOWEVER MY UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS HAVE NOT WITHIN THAT
DELAYS IN MY APPLICATION DUE TO
LANGUAGE BARRIERS HAVE CAUGHT
ME MANY FINANCIAL BURDEN AS
WHITE PAINTED STORY ILLUSTRATES
THE NEED FOR EASY TO GET TIMELY
TRANSLATED WRITTEN INFORMATION
TO NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
CALIFORNIANS DON'T TAKE ON.
ADDITIONAL DEBT AND HARDSHIP
THANK YOU. MAXIMUM OF. SEVENTY
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM MY NAME IS FOX TANG-
TEMPERANCE KALRA THOUSAND OF
TELL EXPERTS- A YEAH MIKE. AND
FOR THEIR EQUITY RATIO EQUITY
AND THE LENGTH ACT FALTER-
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
COMMUNITY MEMBER- I WORK IN
THAT TIME BUDGET CALL ON ABOUT
HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY- WE NEED
WHAT WE DO- WE HAVE THE
LANGUAGE HI- TO DO THE
INTERPRETATION AND- AND- IT TO
A BALL AND- AND WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE A PALM IN
THE MULTIPLE LANGUAGE CHINESE.
VIETNAMESE RUSSIAN. IN ALL THAT
I DO- YEAH THERE'S SHOULD HAVE
WE SAW SOME DOING. THANK YOU
VERY. I IN MAXIMO LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. HELLO YES WE CAN OKAY
THANK YOU BUT MANY WOULD BE
STAYING ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CHICANO
MOVEMENT WE WORK IN THE FIFTEEN
COUNTIES AROUND CALIFORNIA FROM
KERN UP TO FATTER PROFIT THE
BAY WE WORK LARGELY THE PW SIX
UNITY UNDER THE QUICKLY TO
COMMENT ON TO THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED TODAY- ONE AND I
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TOLD ME TO COUNTY SPECIALLY BIG
AMERICAN E. D. D. BUT A LOT OF
THE HUNDRED MAYBE EVEN THERE IN
FRONT OF US- ORGANIZATIONS PPO
TV THE EYES LITERALLY WENT
FROM. ZERO TO TEN THAT'S NOT
HUNDRED OF MILLION DOLLARS IN
IN PROVIDING RESOURCES TO THE
MOST HE DOES THE MOST NEED IN
CALIFORNIA VERY VERY QUICKLY
WITHOUT ANY OF THE ABOVE FROM
THE CONCERNED IN THE FRAUDULENT
SPELL THAT WE'VE SEEN IN OTHER
AREAS BUT THAT BEEN BROUGHT UP
TODAY AND- AGAIN JUST WANT TO
REITERATE IN TERMS OF THE-
LANGUAGE PIECE YOU KNOW EDV
HAVE THE CONTRACT WITH A GROUP
OF THE FROM THERE- WHEN THE
DOCTOR KLEIN COLD ONE STOP
TRANSLATION YOUR APARTMENT
ADVISED THE PLEASE. WRAP UP
THEIR CRY. WILL GUIDE BY THE-
COMMITTEE TO LOOK INTO THAT
BECAUSE- TO GET BETTER. A OF.
OUR REPUBLICAN WHICH IS HOW THE
RIVER BEING SIR. ON W. ONE OF
THE MOST. FROM MY- COUNTERPARTS
THAT ARE WORK WITH THE MUSIC
COMMITTEE. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. AMEX MULTILINE FORTIETH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS NAME IS
THE THOUGHT YOUNGER GET IT
BEFELL WITH THE AT WORK A NINE
WE TERRORISTS ARE ADVOCATES FOR
THE RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIANS LOW
INCOME WORKING FAMILIES I'M
CALLING TODAY TO VOICE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE EDT PRIORITIZE
LANGUAGE BECAUSE IN THEIR
PROGRAM APPLICATION. FOR
PIPELINE FOR LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY VIDAK OLDER MANY
TIMES INSURMOUNTABLE WE
RECENTLY SPOKE DIFFERENT
VEHICLE A MONOLINGUAL SPANISH
SPEAKER WELCOME TO TELL THE
PAST YEAR. ANDTRY TO COLLECTED
PAID FAMILY LEAVE BENEFIT. HE'S
GOT TRIED TO CALL EAST HELP GET
WAS UNABLE CONNECT ANYONE WHEN
YOU GET WITH SOMEONE EIGHT. AM
EDT REPRESENTATIVE THE ABRUPTLY
HUNG UP ON HIM AS A
REPRESENTATIVE ONLY SPOKE
ENGLISH. WITHOUT ANY LITERACY
TO FOB APPLICATIONS ON HIS
AFFECTED WE DO NINE IS RIGHT
THE BENEFIT THAT HE PAID INTO.
UNFORTUNATELY TWENTY FOUR HE
ACTUATION IS NOT UNIQUE. RATHER
PRACTICAL SITUATION IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF HOW THE EDT THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE ACCESS
PROCEDURES ARE FAILING
CALIFORNIA'S LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT COMMUNITY. GETTING
AND THE IDEAS ALAMEDA
APPLICATIONS TRANSLATE INTO
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES PROVIDING
NOTICES IN THE SEVEN NAY
LANGUAGE IS OUR TOP. PRIORITY I
APPRECIATE THE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK FOR THAT NEXT CALLER. IN
FACT HOME OF THE LINE SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
MEMBERS CATALINA DENTURE THE
CORPORATE ANTI THERE
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CENTER PROBLEM THE
DVD UNEMPLOYMENT CARD HIGHLIGHT
THAT CALIFORNIA CATCH UP WITH
WHAT ALMOST EVERY OTHER STATE
IS DOING GIVE PEOPLE A CHOICE
OF RECEIVING THEIR BENEFITS BY
DIRECT DEPOSIT TO THEIR
UNBANKED FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A CHOICE IN
HOW THEY WOULD BE BENEFITS THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD OFFER A REAL
CHOICE AND THAT ONLY AN EDT
CARD OR A PAPER CHECK OPTION.
AND HE'LL BE WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE IN AB SEVENTY FOUR TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIANS WHO DO
NOT WANT THEIR BENEFITS ON AN
EBT CARD HAVE A REAL CHOICE
OTHER THAN ACCEPTING A DELAY OF
BENEFITS BY UP TO TEN DAYS. SB
ALBEIT FURTHER CONCERNED ABOUT
REPORTS THAT CLAIMANTS WHO HAVE
RAISED IT LEGITIMATE SOUNDING
DISPUTE ABOUT UNAUTHORIZED
CHARGES TAKEN OUT OF THEIR
ACCOUNTS HAVE HAD THOSE ISSUES
RAPIDLY REJECTED WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS POSSIBLY WITHOUT THE
REASONABLE AND APPROPRIATE
INVESTIGATION AS REQUIRED.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW. THANK YOU.
MAX SOME OF. SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
NANCY WHY IT I'M THE PUBLIC
POLICY CHAIR FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILY CHILDCARE NETWORK
LICENSE DEDICATED EXPERIENCE
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME
OPERATORS WHO SPEAK LANGUAGES
OTHER THAN ENGLISH ARE HAVING A
TERRIBLE TIME ACCESSING THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
SUCCESSFULLY APPLY FOR EDT
BENEFITS. THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF DIVERSE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ARE GOING UNDER FOR
EVER. THANK YOU. MAXIMO
CAROLINE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KELLY
MCVEIGH I AM AN EMPLOYMENT
RIGHTS ATTORNEY BUT THAT STATIC
LEGAL SERVICES IN LOS ANGELES
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT LANGUAGE
EQUITY FOR CLAIMANTS ON
INCLUDING REAL TIME ACCESS AND
TRAINING AND TRANSLATION OF ALL
EDT MATERIAL. IN OUR PRACTICE
WE'VE COME ACROSS A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS REGARDING LANGUAGE AND
LITERACY ACCESS WITH OUR
CLIENTS AND MANY ARE
UNCOMFORTABLE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND WHEN PAIRED WITH
LANGUAGE ISSUES AND A WEBSITE.
THAT IS ONLY ANY QUESTIONS
SPANISH THE IS CREATED MANY
DIFFICULT FOR KERR. REALLY
REALLY OUR CA CARE MANY ARE
RELYING ON SERVICE TO HELP THEM
FIVE EDT. ANYTHING AMOUNTS OF
MONEY AND- ALWAYS HIGH SIR. WE
HOPE TO THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL
BE BETTER ABLE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE- WHEN WE HAVE BETTER LUCK
ACTS TO ANY EQUITY FROM EDT
THANK YOU. MAXIMO TELLING
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO. THANK
YOU MONEY IS VICTORIA AND I'M
THE THING YOU'RE AT BUT WORKERS
ARE PROGRAM THE ASIAN MARKET
FAILED OF NONPROFIT SERVICE OR
THAT PROVIDES THE LEGAL
PURPOSES TO LOW AND CLEAN.
FRIEDMAN ENGLISH PROFICIENT OR
MONOLINGUAL AND IT ASIAN
LANGUAGE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
WITH BOTH WITH THE BEST WORKERS
BUT UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CLAIMS ON APPEAL SOMETHING
PANDEMIC BUT DEMAND HAS
INCREASED AT LEAST FIFTY PEOPLE
ARE QUITE THE FACE EVERY ISSUE
HE HAS BEEN ON THE CALL ABOUT
IN THE NEWS AND EMPIRE HEARING
BUT IT'S BEEN MADE WORSE BY
THEM AND THE DELAYED MORE
SEVERE BECAUSE OF THE LINK
LANGUAGE BERIA ON TOP OF THOSE
ISSUES AND PROBLEMS. I CAN
PROVIDE SHORT STORY ABOUT MY
CLIENT LIKE MANY CALIFORNIANS
FACE DIRE SITUATION HE'S A
MONOLINGUAL CHINESE WORKER WHO
WAS LAID OFF LAST FEBRUARY HE
APPLY FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE INSURANCE INVOLVED
AND PROVIDED THE REQUIRED
IDENTITY VERIFICATION DOCUMENTS
IN A TIMELY MANNER BUT BY DOING
SO A HEARING WITH THAT AND-
PARKER APPEARED BEFORE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE THE L.
J. ISSUE THE DECISION IN FAVOR
OF THE WORKER AND HE SHOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR BENEFITS. HOWEVER
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME THE
DECISION WILL NOT IMPLEMENTED
THE WORKER FILED TWO COMPLAINTS
AGAINST EACH ONE IN OCTOBER AND
ONE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY HE
DID NOT RECEIVE ANY RESPONSE TO
THE COMPLAINT EVENTUALLY HE WAS
ABLE TO GET A LEGAL COUNSEL LC
AND FOUND OUT THAT THE DECISION
WITH THE EQUIPMENT IT- FEET
OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS AT. THE
TIME TRANSLATING TO LATER ON
CERTIFICATION FORM AND HE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO GET YOU I BENEFIT
IF YOU OVERTHROWING A TYRANT.
IN THE WEEK. AND THE WAY AND
YOU CAN BE USED. TO THE KIND A
BIG. TOLL HIS FAMILY TO. THE
FINANCE. OF THE FULBRIGHT. FOR
HIS FAMILY. TWENTY UTILITY GO
YOU VERY WELL ON RENT PAYMENTS
AND TOOK WITHOUT THE CONNECTED
TO NON PAYMENT. DURING THE GAP
BETWEEN ONE UNEMPLOYED LOT HERE
RECENTLY TO GET THE BENEFIT YES
KEEP IT THE EXTENDED FAMILY AND
FOR. TO BORROW AT THE- TRY AND
STAY. THE RELATIONSHIP HAS
BROKEN. SOMETHING THEN I ASKED
HER FROM HELP HEALTH. LIKE MY
CLIENT WHO HAD TO. IN HER
EARNED BUT BENEFITS. THE TRYING
TO MEDIATE BETWEEN. IF YOU
MARKET IN A- OF. LANGUISH FOR
MINE OKAY TO APPLY FOR AND
CERTIFIED I THOUGHT AND
PROFESSIONAL MY TRIP. THE
INSURANCE TO PAY. THE PORK AND
IT'S- FOR CALIFORNIANS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AGAIN TO THE
CHEN REMINDER PUBLIC COMMON IS
WHY MINUTE. THE MAXIMUM OF
TELLING SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD THAT MADAM CHAIR IN
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE MY IS COPE
QUERY YOU MAY BETTER OF COUNTY
AND EMPLOYEES WE HAVE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS TO OF WORK THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC AS RESTRICTIONS BEGIN
TO LOOSEN ON THE EXPOSURE
CALLED THE NINETEEN INCREASES.
I'M SPEAKING TO THE NEED FOR
EXTENDING EMERGENCY PAID SICK
LEAVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MAXIMO TIME SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I AM NOT OPTIMISTIC
CALIFORNIA WILL BE CONDUCTED IN
HERE THEY THIRTY CALIFORNIA
BEGAN WHICH IS A VERY FINE JOB
MARKET ARABIC AT THE MOMENT
MEXICAN INDIGENOUS LANGUAGES
LIKE MYSTICAL PICKING UP WHAT
THEY CALL IN CALIFORNIA ONE
THING FARMWORKERS AND MEXICAN
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE AND FUND
CHEVY IS THE THIRD MOST SPOKEN
LANGUAGE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
MANY CALIFORNIANS WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO IF YOU I BENEFIT.
WHICH ALLOWS WHICH TECH
INDUSTRY I HAVE A CLIENT WHO
BECAUSE A PRIVATE BUSINESS
EVERY YEAR TO OPEN ARE YOU I
CAME WHEN I THE CULTURE AND
BEING FORTY FIVE DOLLARS EACH
TIME SHOULD THE MINUTE DOCUMENT
OPEN A CRATE OF COMMUNICATE
WITH DIGNITY SHE EXPLAINS AND I
QUOTE I THINK HELP OF THIS
BUSINESS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET AND
BECAUSE THEY KNOW HOW TO USE A
COMPUTER. I CANNOT OPEN MY DO I
ANY OTHER WAY BECAUSE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW TO NAVIGATE THE
ASSISTANT UNQUOTE EACH YEAR HER
BENEFIT AND AFTER A WEEK OR TWO
AND THEN LANGUAGE BERRY HAS
MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO CONTACT
INCLUDING AN WHITE IT IS NOT
COMPLY WITH EXISTING
RECOMMENDED THEREFORE. TO A
COMPLIANCE ISSUE IMMEDIATELY
ONE PROVIDE THREE PROFESSIONAL
INTERPRETING SERVICES IN ALL
LANGUAGES WITHOUT CAUSING
DELAYS TO CONTRACT WITH THE
UNITED STATES AGAIN IS THAT YOU
A PROVIDE QUALIFIED
INTERPRETING COMMON LANGUAGES
AND THIRD PRIORITIZE ACTIVE
LANGUAGE ACCESS TO IMPLANT WITH
IT BY PHONE ON MY THIRD FIFTY
PEOPLE WHO DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
OR ENABLED BE ALRIGHT. THANK
YOU.
FROM LICENSED FAMILY CHILD
CARE HOME. PROVIDERS OR SELF
EMPLOYED. CALIFORNIANS THE
QUESTIONS RECEIVED FOCUSED ON
VARIOUS ISSUES THAT THESE
ESSENTIAL COMMUNITY SERVICE
PROVIDERS COULD NOT FIND THE
ANSWERS TO FROM EDT LANGUAGE
BARRIERS EXIST FOR MANY AND WE
HAVE BUSINESS OWNERSWHO WERE
NOT ABLE TO FILE FOR P. LATE
BECAUSE OF THESE LANGUAGE
BARRIERS. EDT MUST. THE NUMBER
OF THE- LANGUAGE THIS PHONE
LINE AND PROFESSIONAL PHONE
LINE IN. TO IN REAL SUPPORT AN
ASSISTANCE CAL. TODAY I WANT TO
PLEASE I WANT TO PLEASE TO
RECORD OF POSED BY MISSY
SANJANA. LANGUAGE BARRIERS THE
DAY MARK YOUR- I WANT TO THE
TWO MEN FOR THE IN TO
CORRECTION IN THE- SYSTEM. THAT
WILL AFFECT WILL OUT FOR ALL
CAL. THANK YOU. MAX MOVED ON
SEVEN NINE CALL. HI MY NAME IS
BACK THOSE IN UNLESS CAL
EMIGRATE POLICY CENTER OUR
PARTNER THE CONFLICT EFFORTS
AND WORK. ACT THAT GOOGLE
TRANSLATE IF YOU ASK ANY HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT IN A LANGUAGE
COURSE I'LL TELL YOU THAT
GOOGLE CHEN ALONG NOT ADEQUATE
AND SO I WANTED TO AND ELSE
PUBLIC COMMENTS AND ASKING THAT
YOU DO D. X. THEM OF LINK
SPECIFIC FROM MY AND
PROFESSIONAL LINE AND- YOUR
REAL TIME SUPPORT ASSISTANCE-
CAL. MAKE SURE THAT YOU NEED A
HARD FLEXIBLE TO WORK WITH
MULTI PARTNERS TO PROVIDE THE
JACK FOR WRITTEN AND SMALLER
LANGUAGE GROUP AND ENSURE THAT
THE STAFF INTERACTING WITH
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED WITH THE
SUPPORT OUR CHAIN AND UNDER HOW
TO THOSE. AND THE BACK MONTANA
HIGHWAY OF CUTS SERVICE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND FAMILY
COMMUNITY CENTER TO PROVIDE
DIRECT SERVICES TO FAMILIES IN
SANTA ANA. ONE OF MY FAMILY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BUT THE ONLY
OPTION THAT THEY GRIESHOP DO TO
COPE IN NINETEEN. ONLY THREE
NON WORKING WIFE THREE YEAR OLD
TODDLER AND SEVEN YEAR OLD
CHILD ALL RELIED ON THE FULL
INCOME FOR SUPPORT. BECAUSE OF
LIMITED ENGLISH CAPACITY IN THE
CONFLICT LACK OF LANGUAGE
SERVICES AVAILABLE AND HER
BILLION FOR EDT. YOU DO NOT
KNOW THE FAMILY WAS GOING TO
SURVIVE- ONLY BY CHANCE HE
AWARE PRACTICES. HIS FRIENDS.
TOLD HIM OF OUR DEDICATED
CAMBODIAN LANGUAGE STAFF WHO
WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY HIS
ELIGIBLE BENEFITS AND COMPLETED
APPLICATION FOR CALFRESH AND
UNEMPLOYMENT. WITHIN THE NEXT
MONTH HE WAS APPROVED FOR OVER
TWO FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY DOLLARS
PER MONTH AND CALFRESH
BENEFITS. UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
WERE ALSO PROCESS AND HIS
FAMILY WAS ABLE TO READ IT
HERE. THE STORIES ARE COMMON
AMONG HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
IN HARDSHIP COMMUNITIES LIKE
THE CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. TOO OFTEN
MEMBERS LIKE HIM ARE FORGOTTEN
AND- SUCCESS STORY WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT A
TRUSTED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZED ORGANIZATION LIKE THE
CAMBODIAN FAMILY. HOWEVER IT
DOESN'T DEDICATED LANGUAGE
SPECIFIC. PHONE LINE BUT THE
THIRD FOR THE- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THEY WOULD NOT HAVE
DIFFERENT PILOTS. ONE OF MANY
STORIES OF CALL OF HEALTH. WERE
PARKING LOT TO THE- OF. TO THE
LIMIT CONDITION IN ENGLISH. I
WOULD LIKE TO URGE DETERMINE
BEST CREATING INTEREST TO MEET
THE THAT MAY EMERGING IN THE
CALIFORNIANS. IN BUT THE IT'S
GOING YOU. UNLIKE SOME TIMELINE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JAMES DONOVAN THE
PRESIDENT THE GRAMMAR
CONFEDERATION OF LOS ANGELES-
WE REPRESENT THE LARGEST
THERE'S FOUR OF KOREANS LIVING
OUTSIDE OF KOREA AND OVER A
MILLION UNCLEAN AMERICANS.
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA. YOU
THINK IT IS LACK OF CREAM
LANGUAGE ACCESS ARE NOT BROUGH
SUPPORT THE CREATE A STARTED.
CHANNEL THE SOLELY ON EDT
ESTROGEN IN THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE WHICH NOW HAS OVER TWO
MILLION VIEWS AND OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND SUBSCRIBERS. I WAS
HELPING OUT A CLAIMANT WE'RE
NOT ACTUALLY HELPING OUT
CLAIMANTS FROM OVER TWENTY
DIFFERENT STATES THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. AND I WAS SPOKE
WITH MISSISSIPPI LABOR
DEPARTMENT LAST WEEK AND WITHIN
THREE MINUTES AFTER INFORMING
THE OPERATOR THAT THE CLAIMANTS
QUITE PRIMARY LANGUAGES KOREAN
WAS TRANSFERRED TO A CURRENT.
LANGUAGE- TRANSLATOR WITH ABOUT
OF THREE MINUTES. PUBLISHED ON
SERVER- JUST TO. AND TO PUT
NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT NOT PARTY
TRYING SERVICES AND OTHER
LANGUAGES THAN THEN THE ONES
THAT ARE ALREADY. BEING
EMPLOYED BY THAT YOU CAN BE I
THINK IT'S A MUCH. AMERICA NOW
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE AT TIME.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND THANK
YOU TO ALL OF OUR OUR SPEAKERS
AND CALLERS ON THE PUBLIC LINE
WE ARE ABOUT TO WRAP UP THIS
HEARING BUT BEFORE WE DO SO WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MATTER CHOOSE WAS
WAITING TO MAKE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. ON THIS VERY ISSUE
MISTER CHIP. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND THANK ALL THE
ADVOCATES WHO PATIENTLY WAITED.
YOUR TESTIMONY AND KNOW THAT WE
SEE YOU. WE HEAR YOU- AND-
WE'RE ALL COMMITTED TO DOING
THIS WORK- HI I DECIDED AS I
WAS LISTENING TO PULL OUT. THE
DISTRICT TEAM REPORT- THAT WAS
DONE IN SEPTEMBER TO KIND OF
LAY OUT WHAT. DEPARTMENT GIVING
THEM FORWARD AND JUST NOTE I IN
ONE SECTION. IT STATES
INDIVIDUALS WERE NOT FLUENT IN
ENGLISH FACED INSURMOUNTABLE
BARRIERS TO RECEIVING
ASSISTANCE. CLAIMANTS WHO
SPEAKING LANGUAGES OTHER THAN
ENGLISH HAVE A DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TIME. NAVIGATING THE
UNEMPLOYMENT APPLICATION
PROCESS- YOU KNOW FOR ALL THE
THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
AFTERNOON FROM FRAUD TO
BACKLOGS TO OTHER ISSUES AROUND
PROCESS I THINK THIS. ISSUE OF
LANGUAGE ACCESS IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS ALL THE OTHERS I
AND I WANT FOLKS TO KNOW THAT-
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE- ALL OF
THE- ADVOCATES WORKING ON THIS-
WE'VE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH MANY
THE ADVOCATES ARE THINKING
ABOUT WHAT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD. I AND- AND
HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE MORE TO
SAY ABOUT THAT IN THE NEAR
FUTURE- BUT I ALSO WANT TO SAY
HAVING SPOKEN TO THE NEW EDT
THEIR SHIP I KNOW. THEY ARE
ALSO EQUALLY COMMITTED TO THIS
AS WELL SO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH EVERYONE- WE HAVE
TO GET THIS RIGHT- MY HOPE IS
IN THE COMING MONTHS AS FOR
FIXING ALL THE OTHER THINGS WE
NEED TO FIX AROUND EDT. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN TACKLE
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO- WITH SO
MANY CALIFORNIANS SHOT OUT OF
THE SYSTEM. DUE TO LANGUAGE
WE'VE GOT TO DO BETTER. THANK
YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
CHIU OKAY WE ARE ABOUT TO WRAP
UP AND BEFORE WE DO SO I JUST
HAVE SOME. CLOSING REMARKS OF
MY OWN AND I WANT TO THANK OUR
PANELISTS FOR MAKING THE TIME
THAT'S EDT DIRECTOR RITA SIGNS
AND HER TEAM NANCY FERRIS AS
WELL AS CAROL WILLIAMS. CHEST
ALAMO THE PRINCIPLE THE
PRINCIPLE FISCAL AND POLICY
ANALYST WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. FIFTH AHMAD
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF
TRANSACTION SERVICES OF BANK OF
AMERICA AS WELL AS A TEAM. FOR
JOINING TODAY'S ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE FOR OVERSIGHT
HEARING. ON ED'S EMPLOYMENT AND
INSURANCE PROGRAM. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHO JOINED OFF AND
TODAY AND THOSE ARE WERE ALSO
INVITED TO PARTICIPATE. AS WELL
AS OUR WONDERFUL STAFF FOR ALL
OF THEIR HARD WORK. AS I
MENTIONED IN IN MY OWN OPENING
REMARKS AS THE NEW CHAIR OF
THIS BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE. IS
MICHAEL. THAT EDT BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND TRANSPARENT
WITH HOW THE DEPARTMENT WORKS
WHAT CHANGES ARE BEING MADE.
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT NEEDS IN A
IN SUPPORT TO THE WORK BEING
DONE AND ULTIMATELY. HOW WE
HELP MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO WANT. IN THEIR STATE
GOVERNMENT TO SIMPLY FUNCTION.
I WANT TO CLARIFY THE COMMENT
MADE BY MR AHMED REGARDING THE
STATE CONTRACT WITH AT TEAM AND
BANK OF AMERICA. HIS STATEMENT-
INDICATING THAT IF EDT FELT
COMFORTABLE ENSURING THAT
CONTRACT HE WAS OPEN TO TALKING
ABOUT IT. AND SHARING THOSE
DETAILS ABOUT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. HOWEVER THAT
COMMENT IS MOVED. OFF THE
CONTRACTS ARE PUBLIC DOCUMENTS
AND ARE PAID FOR BY HARD
WORKING. CALIFORNIANS WHO PAY
THEIR TAXES AND SO DOT COM AND
THAT DOCUMENT IS ACTUALLY A
PUBLIC DOCUMENT THAT ANYONE CAN
ACCESS AT ANY TIME. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE THAT.
PARTICIPATED TODAY. THIS IS.
ONE OF MANY HEARINGS AND I LOOK